An Mowamex, dem bestrecherchierenden Podcast überhaupt. Wir haben etwas sehr Merkwürdiges aufzuklären.
Etwas sehr Merkwürdiges?
Stellen Sie sich vor.
Im Vorfeld habe ich gehört, dass es das erste 30 Milliarden Umsatzquartal in der Geschichte von Apple wird. Ja, ja, ich habe auch gehört, es könnte auch das erste 40 Milliarden Quartal werden.
Nein, doch.
Apple könnten mit ihrem Bargeld, ohne sich zu verschulden, könnten die BMW und Mercedes kaufen.
Nein, doch. Lass uns lieber ein bisschen furzen, das erleichtert wenigstens.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zack Return.
Tja, damit ist eigentlich schon alles gesagt, finde ich. Weil ist ja eigentlich nichts passiert.
Super, dann klappen wir zusammen und dann gibt's jetzt Nachtisch.
Ja, das ging ja dann auch ganz gut. Vielleicht noch ein Lied zum Schluss? Was fällt uns da ein? Gibt es eigentlich so eine Apple-Hymne?
Eine?
Na, mehr als eine?
Bestimmt.
Was heißt bestimmt? Dir fällt keine Einung, kannst du nicht auswendig? Wie oft singst du deine Apple-Hymne? Nicht etwa mehrmals am Tag?
Ich lasse singen.
So, so.
Siri singt die Hymne.
Automatisiertes Fanboy-Tun. Na großartig. Wo soll das enden?
Aber es gibt doch nur diese etwas über eine Sekunde lange Hymne, dieses...
Stimmt, das könnte das ist die Apple-Hymne. Der Einschalt-Sound.
Das ist doch keine Hymne.
Klar.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie ist diese ganze Apple-Welt... Ich weiß nicht, da gibt es gar nicht so viel Hymnen. Und ich habe immer so den Eindruck, diese anderen Firmen, die spielen die ganze Zeit immer irgendeinen Scheiß. Vieren Konferenzen und so. Weil Steve gab es immer nur Beatles. Was auch so ein bisschen gelangweilt hat. Oder Bob Dillen, genau. Oder Coldplay.
Vielleicht geißt du schlecht, dass Steve tot ist.
Kommt jetzt mal ein bisschen pfiff in die Geschichte. Aber das werden wir ja erst noch sehen, ne? Ob es krumm ist, dass er tot ist, oder?
Max, wie kannst du nur?
In Saudi-Arabien wäre ich jetzt wahrscheinlich schon gesteinigt worden.
Ja, wir können dich da auch gleich hinschicken, wenn du weiter machst. Wie auch immer, hier ist MobileMax, Ausgabe Nr. 81, so weit haben wir es schon getrieben. Während Max verliebt in Siris Gesicht blickt, ringen wir nach Themen, weil eigentlich so richtig was passiert ist nicht. Nur so Sachen, über die man eigentlich gar nicht reden will.
Du willst ja nicht reden.
Ich weiß nicht, so eine besondere Begeisterung habe ich noch nie gesehen, wenn es um Patentklagen ging.
Nee, das kann ich auch nicht.
Wir sind ja auch keine Patentanwälte.
Thema vorwerfen, ja?
Ähm, ich soll das oder man müsste das?
Du bist ja schon dabei, hast ja schon angefangen.
Seid doch froh, wir haben die Quartalszahlen schon letztes Mal gemacht. Das ist langweilig.
Du musst mal dein Mikrofon noch ein funken.
So?
Nicht übertreiben.
Jetzt kommt erst mal kurz die...
Du musst dein Mikrofon auch besser ausrichten, das zeigt nämlich auf deine Augen.
Das ist jetzt auch erstmal der Standardteil einer jeden Mobile-Max-Sendung, das Audio-Setup. Also jeder rückt mal jetzt noch sein Mikro gerade und kannst du mir meinen Kopfhörer vielleicht noch so ein Mühleiser machen?
Ich muss das mal alles automatisiert bekommen.
Du brauchst so Presets für deine Gäste.
Du musst einfach mal hier so ein Programm haben. Kann ja nicht schwer sein.
Ja, das ist mein Reden.
Was machst du dir an den ganzen anderen 13 Tagen, während wir keine Sendung machen?
Fahnen, rumsitzen und Schoki zuschicken lassen.
Ich bin...
Also diese Woche war ich ein bisschen krank, aber nicht unfleißig. Na gut, es geht voran.
Keine Atempause.
Große Dinge befinden sich in der... Wasserröhre.
Wasserröhre?
Ja, was ist denn die korrekte Übersetzung von Pipeline? Ja, könnte. Aber für Pipeline selber gibt es eigentlich gar keinen...
Das schauen wir sofort nach.
Rohrlinie sagt ja keiner. Oder?
Ist doch eher eine Strecke.
Rohrstrecke sagt keiner.
Anschlussbogen, Anschlusskanal, Anschlussleitung.
Bogen, Anschlusskanal, Anschlussleitung. Das klingt nach Deutschland, wenn du mich fragst.
Rohrstrang. Rohrstrang gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja okay, also ich hab so einiges im Rohrstrang.
Gehen wir zum Arzt.
Ich glaub wir reden auch deshalb irgendwie so viel Englisch, weil wenn wir alles versuchen würden in Deutsch auszudrücken, dann klingt's irgendwie verfänglich.
Ja, wer weiß wie das für die englischen Zuhörer, die Dualsprachler ist, vielleicht ist das auch in Englisch sehr verfänglich, was die Leute die ganze Zeit vor uns her sabbeln.
Ja das ist wahr, aber wir merken es ja nicht. Das ist ja das Gute daran.
Die hören noch nicht beschwert, oder?
Genau, ich kann mich auch an keinen Kommentar diesbezüglich erinnern.
Na vielleicht kommt der ja noch. Ich kann ja mal hier anfangen zu berichten, also so richtig viel zu berichten gibt's nicht, aber wie ich ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnte, tue ich mich ja sehr schwer mit Leon. Das tue ich schon seit einiger Zeit.
Schnee-Löwe.
Ich hätte nicht wieder Drogen verherrlichen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall bekam ich so allerlei Rat, gut gemeinten. Ich wiederhole mich jetzt nicht, aber kurz gesagt, the systems are acting up on me. Es ist wirklich schlimm gewesen. Abstürze, Hänger, irgendwie dieses komische Outdoor-Suspend schlägt einfach zu und suspendet mir irgendwelche Prozesse, die es nicht suspenden soll. Also die volle Windows-Experience hab ich eigentlich. So hab ich mir das immer unter Windows vorgestellt.
So ist es halt als Marktführer.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das einfach so ein...
Oder du hast einfach einen zu kleinen Computer gekauft.
Das ist auch auf meinem großen Computer, der echt groß ist. So.
Was machst du denn anders als ich zum Beispiel?
Der hat einfach Komputronenmangel.
Ja, Burgonemitter. Aber das wissen wir ja schon seit 80 Folgen jetzt mittlerweile.
Ja, aber ein Betriebssystem, was nicht in der Lage ist, so ein Burgonenstrom, irgendwas Nennenswertes entgegenzuhalten, kann einfach nicht überleben im Internet.
Ja, jetzt solltest du mal sowas wie Solaris probieren, so ein Betriebssystem Panzer. Wenn er dann mal rollt, der ist auch nicht mehr aus der Bahn zu bringen. Dann AIX.
Ich könnte dir das so als Dienstleistung anbieten, so ein Frittlaff-Zennraum, wo ich einfach nur so...
Kriegst du mir Zahnabstürzen bringen?
Genau, ich sitze einfach so daneben. Genau, ich sitze einfach auf so einem Kissen, so im Schneidersitz und die Finger zur Lotusblüte gereckt. Samfte asiatische Musik wird eingespielt, Räucherkerze und so mit Duftkerzchen auch.
Und du wunderst dich, warum du nie an irgendwelchen Betatestzahlen nehmen darfst. Hast du doch deine Antwort?
Ich nehme an Betatestzahlen.
Er fährt immer hin und dann ist schon ein Zettel an der Tür, dass es ausfällt, weil alles nicht funktioniert. Sie machen es immer ungefähr ran an die Tür, wenn er 100 Meter davor ist.
Ich bin schon ein paar Mal hingefahren, aber die Straßenbahnen kamen auf jeden Fall nicht vom Fleck. Irgendwas musste ich auf jeden Fall tun und ich beschloss dann doch mal, dieses neue Recovery auszuprobieren. Um auch einfach mal so die Experience zu haben, wie denn das so ist in einer Welt, ohne Betriebssysteme auf CD und so oder auf USB-Sticks.
Du meinst, du hast das jetzt über Internet installiert?
Ja, partiell. Also es gibt da ja zwei Ansätze. Vielleicht kann man das auch nochmal klarstellen, wie sich das jetzt eigentlich gewandelt hat mit Line. Also wenn man jetzt so einen Line auf seiner Büchse hat, dann gibt es so zwei Fälle. Genau genommen gibt es drei Fälle, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe. Entweder du hast so ein ganz altes System, was diese neuen Recovery-Methoden noch nicht unterstützt. Oder du hast eins, was es vom Anfang an eigentlich nicht unterstützt hat, aber jetzt mit den Updates, die, glaube ich, letzte Woche rauskamen, dann doch auch unterstützt. Also die 2010er-Generation, da haben die das jetzt nachträglich in die Firmware geschoben. Ich habe aber kein 2010er-Gerät, sondern nur 9er und 11er, deswegen weiß ich nicht, hat irgendjemand von euch eine 10er-Maschine? Alles Bleeding Edge hier, ja? Von daher, denke ich mal, funktioniert es dann da genauso, wenn man dieses Firmware-Update gemacht hat und dann natürlich die Maschinen, die ohnehin schon mit Linen ausgeliefert wurden, da ist das dann eben so. Also man kann halt booten, also ausschalten, und dann drückt man beim Einschalten, Apple, ich sag mal noch, Apple. Wie heißt denn das? Blumenkohl.
Steht doch drauf Command, bei dir nicht?
Nee, das steht nicht Command, das steht ZMD. Ja, wenn du mir schon so kommst, dann komm ich dir auch so. Also wie auch immer Blumenkohl und R. Apfel-R sagt man da, oder? Sagt man einfach.
Kommando-R.
Ich bin doch in der Zeit groß geworden, da war die Kommandotasse eine Apfeltaste. So, dann, was passiert dann? Dann bootet er von dieser Recovery-Partition ein richtiges OS X hoch und kommt dann direkt in so ein Menü rein, wo du dann so kannst Time Machine Backup auswählen oder du kannst halt direkt neu installieren, das OS, wobei er sich dann eben das Line nochmal aus dem Netz holt. Also er hat keinen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, in dieser Recovery-Partition nicht nochmal ein Line, das wäre auch zu groß.
Das ist ja nur 600 MB die Recovery-Partition.
Genau. Also man möchte meinen, er lädt sich dann das aktuelle Line runter, dazu auch gleich noch mehr. Und dann installiert er das. Und dann wusste ich nicht so richtig, wie clean der Install dann so ist. Ich hatte mich auf alles eingestellt, weil es lief alles so katastrophal, dass ich mir gedacht habe, okay, scheiß drauf, ich installiere alle Treiber neu und so.
Treiber, du installierst Treiber auf macOS?
Wenn er hier für seinen ganzen Audio zu heißt.
Und du hast natürlich gleich wieder installiert und dann war auch gleich wieder alles kaputt.
Na ja.
Jetzt wurde ich wach.
Nein, ich wusste nicht, was passiert. Ich war einfach so weit, dass ich jetzt alles hingenommen hätte. Also ich hätte nicht hingenommen, dass es danach nicht mehr geht, aber ich hätte hingenommen, dass ich so auf dem System-Level Dinge nochmal neu installieren muss. Musste ich aber nicht. Also dieses neu installieren ersetzt tatsächlich halt, ich kann es nur annehmen, alle System-Files, behält aber Extensions bei, die nach seinem Glauben, oder es ist die Betriebssystem, ich weiß gar nicht, er hat dann noch so einen Ordner mit incompatible Software, wo dann so Extensions drin landen, von denen er meint, dass sie nicht passen. Da hatte ich wohl dann noch so alte Versionen, von denen ich eigentlich glaubte, neue Versionen installiert zu haben und so. Ein bisschen skurril. Kann natürlich sein, dass das irgendwas ausgemacht hat, aber ehrlich gesagt, für diese Vielzahl von Fehlern würde mich das sehr überraschen. Wie auch immer, das OS kam weitgehend unverändert hoch. Also Einloggen, User-Accounts, alles da, Einloggen, alle Treiber da, alles Sound-Devices, alles genauso wie vorher. Also insofern, smoothe Experience, das hab ich auf meinem iMac gemacht, und da war auch alles top. Aktuelle Szenen, 7.3 und seitdem bisher auf dem iMac auch kein Stress. Doch, schon mehr so, super, machst du gleich hier auch noch auf deinem Air. 2011er Modell, genau der gleiche Spaß, Apple Air, Recovery-Positionen, Reinstall und so weiter. Und dann auch wieder selbe Experience, alles ersetzt und alles übernommen und einloggen und alles wie vorher. Nur hat er mir 10.7.2 installiert und nicht 10.7.3. Wo ich mir dachte so...
Auf dem iMac hat er 10.7.3 gleich installiert?
Und auf meinem 2 Jahre neueren Gerät... Entschuldigung, das war gar nicht der iMac, das war der Mac Pro. Ah, den iMac muss ich noch installieren. Ich realisiere gar nicht, dass ich schon so viel...
Don't.
Unsere Bandbreite. Also das fand ich schon mal komisch. Dann hab ich es nochmal mit einem anderen, so uralten iMac auch nochmal ausprobiert. Hat im Prinzip, hätte wohl auch funktioniert, hatte dann aber auf einer anderen Ebene ein Double Fail. Erstens, wenn du macOS 10 Server installiert hast, also dieses Erweiterungs-Dingsbum, meint er so, ähm, nö, das ist ja macOS 10 Server, da kann ich das nicht machen, da muss ich jetzt die ganze Platte löschen. Und dann kann ich dir das auch neu installieren. Da dachte ich mir so, ein Paket, die Paket-Management-App-Store runterladen, irgendwie er weiß, was dazugehört. Hallo, ich meine, wenn er das installieren kann, dann kann er das doch vielleicht auch wieder deinstallieren. Nischt. Diese Funktion weigert sich einfach, da in irgendeiner Form was dran zu drehen. Das fände ich schon mal so ein bisschen frustrierend. Und wo ich schon noch mal dabei war, habe ich zumindest noch mal getestet, ob diese alte Bug noch existierte, weil ich ja so eine Time-Capsule habe, wo man Time-Machine übers Netzwerk machen kann. Und da gibt es dann noch diese Möglichkeit, User-Accounts anzulegen, wenn du so mehrere Leute hast, die das gleichzeitig nutzen, durchaus sinnvoll. Und ja, da wollte er dann auch tatsächlich einen Login haben. Da hab ich mich halt eingeloggt. Und ja, da drehte ich mich dann im Kreis und der Login-Screen kam immer wieder hoch und hat mir auch nicht erklärt, was jetzt eigentlich falsch ist. Aber funktionieren ist anders. Also man kann immer noch nicht von der Time-Capsule seinen Backup wieder zurückholen. Was ich mal echt hardcore finde. Weil es ist gar nicht so einfach, daran sozusagen ranzukommen, wenn das dann noch dein einziger Rechner ist und du genau wegen solcher Fälle dir dieses Teil besorgt hast. Und dann, wenn du es wirklich brauchst, kommst du da nicht ran. Also das ist für dich bekloppt.
Die Time-Capsule, der hab ich von Anfang an nicht vertraut, nee.
Also mit Freebies, Dionetta Talk hat das wunderbar funktioniert bei mir.
Dazu später mehr.
Ja, da können wir ja dann vielleicht noch mehr zu erzählen. Ich glaube, das war jetzt auch im Wesentlichen die Erfahrung, nur dass ich als hier eben gerade kurz vor der Sendung hier wieder einen totalen komischen Fnort hatte. Rechner angemacht, dann Tastatur erstmal, keine Reaktion und danach hab ich irgendwie, konnte ich hier gar nichts mehr eingeben, keine Fenster mehr nach vorne holen. Also genau dieses zähe Gematsche und dieses irgendwie alles Kaputtgefühl, was ich schon vorher hatte, das kam irgendwie wieder bloß mal anders. Also in der Form hatte ich es noch nicht. Und dann einzige Möglichkeit war irgendwie Shutdown. Dann hab ich Shutdown initiiert und der Shutdown hat mich dann ausgelockt.
Also nicht Shutdown. Du musst doch mal so einen richtigen Cleaninstall und dann installier mal keine Third-Party-Software und klick mal nur so rum, eine Woche vielleicht und gucken. Also nur so ein bisschen webbrausen und so.
Ich soll keine Third-Party-Software installieren.
Na so Treiber, so Audiotreiber von irgendwelchen.
Auf dem Weg hab ich, auf dem R hab ich, ach nee doch einen hab ich da, ja. Ja, aber den brauch ich halt.
Ja, aber mal so eine Woche, wenn du mal im Urlaub bist. Und dann guckst du mal, ob das irgendwie... Urlaub?
Genau, wenn ich mal im Urlaub bin ohne Internet und so, dann mach ich das, genau. Super Idee.
Dann wirst du ja schon mal so einen Gegentest machen, ne?
Ja, Dennis, kannst ja gerne mal da einhaken und hier Net-a-Talk berichten. Berichten.
Roddy, du benutzt auch Net-a-Talk mit Time Machine und Freebies, die hab ich gehört, gerade eben. Ja, war ich ja auch. Dann gab's irgendwie im Januar eine neue Version, also seit dem Lion Desaster von Net-a-Talk im letzten Sommer geht das jetzt auch alles mit Time Machine und Lion und so weiter. Hat der Typ ja freigeben. Und jetzt kam im Januar noch mal ein Update auf die 2.2.2. Ich zu Hause, super, neues Update, ist ja immer gut. Irgendwie Rufus, Freebies, lege, baut, zack, geht nicht. Damn shit. Nachgeguckt irgendwie, angeblich unterstützt das neue Net-a-Talk irgendwie Send-File. Das ist so beschleunigtes Raussenden von Files, spart irgendwie.
Gibt's das eigentlich nur unter BSD oder?
Nee, das gibt's überall, aber die API ist natürlich überall eine andere, deswegen hat's ja auch nicht funktioniert. Also das gibt's für Linux, das gibt's für Solaris, gibt's für Freebies auch schon ewig. Aber die beiden Linux machen's ein bisschen anders. Und dann haben sie auch die API nochmal geändert. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, dass sie ja gar keinen 64-Bit unterstützen. Und dann haben sie nochmal Send-File 64 eingeführt. Egal. Bei Freebies haben sie es gleich mal richtig gemacht, aber halt ein bisschen anders. Und deswegen muss jeder Programmierer, der irgendwie Send-File unterstützen will, was eine total gute Sache ist, muss das halt der Programmierer immer für Solaris und Linux und FreeBSD-Einzelnen coden. Und das haben die bei Netatalk irgendwie nicht so richtig gemacht. Und der FreeBSD-Code lungert da schon seit 2005 rum, hat nie funktioniert. Jetzt haben sie anscheinend einfach mal eingeschaltet. Aber auch nie getestet anscheinend. Und es ging halt einfach mal nicht. Und dann habe ich mich mal dahin gesetzt und habe mir das alles mal angeguckt und mal ein bisschen Doku gelesen und rumprobiert und ein bisschen Poor Man Print F Debugging nach rein geschmissen. Und mir ein bisschen die Zahlen angeguckt und so lange fummelt, bis es ging. Und dann ging es irgendwann. Hab einen Patch hochgeschickt, wurde auch angenommen und ist auch eingecheckt. Ganz toll. Und jetzt kann FreeBSD Sendfile unterstützt das. Und wir haben eine Kiste irgendwie im Club, die das auch macht, die vorher immer nur so 60 MB die Sekunde geschickt hat. Und die schickt jetzt gnadenlose 112 MB die Sekunde. Also Wire-Speed, mehr geht über das Ethernet nicht.
Also fast verdoppelt und aber da an die physikalischen Grenzen gestoßen.
Mehr geht da nicht. Und das kann jetzt mehr schicken, ohne dass es doll die CPU belastet. Also es kann ein Sparsamer schicken. Vielleicht haben andere Leute vorher auch schon 112 MB gehabt, aber dann würde der Patch immer noch dafür sorgen, dass die CPU dabei nicht ganz so stark belastet ist. Und leider hat es natürlich nicht mehr in diese 222 reingeschafft, weil die gab es ja schon. Und da muss man jetzt warten, bis die 223 rauskommt. Wenn man aber das aktuelle Git auscheckt, dann ist das schon irgendwie dabei. So, das ist die eine News. Vielleicht nur für Leute interessant, die in FreeBSD haben. Und die andere News von Netatalk. Ich erzähl mal weiter, hast du noch was zum Alten? Die nächste News bei Netatalk ist, dass es dann wahrscheinlich auch für alle interessant, auch für Linux und Leute, die es unter Open Solaris benutzen, es gibt ja die ganzen Firmen, die das da auch einsetzen, ist, dass Netatalk 3.0, wann auch immer das rauskommen wird, vielleicht werden wir demnächst einen größeren Sprung machen, einfach, dass das diese Punkt-Apple-Double-Files, die man immer noch so dann sieht, abschaffen will. HFS Plus ist es ja eigentlich, was auf einem Server gespeichert wird und es muss ja die Metadaten irgendwo speichern. Und diese Ressource-Zeugs und so. Und das wird halt in so hidden Files, in diesen Punkt-Apple-Double-Files gespeichert.
Die verwenden auch Apple-Double, das ist ja interessant.
Und das wird mit der Version 3.0 von Netatalk verschwinden, weil sie werden das dann, zu 100% bei ZFS zumindestens, in den ACLs, irgendwie haben da so...
Nicht in den ACLs, in den Metadaten. Weil ZFS heißt das auch Extended Attributes, oder?
Also heißt es meistens.
Also Metadata halt.
Genau, jedenfalls werden die das da speichern. Das heißt, man sieht keine Apple-Double-Files mehr, die immer so rumliegen, die immer ein bisschen nerven. Die ganzen anderen Unixer, die halt mit Samba zum Beispiel auf das gleiche Filesystem zugreifen würden, die da nicht immer sehen.
Aber bei den Linux-Filesystemen gibt es doch mittlerweile auch diese Metadatengeschichte, oder nicht?
Weiß nicht, es kommt immer aufs Filesystem an. Also da stand da in seiner Erklärung, dass unter Linux das zu 99% verschwinden würde. Weil so ein paar gibt es halt. Photoshop ist noch wohl eins der letzten Programme, die wirklich real richtige Resource-Daten haben, die da gespeichert werden müssen. Und die könnten sie da irgendwie nicht mit einbauen. Kommt wahrscheinlich immer darauf an, wie viel diese Extended Attributes so unterstützen. Keine Ahnung.
Weil sie wahrscheinlich die Resource-Files selber als solche öffnen.
Kann sein, ja.
Also nicht, genau. Vermutung, aber klingt so ein bisschen danach.
Irgendwie so. Und die würden noch so liegen bleiben. Und unter Linux mit deren Filesystems, glaube ich jetzt, ich kann mich mit der Linux-Ecke da nicht ganz aus, die würden dann halt übrig bleiben. Es wäre halt nur ein Prozent. Also im Großen und Ganzen würden die einfach verschwinden. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, dann ist halt diese Extended Attributes, diese Metadaten sind auch alles hier so, Finder, Kommentar, die Farbe wahrscheinlich. Oder es ist im DS-Store drin. Da weiß ich das gar nicht so genau.
Das ist im DS-Store drin.
Aber der Kommentar nicht, richtig? Der Kommentar müsste dann Metadaten sein zum Beispiel.
Kann sein, das weiß ich nicht.
Also so eine Sache. Und die sind dann einfach alle weg. Also jeder, der halt mit Netatalk und unten im Unix irgendwie rumgespielt hat, der wird diese Apple-Double-Files kennen. Das ist dann Vergangenheit. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache.
Apple-Double ist übrigens auch keine Erfindung von Netatalk. Das ist tatsächlich eine alte Spezifikation von Apple, wie man eben diese Resource Forks auf Fallsystemen ohne diese Fähigkeit abspeichert. Es gibt nicht nur Apple-Double, sondern es gibt auch noch Apple Single. Na das gehört quasi dazu, und jetzt muss ich gerade mal ein bisschen grübeln. Das war sozusagen für zwei Fälle. Apple Single ist, wenn du alles irgendwie in einer Datei ablegst. Das war also sehr uninteressant. Und dann Apple-Double ist halt, wenn du zwei Dateien hast. Also wenn du quasi die eigentliche Datei in einer Datei ablegst und die Resource Fork-Geschichte in einer anderen Datei. Und das ist halt dieses Apple-Double.
Gab es ja so zu System-7-Zeiten auch so Dateien, die nur aus Resource Fork bestanden und irgendwie überhaupt keine Daten-Fork hatten?
Ja, die Ups.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn du da so ein Apple-Double-File hast ohne ein dazugehöriges eigentliches File, dass da einige durcheinander kommen.
Ja, dann gab es halt diese entsprechenden Hacks. Also ich meine, das Ding hatte halt immer einen Namen. Das Data-File konnte halt leer sein. Ja, also die Datei als solche, so in dem Sinne gab es ja. Und du hast halt immer diese beiden Forks und der eine war dann halt einfach leer.
Ha, Grusel. Ich glaube, ein Data-Fork hat das da automatisch. Also es war dann halt leer. Also ein Resource-Fork musste explizit angelegt werden.
Ja, richtig.
Das war, wenn man das in Resetit aufgemacht hat, das enthält keinen Resource-Fork, sollte ich eins anlegen?
Naja, ich weiß.
Und umgekehrt war es aber immer da.
Ich meine, man kann da viel drüber fluchen, aber damals war das eigentlich echt super.
Es hat gut funktioniert.
Ich will jetzt mal nicht visionär sagen, aber das war eine coole Idee eigentlich. Strukturierte Datei. Eigentlich ist das halt abgelöst worden durch diese Metadatengeschichte und macht insofern auch total Sinn, dass wir das damit jetzt auch implementieren dabei.
Ja, und durch die Bundles.
Richtig, und die Bundles. Also wo sie dann quasi die Struktur im Fallsystem abgelegt haben. Das stimmt. Ja, wo wir jetzt schon dabei sind, können wir auch gleich mal das ZFS-Lied nochmal singen. Wir hatten ja letztes Mal hier schon berichtet über Cebo. Da war das allerdings noch relativ neu. Roddy hat schon ein bisschen...
Guck mal, die Hörer schlafen aber schon ein. Jetzt hier bei dem Nerd-Talk.
500 gestiegen.
Ja, die hören, schalten ein und schlafen dabei ein. Das ist aber auch super für die Statistik.
Da müssen wir jetzt durch.
Bleiben Sie unterhalten. Wir unterhalten uns auch bald wieder mal kalender aus.
Also wer die letzte Sendung gehört hat, der hat ja auch den Roddy gehört, wie er vom Z-Tab S ein bisschen erzählt hat. Nur, dass es jetzt für den Mac gibt, die Cebo-Version, die in Silver nur bisher existiert. Die anderen gibt es irgendwie noch nicht. Alles schön und gut. Habe ich auch mal mir geschoppt und ausprobiert. Und es ist ja so, weil mich Leute mal fragen, wofür das denn gut ist. Weil es kann ja irgendwie noch nichts. Und dann meine ich, naja, aber es macht ordentlich Check-Something auf irgendwie dein Filesystem. Und ist flott. Und flott ist aber eigentlich auch nicht mehr wichtig heutzutage, weil mal ehrlich, jede Platte, SSD, USB-Gehäuse ist egal. Man ist eigentlich immer am physikalischen Anschlag. Also das Filesystem ist nicht mehr das Bottleneck schon natterlich mehr, oder?
Nö, aber es ist schon schön zu sehen, dass so eine USB-Platte halt wirklich USB dann der Bottleneck ist und dass das ZFS halt alles rausholt, was aus dem USB rausgeholt ist.
Ja, aber das würde bei jedem anderen Filesystem eigentlich auch so sein. Also ich denke mal, es ist nicht mehr so das Limit. Jedenfalls, was aber noch ein Unterschied ist, das mir immer so aufgefallen ist, aber auch, naja, für uns Freaks ist es ja schon interessant. Und zwar, wenn man sein Transmission, also hier BitTorrent, auf dem ZFS benutzt, Hucke hat ja letztens davon erzählt, meint der Hucke nämlich hier mit seiner SSD, wenn er irgendwie, sagen wir mal, so ein 5 GB File runterlädt, dann muss dieses Transmission erstmal halt 5 GB schreiben, weil ja danach randommäßig...
Wenn du Pause drückst, auch nur.
Ja, inzwischen macht das erst, wenn man Pause drückt. Früher hat das gleich gemacht. Warum? Na, weil der randommäßig in der Datei so rumschreibt und weil er will, dass die an einem Block entsteht, macht der M-Map das File erstmal. Man kann am Speicher drauf schreiben, wo er will, dann sagt er schließen und dann sorgt das OS dafür, dass es weggeschrieben wird. Irgendwie so läuft das. Und das heißt am Ende dann, dass es so eine Art auch Sparse-File ist, weil wenn du von den 5 GB, wenn du deinen Transmission dann stopfst, der das wegschreibt und da ist halt noch nichts drin, da muss er halt trotzdem 5 GB Nullen schreiben. Mit so einer SSD, wie Huckl schon meinte, geht das halt schon voll flott. Der schreibt dann mal da 300, 400 MB die Sekunde. Dann ist das irgendwie in 12 Sekunden gemacht. Aber bei so einem ZFS ist es halt noch viel cooler, weil das HFS Plus schreibt halt wirklich 300 MB Nullen die Sekunde. Und das ZFS macht einfach nichts weiter als, was, der Blog, da sollen nur Nullen drin sein, alles klar. Ich mach den Blog-Eintrag, aber ich schreib irgendwie nicht die Nullen. Und lässt es halt komplett weg, so wie das eigentlich alle anderen File Systems auch machen. Alle modernen, bis auf HFS Plus, weil es halt nicht mehr modern.
Ich wundere mich nämlich gerade, weil eigentlich alle, soweit ich mich erinnern kann, hat das Unix eigentlich schon immer so...
Ja, kannst mal sehen, wie alt HFS Plus ist.
Also wenn du Nullen schreibst, dann nicht. Aber du konntest auf jeden Fall Gaps haben. Ach so, aber das funktioniert dann mit dem MemMap nicht. Der kann da nicht mehr unterscheiden, was eine Null und was ein nicht beschriebener Bereich ist.
Genau, weil der MemMap hat ja auch... Also wenn du dann die Speicherseiten noch nicht reingeschrieben hast, dann weiß er auch, da ist nichts. Dann würde er ja auch wahrscheinlich nicht Nullen schreiben, sondern... Also unter dem Unix würden da keine Nullen geschrieben werden. Würde ich mal ganz stark von ausgehen. Klar, wenn du richtig sagst, ich will jetzt Nullen geschrieben haben und dem richtig Nullen schickst, dann schreibt er die. Aber wenn du sagst, ich möchte jetzt anstelle von Offset 5 GB irgendwie einen Kilobyte schreiben, dann musst du da erstmal, also unter HFS Plus, erstmal 5 GB Nullen schreiben. Und unter einem UFS von einem Unix würde der halt ein Sparse-File machen. Das würde alles nicht existieren mit 5 GB. Und dann würde er dieses eine Kilobyte schreiben. So und ZFS kann das halt eben auch. Der kann auch diesen Sparse-File support und der schreibt die Nullen halt auch nicht. Und dann geht's wupp wupp und dann ist es fertig. Und vor allem ist es auch cool beim Einlesen, weil wenn man ja auch beim Tradition, wenn du mal dein Bit tauchen, was noch nicht fertig ist, du kannst ja Verify klicken und kannst sagen, hier check noch mal durch. Und wenn du ja so ein 10 GB File hast und du hast es gerade mal zu 10% runtergeladen, dann besteht es halt zu 90% aus nichts, aus Nullen. Und im Half-S Plus muss halt dann die 10 GB trotzdem einlesen. Und der ZFS kann es richtig zugucken, dann macht er so Jump, Jump, Jump, der springt da jetzt so durch und nix, also ist er einfach zehnmal schneller, weil du nur noch ein Zehntel einlesen musst. Und das sind so Kleinigkeiten, mir gefällt das voll. So, das ist erstmal so das, was man schnell sehen könnte, wenn man halt Transmission benutzt oder halt...
Ein tollerer Pirat sein, bitte sehr.
Du kannst auch Wikipedia-Dumps runterladen oder World of Warcraft-Updates. Obunto-CDs.
Das wird aber auf Dauer echt langweilig, ich hab jetzt hier schon so ein Obunto-CD.
Schon klar, ist aber egal. So, dann ist es so, ich dachte mal bei dieser Silver-Edition von dem ZFS, weil da steht immer oder stand da, dass es ja diese Gold-Edition noch gibt und dann irgendwie noch eine Platinum-Edition und später noch eine Developer-Edition. Und dann stand irgendwie so da, dass bei der Developer-Edition später dann auch die Command Line Tools dabei wären. Und dann dachte ich, alles klar, muss man wohl später irgendwann mal die Developer-Version kaufen, wenn man so richtig geil rumfummeln will. Aber nee, nee.
Richtig geil rumfummeln.
Bei der Silver Edition...
Den Fallsystemer so richtig ins Gemächt greifen.
Bei der Silver Edition jedenfalls sind die Commands auch da. Die ZDB, ZFS und Zpool ist auch da. Das heißt, weil die sagen ja, die Silver Edition kann zum Beispiel keinen Compression. Die kann sehr wohl Compression, die kann halt nur keinen Compression im GUI. Man kann halt ins Command Line gehen, kann sagen, irgendwie hier ZFS, Set Compression gleich on, Tank und dann BUM ist irgendwie Compression an. Und das gleiche kannst du sogar auch für DDoP machen, also DDuplication.
Man kann es jetzt einfach enablen, auch wenn das nur Silver ist. Es gibt bloß keinen User Interface dafür.
So sieht es aus. Oder auch Scrub, was natürlich im GUI auch geht. Aber ein Scrub-Command kannst du auch. Also kannst du alles machen. Du kannst ja diese Metadaten, also mit ZFS, Get All kannst du dir irgendwie alle angucken, setzen, machen und tun, check-summing, ändern und so weiter und so fort.
Also so wie ich die verstanden hatte, ist die Developer-Edition ganz ohne GUI-Tools.
Und gratis ja angeblich auch, oder?
Du meinst, die kommt erst ganz spät und ist eigentlich die billigste von allen. So rum kann natürlich sein.
Die kommen wohl weitgehend ohne GUI-Tools.
Ein bisschen schade, weil natürlich haben alle schon die dicke Edition gekauft, was wahrscheinlich aber deren Sinn der Sache ist.
Ich meine, dass die jetzt ein bisschen Kohle da einsammeln, ist ja auch okay.
Bei 20 Dollar, da kann man echt nichts sagen.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt total überrascht gewesen, wie billig das ist.
Naja, die Silver-Edition, die anderen kosten ja ein bisschen mehr.
Aber da steht aber nichts davon, was die Developer-Edition kosten.
Ich bin früher mal drauf und irgendwie, also früher stand mal da irgendwo, will ich mir erinnern, dass die Developer-Edition halt frei ist.
Vielleicht hab ich das auch in dem Beta-Forum gelesen, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Ich bin ja auch so der Meinung, dass ich gelesen hab, die Developer-Edition ist irgendwie so das alles. So das kriegst du einmal alles.
Ja, einmal alles, aber ohne schöne GUI.
Naja, ich dachte mal, es wäre dann später das ganz Teure sozusagen.
Der Trend geht eh jetzt zum Terminal, ne, wieder.
Aber was unterscheidet dann Silver, Gold und Platinum wirklich?
Das GUI glaube ich vor allem.
Das heißt, man könnte jetzt auch aus drei Platten?
Nee, das war gecancelt. Irgendwie, ich glaube, unser Freund Kröx hat das probiert, einen Mirror zu anzulegen. Und da hat das Command & Tool gleich gesagt, nee, ist nicht supported hier. Also das haben sie schon gesperrt. Aber halt, Compression geht. Was ich mir auch gut vorstellen könnte...
Also Mirrors und Raids ist sozusagen...
Ich glaube, der Lesesupport, wenn du einen Mirror schon hast, das hab ich halt noch nicht ausprobiert, und einen Mirror anschließt, dass der den dann halt schon lesen kann. Aber dass du keinen erstellen kannst. Ich glaube, lesen können sie halt immer alles. Weil wenn du so eine Platte anschließt, die jetzt halt schon irgendeinen Compression gesetzt hat, dann muss der das ja auch lesen können. Aber du kannst den halt nicht setzen. Okay, bei Compression kannst du setzen, aber den Mirror kannst du halt eben nicht setzen.
Also ich hab eine ZFS-Platte, die ich unter FreeBSD mit Z-Pool-Version 28 erstellt hab. Und vollgeschrieben hab, ohne Probleme, auch mit Snapshots und allem Drum und Dran und das Cevo Silver gemountet gekriegt. Also es war irgendwie überhaupt kein Problem.
28 ist auch die Version von...
Z-Pool 28 ist die momentan aktuelle Version, die alle benutzen, weil die irgendwie über dieses Open Solaris Nevada, wie auch immer, der letzte Stand der Open Source ist.
Hast du da irgendwelche Einblicke? Wir haben ja letztes Mal hier so ein bisschen gerätselt, wie das so ist, wenn man DDoP hat, was so das benötigte RAM im System.
Ja, hab ich mich auch nochmal drum gekümmert. Und zwar verbraucht es, da muss man ein bisschen rechnen, verbraucht es pro Block, der gespeichert wird. Die Sache ist die, dass auf dem Pool, und zwar ist das eine Pool-weite Geschichte, muss er für jeden Block, den du speicherst, speichert er die Checksumme in so einer DDuplication-Table. Die Blöcke bei ZFS können variabel groß sein, und zwar zwischen 4 und 128 Kilobyte. Wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht, du hast nur fette, große Dateien, wo die Blöcke immer 128 Kilobyte groß sind, dann würde pro 128 Kilobyte-Block eine Schar-256-Checksumme gespeichert werden in dieser DDuplication-Table. Und der ganze Eintrag, wo noch der Block ist, und Metadaten und so, sind 320 Bytes. Das heißt, du musst eigentlich deine Platte, so groß wie die ist, 2 Terabyte geteilt durch 128 Kilobyte. Was ist denn der Pool? Also wenn dein Pool 2 Terabyte groß ist, geteilt durch 128 Kilobyte, so oft wie die Blöcke da reinpassen, mal 320 Bytes. So groß ist die Tabelle, wo er drinnen nachgucken muss, ob es den Blog mit diesem Hasch schon gibt oder nicht. Und der muss möglichst wiederum im Ram liegen, damit er den schnell findet. Das performt auch alles, während das halt auf der Platte liegt, aber da muss er es halt immer einlesen. Und da kannst du dir ja vorstellen, wie langsam das ist, wenn er immer erst lesen muss, ob es den Blog schon gibt, um ihn dann eventuell schreiben zu können und so weiter und so fort.
Was muss immer im Ram liegen?
Naja, du kannst natürlich auch den Cache-Device anschließen an dem Pool. Du kannst dem Pool natürlich immer ein Cache-Device hinzufügen. Und dann liegt diese Tabelle sehr wahrscheinlich auch auf dem Cache-Device. Und wenn dieses Cache-Device jetzt eine schnelle SSD ist, dann ist dieser Zugriff immerhin so schnell wie auf einer schnellen SSD.
Aber der erste Trick ist natürlich, erst mal Ram voll machen.
Hast du das mal ausgerechnet? Was ist jetzt so der realistische Speicherbedarf?
Pro Terabyte, wenn man nur 128 Kilobyte Block hat, weil man hat ja auch mal kleinere. Aber wenn man 128 Kilobyte Block hat, ich glaube, ich bin auf 2,5 Gigabyte gekommen bei einem Terabyte. Haut das hin? Ich glaube ja.
Ja, ich glaube so 2 Gigabyte pro Terabyte war so die Daumenregel.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn man sich eine relativ günstige 80G SSD schnappt.
Nee, erst mal Ram. Erstens voll machen mit Ram. Ist billiger, ist schneller, ist besser.
Ja okay, abgesehen jetzt von dem. Also mich interessiert eigentlich mehr, dass es läuft. Weil ich würde mir, ich fänd's einfach mal geil, wirklich mal so einen zuverlässigen Time Machine-Backdrop zu haben, der einfach ZFS nutzt mit Date Duplication, weil er dann einfach viel mehr Daten frisst. Also ich hab hier wieder das Problem, nach diesem Clean Install will er natürlich sofort alle System Files wieder, ein ganzes Terabyte wieder wegbackupen. Da reicht dann sozusagen der Rest Space auf der Platte nicht mehr, dass er das dann irgendwie schreiben kann?
Da muss ich kurz einhaken. Da gab's in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung auch so eine kleine Diskussion da drum. Du musst dir noch vor Augen halten, dass Time Machine legt dir ja ein Image, ein Disk-Image an.
Das zwingt.
Doch, wenn du auf dem Server backups, sei es nun Time Machine, oder aber auch irgendwas mit Netatalk, legt er dir immer ein Disk-Image an. Dieses Disk-Image ist immer ein Sparse-Bundle, der immer in einzelne Dateien diese Bands reinschreibt usw. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er da vernünftig dedupliziert, ist eher nicht so groß.
Korrekt.
Das stimmt. Aber du kannst ja dann hier mit Sivo deinen Time Machine-Ersatz mit deinen Rotating Snapshots usw. realisieren. Du musst ja dann nicht Time Machine benutzen auch.
Ja, aber wenn du jetzt direkt Time Machine benutzen willst auf einem NetAttack-Server, dann hast du dieses Problem und dann ist das mit dem D-Drop wahrscheinlich irgendwie funktioniert dann wahrscheinlich nicht.
Lässt sich das eigentlich irgendwie abschalten, dass er ein Disk-Image verwendet?
Nee, ich hab mal direkt auch eine ZFS angeschlossen, hab gesagt, mach mal Time Machine jetzt auf diese Platte. Selbst da hat er gleich gemerkt, ist nicht das richtige Fallsystem und hat direkt auch wieder ein Bundle angelegt. Oder hat sogar gleich gesagt, es ist nicht das Fallsystem, was ich haben möchte und geht nicht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, es ging auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das ist nicht das Fallsystem, was ich habe.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass du, da ist wohl auch HFS Plus einzigartig, dass du Hardlinks auf Verzeichnisse machen kannst. Sonst hast du halt nur Hardlinks auf Dateien. Aber Time Machine macht dir auch Hardlinks auf ganze Verzeichnisse. Und das müsstest du ja überhaupt erst mal über dein Serverprotokoll drüber kriegen, dass der Server auf seinem Dateisystem Hardlinks macht auf Verzeichnisse. Und ich glaube, soweit sind wir dann doch noch nicht im Jahre 2012.
Das kann auch ZFS nicht, oder?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weiß ich gar nicht.
Gute Frage, kann ich auch nicht beantworten.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein esoterisches HFS-Feature.
Aber ich hab noch eine Geschichte, weil Roddy gerade meinte, Snapshots auf einem Time Machine-Filesystem von ZFS. Das geht auch ganz schnell in die Hose, weil das Time Machine will ja, wenn voll ist, selber löschen. Und wenn du aber einen Snapshot auf deinen Daten hast, dann verschwinden die Daten dann nicht, weil die werden ja vom Snapshot noch festgehalten und dann fängt die Time Machine an, alles zu löschen, weil nichts frei wird und dann ist alles weg. Also da muss man auch aufpassen. Keine Snapshots auf einem Time Machine-Volumen, wenn man ZFS nutzt.
Ja, doch das kann man schon machen, wenn man sagt, man will so und so viel Reservation haben, beziehungsweise so ein Quota in dem Dateilsystem.
Man muss da ganz doll aufpassen, sonst geht's in die Hose.
ZFS ist überhaupt das einzige Dateilsystem, wo es einem passieren kann, dass die Platte voller wird, wenn man was löscht. Weil er nämlich, wenn du einen Snapshot gemacht hast, und sagst, lösch jetzt diese Datei, schreib dann noch Informationen drauf, dass die Datei jetzt gelöscht ist, hält aber den Platz für die Datei fest. Im Snapshot. Und dann wird die Platte noch voller.
Die wissen schon, warum sie nur diese Silver-Edition für den Mac rausgebracht haben und da erstmal nichts geht. Was für den normalen User erstmal voll okay ist.
Aber ich hab zum Thema ZFS noch was ganz Skurriles. Ich dropp das mal in den Chat. Und zwar hat da jemand auf der Mac-ZFS-Liste diesen Link gepostet, wo jemand behauptet, er hätte irgendwie ein iOS 5.1 Beta mit einem laufenden ZFS.
Nicht mit einem laufenden, sondern er hat das im Binary gefunden, oder?
Oder er hat das im Binary gefunden, irgendwie sowas.
Also es hört sich schon erstmal cool an, da fängt natürlich der Dennis auch gleich an zu träumen, aber es ist eigentlich, glaube ich, totaler Blödsinn, weil das iPhone hat wie viel Speicher? Ja, so ZFS, also so unter 4 brauchst du gar nicht kommen, unter 4 GIG, dann geht es, also es ist nicht so spannend. Vollkommen rausgeschlossen.
Bis man ja was, was ein iPad 3 hat. 4,5 Gigabyte RAM.
Dann ZFS hätte gerne 64 Bit irgendwie, also es geht auch mit 32, aber mit 64 Bit, da fühlt es sich echt viel wohler, weil sowieso alles da 64 Bit oder größer ist.
Ohne 64 Bit will man kein ZFS.
Also es macht alles gar keinen Sinn.
Na, das heißt also für die iPad 3 Spekulation gleich mal...
4 Gigabyte RAM und 64 Bit. Und 4 Cores, aber egal.
Ja, won't happen. Ich glaube 64 Bit auf dem iPad, da vergehen noch ein paar Jahre.
Also da gab es auch eine lustige Diskussion auf der Mac-ZFS-Liste da drüber, weil es ein paar Leute gab, die diese Idee verteidigt haben, dass das doch total sinnvoll wäre und in ein paar Jahren und so weiter. Dann tragen wir alles so hardware in der Tasche und so weiter.
Haben wir bei Time Machine auch gedacht, dass das voll sinnvoll wäre.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, die ganzen coolen Features von ZFS machen einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn auf so einem iOS-Device.
Naja, mal gucken, also vielleicht... Ich denke, der Pfad ist irgendwie klar, wo er lang geht, nur noch nicht, wie er aussieht mit diesem Core Storage. Sie werden einfach jetzt dieses Core Storage System modular um die Features ergänzen, die ihnen wichtig sind. Und ich hoffe halt sehr, dass sie überhaupt erstmal Check-Zooming einführen als nächstes. Ich meine, wenn sie die ganze Platte verschlüsseln können, dann können sie auch die ganze Platte Check-Zoom. Wenn sie jeder so ein Abstraction-Layer drunter haben, dann wäre das auf jeden Fall machbar.
Ich hab ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht und es gibt einen Stolperstein an der Stelle, nämlich die Blockgröße ändert sich. Wenn du nämlich die Check-Zooms nicht mit in die gleichen Blöcke schreibst, die du Check-Zoomst, hast du immer zwei Zugriffe, weil du einmal erst den Block liest und dann guckst du in irgendeiner Tabelle nach, ob der Block auch tatsächlich die richtige Check-Zoom hat. Oder aber du schreibst es mit in den Block, aber dann musst du den Block um die Check-Zoom-Länge kleiner machen. Und dann hast du natürlich das Problem, dass dein ganzes Dateisystem irgendwie von der Annahme, wie groß ist denn ein Block von oben bis unten, durchsetzt ist. Und wenn du da jetzt irgendwie 20 Bites abschneidest, dann bricht die Hölle los.
Aber ist ja bei ZFS auch schon so.
Ja, aber bei ZFS haben sie es von vornherein eingebaut. Und wenn du jetzt einen HFS+, was wahrscheinlich von oben bis unten mit hardcoded values voll ist, wie groß ein Block ist, plötzlich irgendwie die Blöcklänge um 20 Bites oder 32 Bites verkürzt, dann bricht möglicherweise das Chaos aus.
Aber du weißt, dass Festplatten, die haben gar nicht 4 Kilobyte oder 512 Bites, sondern die haben immer ein bisschen mehr. Also es waren gar nicht immer 512 Bites, es waren immer 520 Bites. Und du konntest genau da drin, glaube ich, so eine Sache speichern.
Na wie dem auch sein Erholen. Also das ist, glaube ich, was, was man nicht mal so eben macht. Wenn man da mal drüber nachdenkt, dann kann es sein, dass man da stolper scheint.
Okay, ich kann mir auch durchaus vorstellen, auch wenn es in gewisser Insicht schade wäre, dass Apple auch sich sagt, sich jetzt noch groß Gedanken um Features zu machen, die für Festplatten, komm mal rotierende, sinnvoll wären, ist irgendwie, weißt du, das ist so, als hätten sie noch mal so in der Endphase des CRTs sich darum Gedanken gemacht, wie man die Optik...
Wie man Features in das Kettenlaufer einbaut.
Ja, es ist einfach so Legacy-Technologie, wobei ich Schwierigkeiten habe, einzuschätzen, wie lange die rotierenden Platten noch bleiben werden.
Na Gott wollte die letztes Jahr schon abschaffen mit der Flut, aber es hat nicht ganz geklappt.
Kann die nicht kurz nach dem Steve-Tot, wa?
Die Flut?
Okay, jetzt wo ich schon mal hier bin.
Steve hat Gott erst mal geohnt.
Okay, kommen wir damit zu Freude.
Ich sehe ja ein ganz neuer Sparternwitz noch auf uns zu kommen.
Seitdem gibt es immer so ein Schlecht.
Gut, dann können wir gleich zur fortgeschrittenen Götterdeutung kommen. Neues aus dem Apple Store Berlin.
Was gab es denn letztes Mal Neues? Ich habe ja nicht gehört.
Ach so, letztes Mal gab es generell erst mal die Information, dass es Rolltreppen geben wird. Das ist ein riesen Areal über drei Etagen, ganz oben dieses ehemalige Kino. Ansonsten so in der Mitte so ein Freiraum und dann so Emporen drum herum auf der ersten Etage. Dann führten eben diese Rolltreppen in die erste und da auch in die zweite Etage. Die zweite Etage ist halt dieses Kino. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass der ganze Bau jetzt schon schwarz eingekleidet ist. Es gibt ja eh schon seit längerer Zeit keinen Zweifel daran, aber natürlich auch noch keine offizielle Bestätigung, dass es einer wird. Weil das Bauschild fehlt. Weil da einfach keiner was sagt. Aber wir haben halt gesicherte Erkenntnisse, dass es halt tatsächlich einer ist.
Auf irgendeiner Seite, auf berlin.de, irgendeine Behördenunterseite, stand irgendwo ganz weit unten mal das Wort Apple. Da gab es irgendeinen Link in der Diskussion.
Das ist ja hier Qualitätsjournalismus.
Nein, in der Diskussion zu den Show.
Ja gut, das mag natürlich auch sein, dass da irgendwelche Bemaße, Informationen sind.
Ja, das ist absolut sicher. Was jetzt neu ist, ist, dass seit unserer letzten Sendung die Rolltreppen verschwunden sind. Sie haben alle Rolltreppen rausgenommen. Also unsere Erstaunen über die Präsenz von Rolltreppen in einem Apple Store ist insofern jetzt wieder...
Sie haben natürlich Glas wieder eingebaut. Ich kenne das doch.
Ja, also meines Wissens gibt es... Also ich weiß nicht, ob es da jetzt schon Glastreppen gibt, aber wenn sie die Rolltreppen rausnehmen, werden sie sicherlich keine neuen wieder einsetzen.
Glas-Rolltreppen. Aber wie ist das eigentlich in den Apple Stores? Gibt es da auch so Fahrstühle?
Immer.
Das muss ja ein bisschen hinderndengerecht sein.
Immer. Also ich hab bisher eigentlich in jedem Apple Store einen Fahrstuhl angetroffen.
Aus Glas.
Wenn er mehrstöckig war. Ja. Im Frankfurt auch? Nein, nicht unbedingt immer aus Glas, sondern die sind sogar, da muss ich jetzt gerade mal grübeln, in den meisten Fällen gar nicht sichtbar. Also die Fahrstühle bieten sich, in Japan war es tatsächlich so, der Fahrstuhl, genau, der war aus Glas und der führte ein, weil das war irgendwie, da in Ginza, da gibt es irgendwie den Apple Store, der geht glaube ich über drei oder vier Etagen sogar, ich weiß nicht, aber halt relativ klein, halt Japan.
Das ist ja alles ein bisschen kleiner.
Ja, da kostet auf jeden Fall der Quadratmeter wahrscheinlich so viel wie in Berlin der ganze Store. Und da gab es definitiv einen Fahrstuhl for the public, ich glaube sogar zwei. Und in München und in Frankfurt. Und wo war ich noch? Ich glaube München und Frankfurt war ich nur. Da sind diese Fahrstühle so ein bisschen versteckt und eigentlich nur fürs Personal. Aber wenn du halt da hingehst und sagst, ich Rollstuhl oder ich habe hier Podcaster-Equipment und ich brauch mal einen Fahrstuhl, dann darfst du da halt auch mit hochfahren. Dann fährt da einer mit dir hoch und ist irgendwie freundlich zu dir.
Sehen Podcaster sein ja schon als Behinderung.
Helfen Sie mir, ich bin ein Podcaster. Es ist immer rührend, wie sehr sie sich um einen kümmern.
Wo hat der Mann probiert, seine Stimme aufzunehmen?
Naja, auf jeden Fall sehr wahrscheinlich, dass da auch ein Fahrstuhl ist. Aber normalerweise schicken sie die Leute halt nicht in die Fahrstühle, sondern sie wollen halt, dass sie da über die Treppen schreiten. Und vermutlich wird da wahrscheinlich auch wieder irgendeine epische Glastreppenkonstruktion sein. Wie die dann konkret aussieht, das wissen wir halt nicht.
Spectacular, spectacular.
Ich vermute mal so halt, keine Ahnung, so zwei separate Niemannandertreppen in die erste Etage und dann eine dicke irgendwie nach oben.
Da war der Link im Chat.
Der Link, welcher?
berlin.de. Ja, du warst da gerade mit uns.
Ah, ok, berlin.de.
Noch mal in der Bildschirm.
Body is this.
Ja, das ist aber auch schon älter tatsächlich. Hab ich schon mal gesehen. Vor einer langen Zeit.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist glaube ich die alte Verbauung.
Ja, das ist die alte Verbauung. Genau, so sah das vorher aus. Na ganz toll. Und wann die offizielle Eröffnung ist, ist noch nicht bekannt. Tja, weil ihr nicht Moma Max hört, dann wüsstet ihr, dass das Scheißteil im Juli aufmacht.
Ja, aber offiziell ist das auch noch nicht.
Wenn wir das sagen, dann ist es offiziell.
Swiss ist offiziell.
Gut, das heißt wir kriegen jetzt einen Apple Store in Westberlin. Wann kriegen wir denn einen in Berlin?
Gute Frage. Also das ist ja ohnehin komisch, dass so im Osten eigentlich... Also es gibt ja überhaupt nicht einen einzigen richtigen...
Dresden.
Oder? Nee, das stimmt gar nicht. Es gibt hier so kleinere Shops, die so Apple-Dealer sind, so halb offiziell.
Cyberport, das fällt mir dann am ersten ein. Aber die sind nicht wirklich ein Apple-Dealer, aber immerhin, sie haben...
Cyberport aber ganz schön.
Cyberport ist auch eher... Die sind in der Friedrichstrasse.
Ja, die verkaufen das auch.
Aber ihr Katalog ist so...
Also ein Apple-Dealer ist für mich ein Dealer, wo du reingehst und da gibt es halt nur Apple und Zubehör.
Ich kenne ja so einen Kleinen an der Greifswalder, weiß aber nicht mehr, wie der heißt.
Stimmt, ja.
Ja, der Film nehme ich auch gerade ein, aber die sind halt alle nicht sonderlich... Der Greifswalder?
Prenzlauer.
Wir prangern das an. Wir möchten jetzt gerne einen Apple Store Prenzlauer Berg haben, mit extra Rolltreppen, damit auch behinderte Podcaster dann eine Chance haben, sich...
Kinderwagen.
Hier so ein Windskiez, da hätte er zwei große Fanboys direkt in der Einflugschneise.
Muss auch kinderwagenfreundlich dann aber sein. Und dann brauchst du auch einen Fahrstuhl für den ganzen Kinderwagen.
Da, wo der Kaisers ist, den können sie wegreißen, und dann können sie einen 24-Stunden-Apple-Laden hinmachen.
Nein, nicht den Kaisers. So, Dennis, dein Wunschthema? 500 Dollar.
Schon wieder?
Hab ich nie gesagt. Also, der Apple-Kurs ist ja gestiegen, da haben wir alle gesehen, wir sind ja alle Aktionäre hier. Egal.
Ich sag kein Lieblingsthema für 500, das war doch schon.
Na also, erstens, Apple hat jetzt Exxon so richtig böse eingeholt. Aber jetzt so richtig und deutlich.
Ja, jetzt haben sie alle eingeholt.
Genau, also sind jetzt auch dann irgendwie vor zwei Tagen, wie ist es so, erstmals über 500 Dollar, jetzt sind sie schon wieder bei 500, lass mich gucken, bestimmt 530 oder so, die steigen ja hier im Minutentakt. Und jetzt ist ja der Kurs an sich erstmal nicht so spannend. Stimmt's, stimmt's Jungs? Gern. Aber der Kurs, der steigt da, also meiner Meinung nach, der steigt da nicht einfach so, sondern dass er jetzt innerhalb von einer Woche wirklich so krass gestiegen ist. Ich glaube, da kommt demnächst irgendwas richtig doll Großes, weil das muss ja ein Grund haben, dass der so steigt.
Was richtig doll Großes, natürlich ist ein Grund. Das ist ja kein Geheimnis, weil was die Börsianer denken, die haben ja keine Ahnung, sondern die folgen einfach immer nur der aktuellen Gerüchteküche. Und alle rechnen halt damit, dass Apple in den Fernsehmarkt einsteigt.
Ja, aber warum steigt es jetzt gerade in der letzten Woche genauso stark?
Naja, es gab noch das iPad 3-Gerücht.
Weil jetzt das iPad 3 kommt und weil viele Leute der Meinung sind, dass das iPad 3 ein wichtiger Baustein ist.
Wo kam das iPhone 4S? Da ist der Kurs nie so stark gestiegen wie jetzt gerade.
Weil sie mittlerweile eingesehen haben, dass es keinen iPad-Killer gibt. Nicht auch nur im Ansatz auf absehbare Zeit.
Doch! Und so konzentriert auf die letzte Woche?
Naja, eben. Bitte?
So konzentriert auf die letzte Woche?
So, ich kann dir jetzt nicht gerade sagen, was sich da kombiniert hat. Ich verstehe, was du da auch nur so schwänzt.
Das sind wahrscheinlich alle, die ihr Geld aus Griechenland rausgezogen hat. Jetzt irgendwo investieren müssen.
Ich weiß natürlich auch nicht, was es ist, aber ich denke, da kommt demnächst irgendwas Dickes.
Ja, da kommt auch was Dickes. Es ist ja im Wesentlichen auch schon absehbar, was da kommt. Da kommt halt das iPad 3. Und ich denke, das iPad 3 wird definitiv noch mehr auf den Tisch legen, als nur eine höhere Auflösung, schnellerer Prozessor, etc.
Ein Cloud 2.
Naja, so 1080p, tralala. Und ich meine, wie es sich gerade entwickelt ist so, das iPad gehört künftig zumindest den US-amerikanischen Haushalten zur Standardausrüstung des Wohnzimmersophers. Es liegt da rum, wie früher Fernbedienungen rum lagen. Weil man da halt dann, während man irgendwie...
Der Tablet-Markt ist größer als der PC-Markt, sagte der Tim Cook. Und ich glaube, er hat recht.
Genau.
Das Apple TV wird das iPad 3.
Naja, das...
Na, das Apple TV ist ja schon da. Das Apple TV ist ja quasi die Verbindung zwischen einem iPad und großem Fernseher.
Na, jemand wahrscheinlich so.
Du hast halt ein Top-User-Interface. Du kannst da mit Airplay drauf streamen. Also, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es so unbedingt Not tut, dass sie einen eigenen Fernseher haben. Ja, das Hauptproblem, also technisch finde ich, ist die Lösung in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass viele Leute heutzutage sowieso schon mit so einer Myriade von Set-Top-Boxen und so weiter herumfummeln. Da ist dieses Apple TV schon fast ein Segen, weil es sich halt relativ einfach bedienen lässt.
Ja, also so ein richtiger Fernseher von Apple hätte halt die Chance, dass du keine weitere Fernbedienung hast. Weißt du, du hast so einen normalen Fernseher, da musst du irgendwie Ctrl-Y-7 drücken, damit du irgendwie deinen so und so viel dritten Input-Port aussuchst, um dann zum Apple-TV zu kommen.
Jaja, ne, das ist richtig. Aber wenn Sie wirklich einen Fernseher rausbringen, frage ich mich natürlich, was hat der so für Anschlüsse?
Na, Thunderbolt. Und Ethernet.
Vielleicht Antenne, vielleicht auch das nicht einmal.
HDMI auf jeden Fall. Also was ich, ich kann mir schon einige Sachen vorstellen.
Ist das ein Fernseher, der eigentlich nur noch Ethernet und WLAN hat?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube, das wäre der Traumfernseher, den sich Apple wünschen würde. Aber das können sie nur machen, wenn sie auch in der Lage sind, für dieses Gerät dasselbe Programming zu bieten, wie so ein Kabelnetzbetreiber. Und dann auch haben sie das Problem, dass ihnen Comcast da in den USA einfach schwer in die Suppe spucken wird. Auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Sollen sie kaufen? Nein, aber...
Ja...
Ich meine, das Ding ist halt echt so... Der Content, den es an diesem iTunes-Store gibt oder den es auch sonst so bei Netflix und sonst so gibt, da fehlt halt auch einfach extrem viel. Also ich könnte jetzt nicht sozusagen...
Aber da gab es ja bei der Einführung des iPods auch noch nicht so viel Content und der kam dann. Also ich meine, irgendwann muss man anfangen.
Ja, aber das ist im Fernsehmarkt einfach was ganz anderes. Weil derzeit verstehen diese ganzen Fernsehleute, ihre Einnahmequelle ist Werbung über möglichst breites Streuen auf viele Kanäle. Und derzeit kommt einfach die fette Kohle noch über Cable. Das ist einfach da, wo am meisten Geld generiert wird. Da kommt das Internet noch nicht mit. Das mag zwar irgendwie kommen, aber die sind es halt nicht gewohnt. Und jetzt kommt irgendwie Apple, die größte Firma der Welt. Alles, was sie anfassen, ist Gold. Und danach sind sie die Zampanos in dem Content-Geschäft. Das ist das, was sie sehen. Die Musikindustrie hat Apple einfach bei den Eiern. Und die wollen halt nicht, dass ihnen Tim Cook auch noch irgendwie ein Bellen rumspielt. Und deswegen versuchen sie halt, irgendwie zwar davon zu profitieren, aber eben jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie die Kontrolle verlieren. Und von daher sind ihnen die anderen Mitspieler da auch relativ recht. Und deswegen kriegt Apple einfach nicht den Content. Angenommen, Apple hätte Zugriff auf jeden Film. Sie könnten jeden Film verleihen und jeden Film kaufen. Apple TV würde sich wahrscheinlich besser verkaufen als das iPad.
Aber die Frage ist doch, wenn die jetzt so viel Kohle haben, können die nicht einfach diese komischen Studios da einfach so schnick schnack kaufen? Die sind doch nicht so viel wert. Aber wahrscheinlich ist das alles so ein Konklungerat.
Disney gehört ihnen ja schon.
Ich kann dir sagen, warum sie es vielleicht nicht tun. Weil sie natürlich damit sofort in so einen Interessenkonflikt geraten, wie Sony zum Beispiel. Sony hat ja damals auch sich Fernseh... was soll ich machen?
Den DSR ausschalten.
Ich mach mal was anderes hier. Sony hat...
Und schon sind wir raus.
Nein, nein, nein.
Weiter machen.
Sony hat damals... wen haben sie gekauft?
Was hat der hier gemacht?
Columbia war das. Damit waren sie im Content-Business. Parallel dazu wollten sie irgendwie ihre neuen Formate durchbringen. Minidisc, ihr beklopptes DAT-Tape und so weiter. Und da waren sie einfach so janusköpfig. Also ich hatte auf jeden Fall mehrere Sony DATs.
Weil DAT ja relativ erfolgreich war, deswegen hätte ich jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, dass es von Sony ist.
Das war ein Flop.
Naja, aber im Gegensatz zu Minidisc fand ich, war DAT nicht so ein Flop wie Minidisc.
Ja, das mag sein, aber es war beides der totale Fail. Ich meine, das sind einfach Sachen, die nur in bestimmten Nischen gegriffen haben. Minidisc hat nur so im Mobile-Recording-Bereich so ein bisschen was gerissen. Und DAT hat sich einfach nur im Profibereich, in Studios durchgesetzt, wo du deinen eigenen Scheiß machst. Weil du damit halt einfach wegen diesem Kopierschuss-Kack. Und das ist halt das Problem. Sony hatte quasi den Feind im eigenen Haus. Sony Entertainment hat halt gesagt, das könnt ihr doch nicht machen. Und dann halt hier so Copyright-Bits und so weiter. Hätten sie den Scheiß einfach irgendwie, ohne darauf zu achten, einfach verkauft und gesagt, so hier machen wir doch eine Abgabe wie bei Kopierern und so, haltet doch das Maul. Ich weiß, eine Menge Leute, die sich damals DATs gekauft hätten, ohne Ende. Ich auch. Und auch diese Minidisc. Du konntest von dieser Minidisc zwar aufzeichnen, aber es war nicht möglich, die digitalen Daten auch digital auf deinen Computer zu übertragen.
Stimmt, da musste man irgendwie, das musst du...
Ja, da musstest du dir das große Gerät kaufen.
Ja, aber mein Codec war doch sowieso total schlecht die ersten Jahre.
Mein Minidisc-Player hatte ein Optical-Out.
Aber es war halt damals, muss man auch sagen, Minidisc ist halt damals noch gegen die Kompakt-Kassette angetreten.
Das ist richtig, aber...
Da war das viel besser. Das andere digitale System war CD und da gab es noch kein Recording.
Da gab es aber auch noch kleine Computer, um die Minidisc auf den Computer zu schieben, oder?
Wie, es gab keine Computer?
Ja, was gab es denn zur Zeit von Minidisc an Computern, wo die Qualität von Minidisc hätte draus spielen können?
Das ist ja das, das gab es schon.
Von wann ist denn das Minidisc?
Wann ist das hier eingeführt worden? Also ich hatte in den 90er Jahren Minidisc.
1998.
1998 auf keinen Fall.
Ich hab noch 2005 eine Minidisc benutzt. Da gab es einfach noch keine Flash-Recorder. Alter, es gab einfach kein mobiles Recording-Ding. Die Alternative war so kleine Analog-Bändchen, so diese Diktaphone-Minitapes.
Announced 92.
Entweder Kompaktkassette, Dutt oder Minidisc.
92 hättest du doch noch nichts auf den Computer geschoben.
Naja, du hättest bei Minidisc sowieso das Problem gehabt, dass Minidisc diesen komischen Attract-Codec hatte. Dieses selbst entwickelte Zeug von Sony, was ja auch so ein lossy-Codec ist. Wie MP3 halt nur viel schlechter.
Noch schlechter als MP3?
Viel schlechter. Zumindest in den ersten paar Versionen. Attract 8 war wohl dann relativ gut. Wie viele Versionen gab's denn? 8 oder 9 Versionen. Die ersten waren richtig schlecht. Das war halt auch mitten ein Problem der Minidisc. Dass dieser Codec so scheiße war.
Und bleibt mal ein paar Klammern zu schließen. Deswegen denke ich, dass Apple das nicht macht. Das ist auch nichts, wofür Apple Geld rausschmeißt. Und danach müssen sie sich auch noch mit dieser Scheißfirma auseinandersetzen. In der Idioten rumlaufen ohne Ende. Verstehst du, die ein Vertriebsmodell machen, was Apple eigentlich übernehmen will. Und die haben Zeit. Apple ist jetzt gar nicht eilig. Die haben es nur dann eilig, wenn es darum geht, die Produkte auf den Markt zu kriegen, für die die Zeit jetzt auch reif ist. Aber wenn die Zeit nicht reif ist, dann können die halt auch noch zwei Jahre warten. Gar kein Problem. Solange machen sie inkrementelle Verbesserungen hier und da und pflegen ihr Hobby, ihr tolles Apple-TV, und bringen halt Schritt für Schritt das rein. Solange, bis sie irgendwie diese Content-Quellen geknackt haben. Und es gibt ja immer mal wieder so Rumors, was sie so probiert hätten, bis hin zu so Werbungsanteilen und so einfache Modelle des Aufteils. Ich glaube, was Apple gerne hätte, ist, dass sie direkt mit den TV-Stationen zusammenarbeiten können und dann sagen, wollt ihr auch auf das Apple TV drauf? Ja, dann zahlt ihr irgendwie nichts, sondern wir zeigen euch den Content und die Werbung, die da gemacht wird, da gibt es dann irgendwie einen Split. Was weiß ich? 70-30. Der alte Witz. Vielleicht auch irgendwas anderes. So, und das ist an sich wäre das wahrscheinlich für die auch total mega lukrativ. Kann ich mir auf jeden Fall gut vorstellen. Davon abgesehen gab es noch dieses andere Gerücht, dass sie jetzt zumindest in Kanada, das habe ich nur so am Rande jetzt mitgelesen, weil ich da die Infrastruktur nicht so gut kenne, dass sie jetzt direkt mit diesen potentiellen Verhinderern reden, also mit diesen Cable-Anbietern, dass sie mit denen irgendwie einen Deal machen.
Haben sie mit einem Cable-Anbieter? Ich dachte, die hatten mit einem Breitband-Anbieter gesprochen.
So hatte ich das verstanden. Was meinst du denn mit Breitband? Ach so. Hab ich das falsch verstanden?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Du hast recht, da stand was mit Broadband. Ich hab das aber irgendwie... Also ich meine, auch Cable ist...
Du kannst über Cable auch Breitband...
Also Comcast, da hast du halt schnell das Internet drüber.
Also ich kann mir nämlich vorstellen, dass wenn Apple das Ding knacken wollte, dieses wir wollen eine Box, an die kein Cable hinten reingeht, weil wir die Cable-Firmen nicht mögen, aber wir wollen Content leicht haben, dann könnten sie in Deutschland zum Beispiel mit der Telekom kooperieren. Weil die haben ja diese ganzen Fernsehsender drin und haben diese ganzen Rechte dafür, und dann kommt da halt noch eine Apple-Box davor.
Ja, aber Apple wird sich nicht den Scheiß von der Telekom streamen lassen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber ihr wisst, dass die ARD gerade wo... Nee, war es die ARD? Na doch, ich glaub schon.
Weil sie müssen mit den Lokalen was machen.
Dass die ARD ihr Programm per Multicast bei Alice und Telekom einspielt?
Nochmal, wer spielt was bei wem ein?
Die ARD streamt ihren Content per Multicast zu Alice und Telekom. Das heißt, du meldest dir deinen Multicast-Kanal an und kriegst dann den Kram. Ohne dass die ARD das direkt zu dir schickt. Weil die machen halt Multicast. Die Hörer, die nicht wissen, was Multicast ist, müssen jetzt mal Wikipedia bemühen.
Das ist halt eine IP-Adresse, die nicht nur an einen, sondern an jeden geht, der unter der Adresse lauscht.
Die ARD schickt einmal, ist wie Broadcast, die schickt einmal, die weiß gar nicht, wer das alles sich holt. Wobei, das könnte man auch noch rauskennen. Sie müssen es nur einmal schicken. Sie schicken es einmal zu Alice und einmal zu Telekom. Und die schicken es dann über ihre Router immer an die Endpunkte, die es brauchen.
Genau.
Und ich meine, mit dem Fernsehen ist doch eh so eine Sache. Wenn das demnächst alle machen, Internet oder dieses IP, TCP-IP, so auf Ethernet-Ebene oder wie man auch immer das zu sich nach Hause holt, ist doch klar, dass das das Übertragungsmedium demnächst ist. Also Kabelanschluss oder DVB-T und so, es fällt doch eh alle weg.
Ich glaube einfach nicht auch nur eine Sekunde, dass diese Art und Weise, wie die Telekom derzeit Fernsehen verbreitet, nämlich im Wesentlichen, wir machen dasselbe wie aufm Ether oder aufm Kabel in IP, dass einfach da dasselbe kommt. Wenn Apple Fernsehen macht, dann ist da auch Bidirektionalität drin.
Das ist ja auch kein Fernsehen mehr, das ist ja was ganz anderes.
Ja, das ist dann mehr so Ups. Jeder, der dann quasi auf diesem Fernseher ist, hat dann da auch so seine Ab. Das wird auch noch mal eine schöne Privacy-Frage werden, wenn das mal Realität wird.
Du meinst dein Adressbuch wird zum Sende Gott?
Also kurz gesagt, ich glaube, das ist gerade der Hype. Sie sehen einfach, es ist die Zeiten, wo Apple keiner mehr zugetraut hat, dass sie in irgendeinen Bereich einfach mal so einbrechen, sind einfach vorbei. Wenn Apple jetzt sagt irgendwie, hier übrigens, wir sind jetzt hier auch in diesem Markt, dann schlottern die Hosen. Egal, ob sie da den richtigen Ansatz wählen oder nicht, aber jetzt schlottern sie erstmal alle. Weil auch ohne Steve Jobs. Naja, und ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum der Aktienkurs gerade nach oben geht plus iPad 3 plus überhaupt alles. Ich meine, das letzte Quartal hat, glaube ich, jedem die Illusion genommen, dass Apple derzeit in irgendeiner Form zu bremsen und zu stoppen wäre. Ich meine, sie haben sogar mehr iOS-Geräte, mehr iPhones als Android verkauft wurde.
Gab es nicht sogar auch diese Meldungen, denn es war bestimmt in der letzten Sendung noch aktuell, dass das, was sie an den iPhones verdienen, so viel ist wie ganz Microsoft mit ihrer gesamten Produktpalette.
Genau, nur die iPhone Business Unit macht mehr Umsatz und Gewinn als Microsoft insgesamt mit allem. Mit Windows und mit Office. Und da ist der Mac nicht drin, da ist das iPad nicht mit drin, da ist alles andere nicht mit drin.
Der Mac-Anteil ist ja jetzt nicht mehr so groß.
Ja, aber der steigt und wird größer.
Der Anteil vom Mac?
Nein, also absolut, was die Mac-Sparte ist ja auch in so gutem Zustand wie noch nie. Mal davon ganz abgesehen.
Den stoßen die bestimmt ab, den Anteil.
Ich glaube, das geht noch eine Weile weiter.
Ich könnte mir stundenlang dieses Steve Ballmer-Video immer wieder angucken. Das ist nicht einfach immer wieder...
Das wird noch mal der epische Fail des Jahrhunderts.
Aber du wolltest doch jetzt mal in die Glaskugel gucken und uns sagen, was in diesem Apple-TV jetzt mit dem richtigen Apple-Fernseher, was denn da jetzt drin ist.
Na, da strauere ich halt so ein bisschen, weil ich... Also, würden Sie jetzt so ein Gerät vorstellen? Ich schließe das nicht aus, dass das passiert. Ich wäre aber insofern ein bisschen überrascht, einfach weil ich mir nicht so sicher bin, ob die Zeit dafür schon reif ist, weil sie in einen Markt gehen. Ich meine, wenn du sagst heute Fernseher, dann gehen die Leute davon aus, dass sie das zu Hause an ihren Kabelanschluss anschließen.
Ja, oder eine Antenne in die Luft hängen.
Oder eine Antenne in die Luft hängen und hier DVB-T und so. Und das ist auch regional sehr unterschiedlich. Und irgendwie kann ich mir so recht nicht vorstellen, dass das die Produktkategorie ist, in die Apple reingeht. Ich kann mir eher vorstellen, dass diese kleine Apple-TV-Box sich sukzessive in diesen Fernseher rein frisst. Dadurch, ja, also, verkauft sich ja, hat sich auch im letzten Quartal, was haben sie gesagt, 2 Millionen haben sie von den Dingern verkauft. Das sind einfach noch alles keine bedrohlichen Zahlen. Aber offensichtlich zusammen jetzt mit Airplay und iPods, weißt du, iPad kann abspielen auf Fernseher und so. Die Leute haben jetzt ihre Filme auf dem iPad, haben ihre selbstgemachten Sachen auf dem iPhone. Diese Verbindung ist jetzt da. Und ich denke mir, sie warten das jetzt einfach ab, bis so eine kritische Masse da ist, bis sie irgendwann auch den Content-Providern sagen können, ach übrigens, wir haben irgendwie eine Installed Base von dem Scheiß, wo alles top funktioniert, wo alles immer die aktuelle Software hat, wo wir jederzeit neue Features einspielen können, wo die Leute das bedienen können, indem sie geschmeidig in ihrem Sofa sitzen und so ein Tablet in der Hand haben, wo du ein User-Interface deiner Wahl anzeigen kannst. Das ist ja nicht, dass das User-Interface auf dem Fernseher ist. Der Fernseher ist nur wirklich zum Anzeigen von dem Film oder was auch immer da gerade läuft, dem Video eben, plus vielleicht noch so ein paar Overlays, die sinnvoll sind. Aber die eigentliche Interaktion mit dem Fernsehsender, wo du sofort an Gewinnspielen teilnehmen kannst und wo du keine Ahnung...
Das will auch keiner.
Ach, das will keiner. Ich sag nicht, dass ich jetzt darauf warte, unbedingt bei RTN 2 Gewinnspielen. Ich sag nur, es gibt überhaupt einen Rückkanal. Den gibt es halt derzeit nicht. Guck mal, wie sehr die sich bemunen. Rufen sie uns an, gehen sie auf unsere Webseite.
Ich glaube, wenn ich da mal visionär sein darf, ich glaube, dass dieser Konflikt zwischen alter Fernsehwelt und neuer Internetwelt auch an einer ganz anderen Stelle steht. Nämlich, dass Fernsehen eigentlich immer live ist. Also live ist gut für einige Dinge, aber für eigentlich das meiste, was das Fernsehen macht, nämlich vor aufgezeichneten Zeug runternudeln, ist es völlig blödsinnig, weil ich muss zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt mich vor diese Käste setzen, um etwas bestimmtes zu gucken. Und das aktuelle Fernsehprogramm besteht ja eigentlich nur noch daraus, die Leute vor die Kiste zu ziehen zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit. Man bekommt ständig gesagt, was man wann, wie, wo zu gucken hat oder kann. Und ich glaube, das ist so eine Welt, die wird Apple wahrscheinlich nicht mitmachen, weil dieses Offline, ich sag mal, diese ganze Welt Podcasting, was wir ja hier auch machen, ist ja auch eine Offline-Welt. Ich produziere was, stelle es hin und derjenige, der es hören oder sehen will, kann es hören oder sehen, wann er will.
Ja, das ist ein Teil davon, zumindest wenn es um die Filme geht. Aber es gibt ja auch durchaus etwas, wo live eine riesige Rolle spielt und was auch mit so das populärste im Fernsehen überhaupt ist.
Na ja, Sport, Kriegsberichterstattung und was noch, wenn mal der Papst da ist.
Das füllt den Tag. Es gibt viele Leute, die nehmen gar nichts anderes wahr als Sport. Die arbeiten, kommen nach Hause, setzen sich vor die Kiste und dann gibt es entweder Bundesliga live oder Bundesliga Berichterstattung oder Rückberichterstattung.
Ja gut, aber das Fernsehprogramm besteht ja nicht nur aus Bundesliga oder Sportberichterstattung.
Also Last Time I Checked.
Tausende von Kochsendungen.
Ja, Kochsendungen. Live darf man nicht vergessen, hat auch noch eine andere Qualität. Wenn du einen Live-Kanal folgst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass deine Freunde oder Kollegen dasselbe sehen zum gleichen Zeitpunkt deutlich höher, als wenn du da aus deiner Videofilmkiste einen Film auswählst, den dir gerade vorgeschlagen wurde. Und dann kannst du halt am nächsten Tag auch darüber reden. Sowas wie wetten das gucken die Leute gar nicht mal nur so, weil sie die Sendung so toll finden, sondern weil das halt alle gucken.
Naja, wobei, das stimmt ja auch nur noch bedingt. Also ein YouTube-Video, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass in meinem Freundeskreis alle ein YouTube-Video gesehen haben, ist wesentlich höher, als dass alle die gleiche Live-Sendung gesehen haben.
Ja, weil natürlich auch jemand auf Twitter gepostet hat.
Ich will ja nicht sagen, dass sich das nicht ändert. Natürlich wird sich das ändern. Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass alles, was jetzt in den letzten 50 Jahren Fernsehen ausgemacht hat, morgen weg ist, nur weil da ein Apple-Logo drauf ist.
Nein, das war auch nicht das, was ich ausdrücken wollte. Was ich ausdrücken wollte, war, dass es diesen Konflikt gibt zwischen dem Live als Technologie, weil es nicht besser geht.
Versus on demand.
Wo ich sagen würde, 60 Prozent des Fernsehs ist scheiße, weil es live ist und nicht besser geht als live.
Ja, und weil es kostenlos ist, in Anführungsstrichen.
Naja, weil es kostenlos ist auch, aber halt auch einfach, weil dadurch, dass es zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt läuft und nur dann läuft, sind die Fernsehstudios auch in der Lage, da Werbung dazwischen zu klinken und dieses zu machen und jenes zu machen und sonst was zu machen. Also ich empfinde live, sagen wir mal bei 60 Prozent des Fernsehprogramms eher als eine Behinderung, als eine Bereicherung. Jetzt mal von den ganzen Ausnahmen, die wir besprochen haben, abgesehen. Und ich denke, dass gerade das Podcasting hat ja gezeigt, dass etwas produzieren, online stellen und ich kann es mir angucken oder hören, wann ich will, auch eine Bereicherung ist für mich als derjenigen, der eben nicht Zeit oder Lust hat, um 7 Uhr abends oder um 23.30 Uhr irgendwas zu gucken.
Ich meine, als Podcaster kann ich die Einführung des Apple TV gar nicht früh genug herbeisehen. Wenn man sozusagen auf demselben User-Interface-Level landet, wie ARD, dann kannst du halt auch noch dein eigenes Fernsehen machen, was sogar auf dem Fernsehen läuft. Das geht zwar jetzt auch schon, aber du musst dann halt erst ins Apple TV gehen, um da das zu kriegen, was du nur da kriegst. Aber wenn du halt das Fernsehen da kriegst...
Du meinst, wir wollen ja mit unserem Mobile-Max-Podcast gegen Wetten-Das antreten. Und die platt machen.
Naja, sieh doch mal ran, wie es Wetten-Das geht. Ich finde ja noch nicht mal... Die kriegen ja noch nicht mal einen Team-Member da irgendwie zusammen. Wir sind schon fünf.
Sechs. Wir könnten alle locker Wetten-Das machen.
Ja, genau. Wir sollten eigentlich Wetten-Das machen.
Wetten, dass wir auch diesmal über ZFS und Kalender reden. Was ich ja bei so einem Apple-TV, wenn einer kommt, also ich kann mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass einer kommt, weil einfach das liegt irgendwie, das passt zu Apple. Ich meine, iMac ist ja auch so ein komplett integriertes Gerät, wo es ja eigentlich keinen guten, also keinen extrem naheliegenden Grund liegt, warum das alles in einem Gerät ist. Und das würde beim Apple-TV glaube ich auch Sinn machen, weil Airplay damit schöner wäre. Weil im Augenblick, ich hab gestern, hab ich Klos und Spinne, weil du gerade sagst, auf dem Sam-Level spielen wie die ARD, hab ich Klos und Spinne, so ein iPad, da gelegen. Und dann hab ich, ah, kann ich mir ja angucken. Ich weiß nicht, ich kenne das, Volker Strübing, dieses...
Jaja, Volker Strübing, ganz lustig. Klos und Spinne.
Genau, lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Und dann hab ich ein Fernseher eingeschaltet und hab's per Airplay geguckt, was echt großartig war, weil das war eine fantastische Auflösung. Es hat echt Spaß gemacht, das dann auch auf so einem großen Fernseher zu sehen ist. Man hat dann plötzlich eine ganz andere Detailtreue und man guckt auch anders hin, als auf so ein kleines Fenster, also irgendwo im iPad läuft. Aber das Ganze ist halt alles noch scheiße kompliziert, weil jedes Mal, wenn du dieses Airplay einschalten willst, dann musst du auf dieses Icon unten draufklicken, dann geht der Apple-TV an, dann musst du einen Fernseher anmachen, dann musst du da umschalten, auf den entsprechenden, wie du schon sagtest, HDMI-Eingang. Dann musst du die Anlage einschalten und so weiter und so weiter und sofort. Und so ein Apple-TV, der einfach intelligent auf das reagiert, was da per Airplay kommt. Was heißt intelligent? Also der sich einschaltet, sobald er ein Video-Signal hat, und der nur die Tonquelle einschaltet, sobald er nur ein Audio-Signal hat, wo du dann einfach sagen kannst, okay, jetzt möchte ich gerne dieses Stück da abspielen und ich brauch sonst drum herum gar nichts zu machen, sondern ich brauch einfach nur auf dem iPad das zu sagen. Schon allein das ist für mich ein ganz grandioser Mehrwert. Und dann so Sachen wie dann irgendwelche Apps oder sowas, das ist dann, ja, das sind dann sicherlich alles noch schöne Sachen. Aber so diese Integration macht schon Sinn, finde ich.
Mir fällt da ein gutes Beispiel, also ein guter Vergleich ein. Das erste iPhone, das hatte keine Apps, das hatte eigentlich gar nichts und war trotzdem irgendwie so ziemlich das geilste Telefon, was es damals gab, weil viele grundlegende Dinge neu überdacht waren. Also so Sachen wie, dass es keine Tasten, keine Zahlentasten hat, weil man bei einem guten Telefon, gibt man einem Nummer maximal einmal ein. Dann weiß dieses Telefon die Nummer und dann wird sie unter einem Namen referenziert. Und ich muss nie wieder die Nummer eintippen. So etwas wäre für einen Fernseher auch etwas, was man unbedingt haben will. Also du hast sämtliche Programme nicht mehr, als habe ich auf Kanal 55, sondern ich tipp da ein A, ein R und dann bekomme ich noch fünf Einträge in meiner Volltext-Suche, ARD sonst was, ARD dieses und ARD jenes und dann tippe ich drauf und bekomme den Kanal. Wenn da jemand mal zu einem Fernseher ein ordentliches User-Interface machen würde, dann würde allein deswegen glaube ich schon den Fernseher verkaufen können.
Ja gut, aber das User-Interface denke ich auf dem Bildschirm selber kannst du nicht so viel reißen.
Naja, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst, du das Apple TV hat einen WLAN und du kriegst zum Apple TV dazu einen abgespeckten iPod Touch als Fernbedienung. Ja, muss ja kein iPad sein, aber ein iPod Touch ginge ja als Fernbedienung.
Ja, oder du hast einfach ein iPhone.
Kriegst den dazu oder kaufst du dir einfach dazu. Und dann kannst du das ordentlich benutzen.
So ist es ja jetzt schon mit dem Apple TV.
Ja, aber du hast ja immer noch den Fernseher dran hängen. Das Apple TV ist ja immer noch der geknechtete Sklave des großen Bildschirms.
Ja klar, aber ich verstehe, was du meinst. Wir reden eigentlich auch vom selben Ding. Ich sag ja nur, bevor sie jetzt wirklich so ein Gerät bauen, was nur, was Fernseher heißt. Im Sinne von ich bin quasi ein iMac ohne Mac, aber mit Apple TV eingebaut. So ein Gerät. Das ist sicherlich problemlos zu bauen für sie. Das macht irgendwie Full HD und Pipapo. Das sieht ordentlich aus. Sie haben die Bildschirme und alles ist super. Nur, wie kriegst du dann ARD rein, ohne hinten einen Kabelanschluss reinzustecken? Vielleicht denke ich mir so, okay, alles klar, sie haben es trotzdem gemacht. Aber mein Inneres sagt mir, Apple denkt sich die Zukunft des Fernsehens bestimmt nicht auf Basis von so komischen Broadcasting-Standards, die in jedem Land anders sind. Was für ein Produkt sollen sie denn da bauen?
Naja, das ist das iPhone. Das basiert ja auch auf so komischen Standards wie GSM.
Ja, aber der GSM ist ein weltweiter Standard, der fast überall da ist.
Aber ein Tuner, der PAL, SEKAM und NTSC kann, ist jetzt irgendwie auch keine schwarze Energie.
Du musst auch noch DVB-T machen. Du musst irgendwie für verschiedene Kabelfrequenzen was haben. Du hast die ganze Satellitenzuspielungsgeschichte. Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass sie mehrere HDMI-Eingänger haben und sagen, du kannst da auch noch deine Box anschließen. Dann ist aber dein Kabelprovider, der dir diese Box hinstellt und dir das Fernsehen macht, der ist dann sozusagen der Second Citizen. Du kannst dann da auch mit der Fernbedienung für dieses Gerät durchflippen und deine Fernsehkanäle, so wie du es immer gemacht hast, machen. Aber der Default ist einfach Apple. Und unser Content kommt einfach nur aus dem Netz.
Aber wieso sollen die nicht da DVB-C und DVB-S und DVB-T einbauen?
Weil sie das einfach nicht wollen. Weil das europäische Standard sind. Weil das einfach Legacy ist.
Was nehmen die denn in Amerika?
Weiß ich nicht. Aber bestimmt was anderes.
Wir haben bestimmt auch DVB-S haben.
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Aber da bin ich mir total sicher, dass da die Welt noch mal ganz anders aussieht.
Ich glaube, er baut Apple seinen eigenen Standard. Als dass die die ganze Welt zu bauen.
Der Apple-Standard existiert schon.
Der heißt einfach TCP-IP. Das ist ihr Kabelanschluss.
Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass die alle möglichen Kommission-Obscuren...
Ja, aber Fernsehen, also Live-Fernsehen über TCP-IP halte ich auch wiederum nicht für ein Zukunftsmodell.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wahrscheinlich gehen sie jetzt zu diesen Providern hin und sagen einfach lasst uns deine Setup-Box sein. Weil deine taucht eh nicht.
So.
Und es gibt doch jetzt auch...
BitTorrent Live oder wie war das?
Na, ich glaube, sind wir uns einig, dass wir das Thema jetzt ein bisschen durchhaben, dann können wir uns jetzt hier mal auch so für die aktuelle Gate-Beschichte...
Moment hier, Dennis hast du dir das angeguckt? Mit dem BitTorrent? Na, Bram Cohen hat doch hier neue BitTorrent zum Live-Stream rausgebracht, äh, announced. Hast du den nicht gesehen? Ich hab in dem Chat gepostet. Moment, den link den poste ich jetzt mal kurz noch.
Das ist ja nichts Neues, da ist er ja schon länger Zeit dabei.
Das heißt, so ein BitTorrent, der auch wirklich vorne anfängt, runterzuladen, das macht zwar viele Sachen an BitTorrent, irgendwie ein bisschen... Also ist ja gerade der Sinn und Zweck von BitTorrent, ist jetzt, das Live-Stream runterzuladen.
Ich hab das auch nicht so ganz verstanden.
BitTorrent Live hieß es, genau. Ich dachte, Dennis erklärt es heute eigentlich, weil Dennis...
Du hättest ja was gesagt, dann hättest du doch erklärt, wa?
Okay, dann reden wir jetzt erst über Adressbücher und Dennis liest sich das mal kurz durch und dann sprechen wir nochmal drüber.
Ich meine, wenn wir das nicht wissen, wissen wir das nicht. Jetzt Artikel durchlesen und die dann vorlesen, ist ja... My goal is to kill off television, sagt Colin. Na großartig. Ich dachte, das hat er schon gemacht mit BitTorrent.
Ist Fernsehen nicht schon tot?
Nee, noch nicht so ganz.
Noch nicht so ganz.
Also das ist so ein Zombie.
Der ist zwar tot, aber er läuft halt noch rum in Massen.
Und macht Dinge kaputt.
Peek Fernsehen.
Sieht eklig aus und ist auch ansteckend und wenn du dich da zu viel mit auseinandersetzt, dann...
Frisst vor allen Dingen das Hirn.
Ja genau, und dann bist du auch ein Zombie. Ist eigentlich gar kein schlechter Vergleich.
Wollen wir jetzt hier über Adressbuch reden und nicht hier rumscrollen in den Artikel. Das können wir auch noch nachher machen.
Bram Cohn ist auch ein bisschen älter geworden. Ich will jetzt bei diesen Themen nicht so sehr hin und her springen, wenn wir jetzt sowieso schon dabei sind über BitTorrent zu reden, kann Dennis ja auch noch mal seinen BitTorrent Update geben.
Wenn ihr hin und her noch lest zum Thema Live-Fernsehen, einen Ding hatte ich noch, hab ich glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt. Das Einzige, was ich zum Beispiel in Live-Übertragungen im Fernsehen so sportmäßig gut finde, ist ja von der NBA tatsächlich. Weil da hast du HD-Livestream von allen Spielen. Und da gibt's ja jeden Tag 1000 Spiele, hat man so das Gefühl. Und du hast halt auch Live-Metadaten, das heißt immer wenn Slam, Dunk oder sonst was kommt, taggen die das in der Timeline und du kannst dann auch später wieder da hinspringen und noch mal genau den von dem einen Spieler, den coolen Dunk oder den allen coolen Move sehen und so. Ist halt live kommentiert, live mit Metadaten in der Timeline gefüttert und in HD und on demand und super. So wie bei nba.com, so sollten alle machen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du Champions League gucken willst, hier Fußball, für die die Fußball-Grundung hat, dachte ich, ok, 21. Jahrhundert, ich hab ja kein Fernsehen und so, da guckst man ein Spiel jetzt über Stream, dann wollten die da 15 Euro oder 24 Euro für ein Spiel live im Internet in schlechter Qualität gucken haben. Das war...
Autsch. Live. Ja, das ist ja...
Das geht ja gar nicht.
BitTorrent Live gleich wieder.
Ja, genau.
Du, einer kauft das sozusagen, einer hat das legal und strömt dann gleich in die Wolke. Gut, naja, also BitTorrent Live können sie sich ja alle nochmal zum nächsten Mal angucken und dann erzählen wir davon.
Wir wissen jetzt nichts darüber, wir nehmen zur Kenntnis, dass es das gibt. Na dann können wir ja mal zu den Gates kommen.
Genau, Adressbuch-Gate.
Also nehm deine Dateien, dein Adressbuch vom Internet und laden sie mal hoch, weil könnte ja was drin sein, was man mal gebrauchen könnte.
Ja, und wem muss ich jetzt alles schreiben, dass ich mein Adressbuch gelöscht haben will?
Also Paas, die haben ja schon gesagt, dass sie es gelöscht haben.
Nenn mal die berühmten.
Instagram, die haben ja dann stillschweigend. ForceQuer?
Die sind stillschweigend hektisch geworden.
Und Twitter oder was?
ForceQuer, denn Twitter offensichtlich?
Also really Twitter, die laden mein Adressbuch, sagen nichts, steht nirgends und...
Also Twitter, die Twitter-App offensichtlich.
Ich lösche die jetzt instantan, wo ist meine Jacke?
Ja, erst mal musst du anrufen und sagen, dass sie löschen sollen.
Ich muss sie löschen, wenn ich mich da abmelde, oder?
Es gibt so ein... Also es ging vorhin rum, das weiß ich jetzt noch nicht, ob das offiziell ist, das hat mir jemand getwittert, das ist so eine kleine App namens Hipster, die auch so ein bisschen so aussieht wie so ein Instagram für Arme, die wohl tatsächlich das gesamte Adressbuch per GetRequest hochschickt. Also damit das auch wirklich nachher noch... Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das machen. Ohne S, ohne alles.
Ich meine, für Leute, die Adressbuch pflegen, da stehen Geburtstaten drin, da steht der Nickname oben drin, den vielleicht ja auch nicht jeder irgendwie raustun will, da steht alles drin.
Das ist was, was man nicht dringend verlieren möchte.
Ich finde es schon eine Schweinerei, dass sie es einfach so laden.
Nicht beliebig durch die Gegend kopieren.
Die Android-User laden das ja eh alle schon mal bei Google hoch. Die sind ja schon eh raus.
Die haben ja auch beim Kauf des Androids schon damit zugestimmt.
Ich lad mein Adressbuch ja auch bei Google hoch. Aber ich hab halt irgendwann diese Entscheidung getroffen, dass ich jetzt mein Adressbuch...
Dass du die ganzen Nicks und Geburtstaten und Adressen deiner Freunde bei Google hochlädst.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ja schön.
Der hat ja nur so Post-Privacy-Freunde, das ist eher egal.
Ach so, aber eben.
Die erwarten das. Also sorry, jetzt erzählt mir nicht das.
Max, du hast das Adressbuch noch nicht hochgeladen. Meine Online-Reputation sinkt.
Womit synchronisiert ihr eure Adressbücher?
Mit Kabel.
Mit iTunes.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Wie und sonst?
Na ja, entweder iCloud oder... Paranoid, oder?
Na ja, ich bin auch mittlerweile der Convenience.
Aber iTunes Backup doch!
Wie oft machst du das?
Wenn du mehr als einen Rechner benutzt, dann willst du es schon haben.
Also das ist vollkommen indiskutabel. Das geht gar nicht mehr ohne.
Und ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch ein großer Unterschied, ob man irgendeinen Dienstleister hat, mit dem man seine Adressbücher synchronisiert und den man dafür nutzt und wo man dann sagen kann, ok, den vertraue ich oder den vertraue ich nicht. Oder ob irgendeine App, die ich mir installiere, mal eben mein gesamtes Adressbuch durch die Landschaft puste.
Ist schon klar, ich will das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Da wird aber in dem Zusammenhang auch viel zu wenig darüber gesprochen, dass das eigentlich ein Problem von Apple ist.
Klar ist das ein Problem von Apple. Ich glaube, ich habe das in so einer Sendung auch schon gesagt, dass ich gerne hätte, dass die Apps von der Sendbox laufen. Und dass man sagen kann, Location, Adressbuch. Ja, aber die ist halt nicht so richtig dicht. Da läuft da Sand raus. Meine Adressen nämlich.
Also ihr habt es wahrscheinlich noch nicht mitbekommen hier. Apple hat jetzt während unserer Sendung schon angekündigt, dass es in einem kommenden Software-Update eine Abfrage geben wird.
Aha, dann doch.
Bei Zugriff aufs Adressbuch.
Was auch immer das heißen mag.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, wie viele jetzt gerade da sitzen und rasch die Adressbuch-Lauffunktion aus ihrem Programm laufen, damit sie auch garantiert das Update drin haben, wenn es dann soweit ist.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich kein einziges Programm auf meinem iPhone, was nicht in irgendeiner Form aufs Adressbuch zugreift. Also aufs Adressbuch zugreifen heißt ja nicht immer alles auslesen.
Aber das ist doch schon schlimm genug. Wenn Twitter einfach mal ein gesamtes Adressbuch hochlädt.
Welches Programm greift denn nicht auf ein Adressbuch zu?
Spiele zum Beispiel fände ich das mal ganz gut. Foto-Apps.
Gut fände ich das auch. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht so recht dran.
Also ich...
In Zukunft werden sie sich dann halt...
Es gibt ja auch noch unterschiedliche Methoden. Entweder sie greifen auf meinen Eintrag zu, damit sie rausfinden, wie meine E-Mail ist, oder wie ich heiß oder wie sie mich anquatschen können. Oder ob die plötzlich, wie bei WhatsApp, war es glaube ich auch, die Fragen aber, die halt das gesamte Adressbuch so Facebook-mäßig hochladen, damit sie gucken können, wen du da noch drin hast. Und da wäre ich schon gerne gefragt über WhatsApp. Andere Fragen halt nicht, sondern machen es einfach.
Ja, aber es ist halt, ich hab zum Beispiel, es gab ja hier diese IPTV-App, Viber hieß die, die ich ganz gerne mal genutzt habe.
Viber-Kram.
Viber-Kram, genau. Das ist gute Sprachqualität und kostet halt nüscht und ist halt einfach drauf. Und die fragen auch, die fragen nach. Und ich hab das mehreren Freunden gesagt, hey installier das mal, blablabla, dann können wir dann telefonieren. Und hab dann wirklich so wütend, ich hab das gestartet und da hat manchmal mein iPhone gefragt, dass diese App jetzt gerade probiert, auf mein Telefonbuch zu greifen und dann hab ich das runtergelöscht sofort wieder. Kann ja nicht sein, was sind das denn für Schweine, ohne mich zu fragen, auf mein Adressbuch zu greifen. Das waren die Einzelnen, die gefragt haben.
Da gab's auch vorpasst schon einige Apps, die das getan haben und dafür Shitstorm bekommen haben.
Dass sie gefragt haben, ja.
Genau, deswegen bauen das alle einfach so ein und sagen, wir tun ja nichts Schlimmes.
Ja, im Zweifelsfall passiert ja auch nicht. Da baut man die User-Basis mit auf und dann sagt man halt...
Aber wie kennenzulernen sollte bei Facebook? Das gehört dazu.
Ja, ich denke auch gar nicht mal, dass die meisten Leute so ein Problem damit haben, wenn sie diesen Vertrauenslevel haben. Weil auch viele glaube ich davon ausgehen, dass ihr Adressbuch gar nicht interessant ist.
Ich finde schon, dass mein Adressbuch interessant ist.
Ja, natürlich. Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass mein Adressbuch interessant ist.
Das ist so unnötig.
Aber es gibt auch viele Leute, die das glaube ich nicht so sehen.
Ja, die können es ja auch laden, ist mir egal. Aber ich will gefragt werden.
Die freuen sich sogar noch über die Aufmerksamkeit, die das Internet ihnen bringt.
Oh, schöner will jemand meine Daten haben!
Fernsehen ist voll mit Leuten, die bereit sind, sich da nackt und tansend auf Eisboden zu stellen.
Daniela Katzenberger und Konsorten.
Ja, diese ganzen Penner und so.
Oh Gott, jetzt wollen wir hier nicht einfach drüber.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht über Fernsehmoderatoren reden.
Nein, wir wollen über Adressbücher reden. Von Fernsehmoderatoren.
Hast du eins da?
Für jede App eins.
Also die Funktion, warum die das Adressbuch hochladen, das ist ja durchaus eine sinnvolle Funktion, die man haben möchte. Vielleicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich will es nicht haben. Weil ich finde es immer viel interessanter, wer mich trotzdem findet.
Na gut, aber ich finde halt, viele Leute wollen das gerne haben, dass sie irgendein Social-Network haben, dass sie sofort sehen können, wer von meinen Freunden nutzt das denn auch? Das macht Sinn. Aber dieses Problem könnte man ja, und das ist ja oft genug angesprochen worden, wesentlich eleganter lösen, indem man einfach die Daten vorher hasht und dann nur den Hasch hochlädt. Dann kann man immer noch das Adressbuch abgleichen, kann gucken, wer hat denn die gleiche Telefonnummer wie ich. Aber man hat nicht dieses gesamte Adressbuch da auf seinem Server rumliegen. Zum Beispiel? Vielleicht sollte sogar Apple so eine entsprechende Funktionalität bieten, dass man auf so eine Haschwerte zugreifen kann. Also dass das Betriebssystem für dich...
Dass man Apple fragen kann, wen kennt denn der Typ auch noch, ohne dass die direkt damit was anfangen können, wenn die die Person nicht kennen.
Oder dass die Adressbuch-API dir eine Funktionalität bietet, mit der du einen Hasch von allen Personen dein Adressbuch bekommst.
Und von der anderen Person, und dann kriegst du zurück, woran was gleich ist.
Und dann kannst du halt matchen, wenn du magst, ohne das Adressbuch hochzuladen. Weil wenn die das offensichtlich selber nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, diese ganzen PaaS-Entwickler und Instagram-Entwickler, dann muss das ja irgendjemand machen.
Ja, ich meine mal ehrlich, also wenn du halt so eine Bude bist und dir ist das alles scheißegal, und dir geht es halt ums Geld verdienen, warum solltest du da voll Arbeit reinstecken, wenn du es doch einfach still und heimlich laden kannst, keiner kriegt was. Und man muss es ja auch mal so sehen, vielleicht sind die bei PaaS ja voll die netten Typen und die dachten sich, naja, wir haben voll ordentlich, wir haben ja irgendwie voll unser Krypto-Storage, wir laden zwar die Daten alle runter, aber die sind da voll sicher, niemand kriegt die, da kommt gar keiner ran, außer der Coder selbst. Nicht mehr der Admin kann das irgendwie, weil die verschlüsselt noch nicht mehr, der Admin kommt ran, sondern wirklich nur der Programmierer und der hat den Schlüssel da in Tresor gelegt und die machen alles voll richtig und keiner kriegt's mit, dann wär ja eigentlich fast alles okay, aber natürlich wissen wir ja nicht, dass die das halt so machen und deswegen ist Fragen schon eigentlich ganz cool.
Und gar nicht erst die Daten von meinem von meinem Telefon runterlassen, sondern sie vorzuhäschen, das wär richtig, richtig gewesen.
Richtig, richtig wär, wenn Apple halt dafür sorgt, dass es halt nicht geht. Solange es halt geht, werden die Leute das natürlich machen.
Ja, man wundert sich natürlich schon, ne? Also Location ist irgendwie so ein Thema, wo du da eine extra GUI hast.
Hat aber gedauert.
Wo du das ein und ausschalten kannst. Klar, hat gedauert.
Mussten erst Typen kommen, die das hier irgendwie grafisch aufbereiten, hier Location-Gate, ne?
Nee, aber Location-Daten konnten man schon vorher. Also das hat man schon immer nachgefragt.
Ja, aber für Apps gab's das kurz noch vor Location-Date. Das stimmt schon. Dass du Apps verbieten konntest, dass sie Location-Daten bekommen.
Ja, aber das war das nicht von Anfang an?
Dass er nachgefragt hat? Ich glaube auch. Du hast halt diesen Dialog dann in den Settings gekriegt mit den einzelnen Ausschalten wieder.
Genau, und sowas müssten sie eigentlich auch fürs Adressbuch bauen.
Ich glaube, sie wollen einfach nicht so wahnsinnig viele von diesen Abfragen haben.
Sie gucken halt nach, sie probieren das.
Ich will das haben.
Ja, das ist ein Vista-Problem. Ich will das auch nicht haben.
Aber guck mal, das ist doch mit dem Location, das ist doch voll entspannt. Ja, weil zu wenig ist. Und bei Adressbuch, alle, die es halt nicht brauchen werden, da wird ja dann auch nichts hochkommen.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, früher haben sie auch immer noch bei der Kamera nachgefragt. Ich glaube, das machen sie mittlerweile gar nicht mehr. Oder? Sie hat in letzter Zeit mal gefragt worden, ob ihr auf irgendeine App auf eure Kamera zugreifen darf. Ich glaube, das haben sie am Anfang für kritisch gehalten. Das haben sie am Anfang für kritisch gehalten. Und haben dann irgendwann gesagt, Moment mal, nee, damit wird keine Mumpitz getrieben. Und seitdem haben sie es einfach stilschweig wieder rausgenommen.
Aber du kannst ja bei diesem Setup-Requel, also wenn du jetzt so iOS und so neu dein Telefon das erste Mal anmachst, dann fragt er dich ja auch so ein paar Fragen. Und da könnten sie dann auch einfach am Start fragen, sagen wir hier, wenn jetzt eine App dein Adressbuch haben will, sollen wir dich fragen oder willst du das Default erlauben oder willst du das Default verbieten? Dann stellst du es einmal ein, je nach deinem eigenen Präferenzchen. Und dann, wenn du halt sagst, ich will immer gefragt werden, dann kriegst du halt diesen doofen Dialog.
Ich finde Fragen auch, also ich finde es nicht prinzipiell verkehrt. Ich finde es eigentlich gut, weil, also, ich finde es besser als bei Android, als sie es bei Android gelöst haben. Bei Android ist es halt, bevor du es runterlädst, musst du all diese Fragen, dann steht da alles drin, was will die App alles machen und du kriegst keine richtige Antwort. Und ich finde es so wie Apple, das macht in dem Moment, in dem du das erst mal drauf zugreifst, wenn du zum Beispiel eine App sagst, wo du es vorher gar nicht... Eine Wetter-App, jetzt ein klassisches Beispiel. Eine Wetter-App unter Android, wenn mir die sagt, ich möchte eine Location haben, dann denke ich mir, was will die mit meiner Location? Sie ist das erste Mal, wir können die Location an deinem Ort geben. Okay, sage ich trotzdem ja. Macht Sinn für mich. Oder gibt es sicherlich mehr solche Beispiele. Und vielleicht macht das ja auch bei so einer App durchaus Sinn, dass sie auf dein Adressbuch zugreifen kann. Also ich meine, hat ja auch seinen Zweck durchaus. Aber sie müssen halt vorher fragen. Und dass sie erst zu dem Zeitpunkt fragen, zu dem es wirklich notwendig ist. Und dass man da jetzt aber nicht 20.000 Abfragen haben will, verstehe ich auch sehr gut.
Ja, vielleicht sollten sie auch generell verbieten, dass man das gesamte Adressbuch zugreifen kann.
Also wenn ich eine Adressbuch-App schreibe, dann ist das total scheiße.
Warum sollte man das jetzt verbieten?
Das ist total scheiße, aber ich meine, Apple... Ich rede auch gern nochmal über die Sandbox auf dem Mac. Da gibt es ja, wenn man diese Entitlements anschaltet für die Sandbox, gibt es halt auch den Haken. Was ist hier? Allow Adressbook Data Access. Gibt es einen Haken, den muss ich anhaken, wenn ich das haben will. Dann gibt es den Allow Calendar Data Access Haken. Was es nicht gibt, gibt es halt den Allow File System überall Haken. Aber hey, ja, anderes Thema. Ja, warum will ich das nicht haben? Also sagen wir mal so, wenn sie es so machen würden, wie auf dem Mac, wo ich mir als Entwickler sagen muss, ich will die und die und die und die Haken will ich haben, und im Prozess, wo das dann angeguckt wird, das Programm, sagt Apple, ja, Moment mal, du bist eine Wette ab, wieso willst du das ganze Adressbuch auslesen können? Wirst abgelehnt? Das wär irgendwie, find ich, eine Maßnahme.
So, da gibt es durchaus Gründe, warum.
Können sie ja dann erklären, irgendwie beim Anmelden von dem Programm.
Ja, du willst halt die Adresse, du willst halt, wie ist das Wetter bei meinem Freund? Und suchst in dem Adressbuch, ich meine auch die Maps-Anwendung, durchsucht das ganze Adressbuch.
Ja, nur dann könntest du sowas machen.
Da muss man aber nicht hochladen die Adresse.
Ja, aber hochladen.
Aber hier geht es ja um Access, nicht um hochladen.
Ja, Access kann ja so oder so sein. Also du kannst ja als App, kannst du ja auch Access für ein Foto aus den Fotos bekommen, im iOS. Aber alles, was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst den Foto-Browser zeigen, der User sucht ein Foto aus und du bekommst als App dann dieses Foto. Das gleiche könntest du auch für eine, für eine Adressbuch-Anwendung machen, so dass du sagst, der User bekommt ein Adressbuch, Auswahldingen da, was so aussieht wie ein Adressbuch halt, sagt, diese Adresse oder diesen Kontakt wähle ich aus, und dann bekommt das Programm diesen einen Kontakt. Und nicht, ich lese die gesamte Datenbank aus. Weißt du, also Datenbank-Dump ist was, da muss mir ein Entwickler doch erstmal genau erklären können, wozu jetzt ganze Adressdaten.
Ja, ein Navi soll halt alle Adressen, die ich im Adressbuch habe, auch als Punkt anzeigen.
Also hier zum Beispiel...
Ja, der braucht zum Beispiel kein Geburtsdatum, der braucht keine Telefonnummern, der braucht eine ganze Menge nicht, und da kann man ja schonmal ordentlich koden.
Ja, von daher wäre es eher die Frage, welche Felder man für den Zugriff freigibt, aber nicht welcher einzelne Rekord jetzt. Also das ist für mich eigentlich das, ja zum Beispiel die Notes, die ich da drin habe, die möchte ich überhaupt gar keinem Programm geben.
Zum Beispiel?
So, mit E-Mail-Adressen. So, da kann man auch drüber diskutieren und Telefonnummern halt auch so. Und wenn dieser Zugriff, dieser selektive Zugriff, den sie da jetzt einbauen, ich weiß ja nicht, wie der aussieht, dann wäre es eigentlich interessant, also nicht, wenn sie nur sagen, oh ein Programm muss, damit es überhaupt funktioniert, auf das Adressbuch zugreifen. Dann hast du so zwei Buttons irgendwie, beende das Programm oder lass es weiterlaufen im Wesentlichen. Weil du dann entweder kann das Programm tun, was es will oder nicht.
Für 5.1 werden wir aber nichts anderes mehr sehen. Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie jetzt die Antwort sehen.
Die Frage ist ja, was wäre das Richtige und womit wären wir zufrieden? Und ich würde halt dann, wenn schon so ein Dialog kommt, dann auch erwarten, dass er mir sagt, auf was er zugreifen will und zwar nicht auf welchen, sondern auf welche Informationen aus diesem Adressbuch. Wo Adressen oder Notes zum Beispiel gar nicht rausgegeben werden sollten.
Aber das ist auch...
Das ist wirklich privat. Das ist meine Notiz über jemanden.
Ja, aber es gibt auch gute Gründe darauf zuzugreifen.
Wieso?
Wenn ich in einer Adressbuch-App schreibe.
Ja, was dann?
Und die die Notizen anzeigen soll.
Ja, dann kann ich das ja auch immer noch sagen, dass er das soll. Aber ich will halt auch sicher sein, dass ein anderes Programm da halt nicht drauf zugreift, wenn es das nicht braucht. Selbst wenn es nach E-Mail-Adressen sucht, selbst wenn es nach Telefonnummern guckt oder irgendwas tut. Aber Notes brauchst halt nicht, es sei denn es ist halt explizit eine Anwendung, um das Adressbuch zu verwalten. Dann kann es mein Ding auf alles zugreifen.
Was hat dir denn an den Notes stehen? Ich hab da noch nie irgendwas sinnvolles reingeschrieben.
Ich benutze diese Notes wie ein Verrückter.
Die ganzen One-Night-Dance, wo du den Namen nicht weißt. Da musst du noch was hinschreiben.
Also erstmal ist das so mein Tagging-Feld sozusagen. Also da landen halt einfach Text drin. So kann ich einfach suchen, wenn irgendjemand mit irgendeinem Projekt für mich im Kontext steht, was auch immer das sein mag.
Bei einigen Leuten steht da bei mir, wer ist das?
Ja, sowas will ich halt verhindern. Oder wo ich die Leute mal kennengelernt habe, um einfach genau dieser Effekt so zu machen, wer ist Hermann Mayer? Was macht der in meinem Adressbuch?
Haben die bei Paz dann auch die Bilder hochgeschickt, die im Adressbuch mit hinterlegt sind?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Nächste Frage.
Naja, aber wie will man so eine Abfrage machen? Dann hat man ja schnell so einen Facebook-artigen Dialog vor. Es könnte kompliziert werden.
Es könnte kompliziert werden.
Ich hab neulich mal bei Facebook, da muss ich ein kleines JavaScript für schreiben, das mir automatisch alle Checkboxen anwählt und kann dann sagen, welche Rechte man gerne hätte. Das sind wirklich drei Seiten, also relativ kleine Seiten mit Rechten, die man anfordern kann.
Aber ist auch gut, finde ich.
Ich finde schon, dass Apple den schwer machen sollte, aus meinem Adressbuch einfach alles so rausziehen zu wollen.
Mal ganz ehrlich, wenn Apple jetzt die Wahl hat, zwischen wir holen uns noch mal einen Shitstorm ins Haus und irgendein esoterisches Adressbuchprogramm schafft es halt nicht in den App Store, dann weiß ich doch relativ genau, was sie wählen werden. Naja, nenn mir mal auf iOS ein Adressbuchprogramm, was irgendetwas tut, was das eingebaute Adressbuchprogramm nicht tut. Und das ich jetzt unbedingt haben müsste, weil es das etwas Tolleres tut, als das Adressbuchprogramm.
Ich würde zum Beispiel gerne mal nach den Adressen suchen können. Das kannst du nämlich nicht. Und das ärgert mich.
Also ich hab eins, damit kann man...
Ich will Berlin eingeben und dann Leute in Berlin... Also überhaupt so mal...
Also was ich dir ganz konkret sagen kann, was für ein Adressbuch das ist, das ist eins, mit dem kann man Leute Gruppen zuordnen. Das kann man nicht mit dem eingebauten Adressbuch.
Kann man in diesem iPhone überhaupt irgendwas in Falle machen?
Genau, das ist auch ein Problem. Berlin ist jetzt nicht das Beid, aber wenn ich in eine andere Stadt fahre, und ich hab da irgendwas zu tun, und dann hab ich auf einmal 5 Stunden...
Wer wohnt denn in Hamburg?
Ja, dann kommst du echt ins Grübel ins Urlaub. Genau, und sowas gibt es halt auch nicht. Es gibt kein Mapping mit... Zeigt mir alle Personen, die ich irgendwie in meinem Adressbuch habe, im Umkreis von 50 Kilometern, und das wär mal ne schöne... vielleicht gibt es das ja auch keine Ahnung.
Naja, vielleicht bei Passets demnächst.
Gut, jetzt sind wir durch hier mit Adressbuch-Show.
Ja, hast mich überzeugt. So ne App muss her.
So, was haben wir denn noch Neues hier? Tweetboard gibt es jetzt für iPad. Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab's ausprobiert. Ist gut.
Funktioniert, ja.
Kann man machen. Ist gut.
Seit wenigen Minuten, auch während unserer Sendung, die Version 2.01 draußen.
Fucking news.
Schon kommt der 5.1 auf.
Kann man nämlich?
Man hat natürlich bei Tweetboard auf dem iPad sofort das, was man irgendwie immer wieder zwischen irgendwelchen Twitter-Applikationen haben will, nämlich Synchronisation der Timeline.
Tweetmarker?
Wo bin ich gewesen? Egal wie es heißt.
Funktioniert das mit dem Tweetmarker?
Jetzt seit 5.01 funktioniert es wohl. Ich hab's jetzt mal eingeschaltet, mal gucken, wie lange ich dem noch gebe.
Seit 5.01 war es seit iOS 5.01?
Nee, seit... Quatsch, 2.01. Seit Tweetboard 2.01.
Ja, fixes Tweetmarker. Und vorher hat es noch nie funktioniert?
Na doch, vorher hat es irgendwie funktioniert, aber er hat dann, glaube ich, auch manchmal ältere. Ich hab's nicht so genau...
Kannst du das gerade mal erklären, wie das funktioniert?
Ich glaube, das ist eine unabhängige... Also Tweetmarker ist ein eigener Dienst. Und ich vermute...
Der ist auch abübergreifend. Ja, aber funktioniert er. Also diese Echo-Phon... Ich hab da schon tausendmal Sync eingestellt und ich synke da alles irgendwie, aber ich hab einfach nicht den Eindruck, dass das irgendwas irgendwie synkt.
Also ich lese, was ich gerne hätte, wäre mal was, was synkt, welche DMs ich schon gelesen habe und welche noch nicht. Welche Tweets... So Tweetmarker, das interessiert mich eigentlich nicht. Die Bohne, weil ich follow so viele Leute.
Das muss aber Twitter dann unterstützen.
Und ich lese, wenn ich mal...
Warum macht Twitter das nicht einfach?
Das könnte ja auch so was wie Tweetmarker unterstützen, so ein Dienst. Der könnte ja auch einfach die ID der DM schicken, die schon gelesen ist. DM-Marker quasi.
So mit Hashes und so.
Danach dann Euro-Marker.
Ach, das wäre ja alles gar kein Problem.
Denkbar, denkbar.
Ich finde aber ehrlich gesagt, Tweetbot auf dem iPhone, auf dem iPhone bin ich ja großer Freund davon, auf dem iPad ist auch toll, ist großartig. Ich finde aber, es sieht irgendwie... Also auf dem iPhone sieht es gut aus, auf dem iPad nicht. Auf dem iPad hat es zu viel Raum drum herum und so. Da sind so irgendwie, ja lass mal hier mal ein Rahmen...
Bisschen Platzverschwenderisch sind sie schon, ja das stimmt, aber...
Dann würdest du auch mit 140 Zeichen machen, wirst du so.
Und das ist... Aber ansonsten, sehr gelungenes Update, macht echt Laune und...
Kann ich nur empfehlen, müsst ihr alle kaufen.
Kaufen, jetzt. Jetzt kaufen.
Jetzt draufklicken.
Ja, ich finde es gibt keinen Grund, das nicht zu kaufen.
Und es gibt auf jeden Fall noch ein Feature, was echt fehlt.
Und zwar?
Es gibt immer Features, die fehlen.
Nur die DM-Ansicht in der neuen Version, die ist echt um so vieles besser.
Die ist immer noch genauso kaputt wie vorher. Weil sie sortiert das genau andersrum. Ich meine, wie kann man den neuesten...
Oder was meinst du?
Genau, warte mal, jetzt wo du es gerade sagst, komme ich ins Grübeln, jetzt überprüfe ich mal kurz. Vorher war es immer falsch rum. Haben sie das jetzt geändert?
Das war doch noch nie falsch rum.
Na, es sieht jetzt aus wie iChat.
Sieht aus wie SMS oder Messages, oder?
Ja, das heißt, die neueste Nachricht ist unten. Während alle anderen die neuesten oben sind.
Aber vorher war die neueste immer unglaublich bei denen, oder?
Nein, das war schon immer scheiße.
Ich finde es aber in Dialogform wesentlich besser, weil ich lese von oben nach unten.
Ich lese bei Twitter die ganze Zeit von unten nach oben. Immer, die ganze Zeit. Und dann komme ich in die DMs und da ist es anders.
Krass, wieder 100 Hörer verloren gerade.
Ich will aber nicht, dass es so ist wie bei iMessage. Ich will, dass es so ist wie bei Twitter. Weil es ist Twitter.
Aber ich will so, wie es bei iMessage ist.
Weil es sind persönliche, private Nachrichten.
Ich suche die Option nicht, du wolltest die Option.
Ja, ich will sie haben.
Wo ist die Option?
Verdammte Fickscheiße, wo ist die fucking Option? Und was mich auch total nervt, bei diesen Direktnachrichten, du hast dann so diese Übersicht und dann siehst du immer die letzte Nachricht. Ich hab hier so, die letzte Nachricht ist in dem Fall tatsächlich auch von dir, aber wenn die letzte von mir ist, dann steht meine Nachricht trotzdem. Also hier bei Huckel ist die letzte Nachricht, die ich an Huckel geschrieben habe, steht da, aber daneben und darüber steht Huckel. Als wäre das seine letzte Nachricht.
Da frag ich mich immer, was wollte mir Huckel damit sagen?
Ist das nicht etwas, was ich ihm gesagt hätte?
Und dann ja, weiß das keiner mehr.
Okay, hast du mir gesagt, nein.
Also Tweetport ist super, aber diese DM-Geschichte, die ist völlig krank.
Also völlig krank würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Was mir persönlich fehlt, das mag für euch wieder nicht so interessant sein. Das ist eher was für Power-User.
Und immer so schön kleine Seiten hieven einlegen.
Es gibt ja diese tolle Retweet-Funktion. Du drückst auf diesen Button, hältst es und dann kriegst du ja die ganze Liste alle deiner Accounts und kannst das dann unter einem anderen Account retweeten. Was du aber nicht machen kannst, ist dasselbe mit dem Huff, mit diesem Fuff-Stern.
Du kannst das immer nur unter einem Account faffen.
Ich kann das immer nur in dem aktuellen Account faffen, aber nicht in einen anderen. Und das ist genau das, was ich gerne tun wollen würde. Ja, also das...
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen esoterisch, okay?
Das ist überhaupt nicht esoterisch. Für mich ist das wirklich essenziell.
Das ist lebensnotwendig!
Ja, ich sag dir auch warum.
Und nimm das hier mal auch ernst! Da kannst du doch nicht lachen!
Hier geht's einfach um die Essenz. Schmerzen verursacht mir das.
Die Nachbarn gucken schon komisch.
Meine Kriegsverletzung, sie brecht wieder auf.
Ich hab grad spaßenshalber mal ins Mobile-Max-Archiv geguckt, ja.
Ich hab das schon fünfmal erzählt. Nein, nein, doch nicht. Ich will dir kurz, Roddy, dich kurz bekehren, warum das total wichtig ist. Ich verfolge meinen wesentlichen Newsflow im Prinzip unter einem Account. Da hab ich irgendwie meine Timeline und da kommt alles Mögliche rein. Und auch Leute, die ich so kenne, sagen halt manchmal was, was für mich relevant ist im Kontext eines meiner Podcasts, weil ich es da halt gerne dann rauskramen würde. Also wenn du was über Apple twitters, wo ich mir denke, das wäre ja was für Mobamex, dann würde ich gerne so ein Pfaffsternchen drücken, aber für Mobamex. Dann könnte ich nämlich vor der Sendung für den Account Mobamex mal durch die Pfaffs durchgehen und da werden sie dann, bang, alle Nachrichten, die ich explizit markiert habe, als wichtig für die Sendung. Und das wäre für mich der beste Bookmarktdienst. Jetzt komm ich nicht mit Pinterest oder mit...
Pinboard.
Instapaper und diesem ganzen Quatsch.
Nö, komm ich dir auch nicht.
Sondern das wäre halt toll.
Vielleicht solltest du den Jungs mal eine Mail schicken.
Eine kleine Einschränkung dazu.
Ich wünsch mir, wo du es gerade sagst, bei Tweetboard Pinboard Support.
Es war nämlich bisher immer schwierig, diese Pfaffs auch wieder rauszukriegen, weil es ja fast keine Twitter-Apps gibt, die das irgendwie richtig mal anzeigen.
Also so bei...
Defaffen.
Bei Echo Phone zum Beispiel gibt es dafür keine Funktion. Du kannst nicht mal deine Pfaffs anzeigen. Listen, alles gibt es irgendwie. Aber Pfaffs, wieso auch? Warum sollte ich mir das angucken, was ich als merkenswert bezeichnet habe? Warum sollte man sich das nochmal anschauen? Sterben und aus dem Sinn. Keine Ahnung, was du sich dabei denkst. Ich fange da das an. Aber es gibt jetzt eine tolle neue App.
Ist das nicht auch einfach nur so Like-Button?
Jetzt werbst du es dir für Pfaff, das ist ja nett.
Jetzt werbe ich hier nämlich für Pfaff, weil Pfaffs ist nämlich im Prinzip genau das Ding. Da kannst du nämlich jetzt deine ganzen Accounts eintragen und siehst alles, was du da gefaftest hast. Das geht mit Google Reader, das geht auch mit deinen Flatterklicks, das geht mit was du so auf Insta-Papper hast. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich hier so eine Warenbarke.
Warenbarke ist ein Titelkandidat für diese Sendung.
Facebook und jetzt haben sie irgendwie Delicious, was ist dabei hier? Delicious, Dribble, Facebook, Flatter, Flicker, Google Reader, Instagram, Insta-Paper, Pinboard, Readability, Read it later, Stackoverflow, Twitter, Vimeo, YouTube und Zootool auch noch nie gehört. Ich bin mir sicher, wenn es da noch so einen Dienst deiner Wahl gibt, was da auch noch gefafft werden soll, dann kannst du das sehen.
Pinboard, Pinboard deswegen.
Jetzt äußern.
Gibt es gar nicht im App Store das Ding.
In Open Source geht es noch nicht so weit.
Nein, das ist noch Berta. Berta, Berta.
Kann man sich runterladen.
Ich habe vergessen, was ist die URL. Was ist das denn? fafsapp.com Fafsapp, Fafsapp, genau. So sieht es aus.
Schick.
Und das, das ist so was, was ich irgendwie echt gesucht habe. Was mir noch fehlt, ist halt so Syncing, weil ich will es, wenn, dann natürlich auch auf all meinen Macs haben.
Das S-Wort.
Naja klar. Ich will es auch auf meinem iPhone haben.
Ja, ich kann das verstehen.
Ohne Syncing, wer heutzutage eine Software entwickelt, der braucht gar nicht über Sync nachdenken.
Ja, und wer eine mit Sync entwickelt, der flucht wie bekloppt, weil es ist kein einfaches Problem.
Schreibt erstmal eine gute App, weil außer Tim braucht kaum jemand, jetzt lehnen sich wahrscheinlich ungefähr 3000 Leute, die es doch brauchen, aber brauchen nicht so wahnsinnig viele Leute. Macht erst mal gute Apps und danach, wenn ihr unglaublich viel Zeit habt, sagt der Mann, der sein Adressbuch bei Google hochlädt, macht er dann Sync.
Wenn du keinen Sync brauchst, warum lädst du dann deine Daten hoch? Einfach nur für Google als Futter?
Weil ich es auf dem iPad oder Mac haben möchte. Aber das sollen sie doch per iCloud machen.
Du hältst den Google-Moloch am Laufen, indem du ihm Daten fütterst. Ach, ich bin das? Ja, nur wegen dir.
Ich will, dass es Android weiter gibt. Wenn ich da mein Adressbuch wegnehme, dann ist Android gut.
Was hast du denn schönes im Mobile-Max-Archiv gefunden?
Ich hab gerade im Chat durchs Gerolde, dass Dennis angeblich in der ersten Folge sagte, dass Apple Evil ist, hab ich mal kurz ins Archiv geguckt. Da steht in der zweiten Folge schon ZFS. Die ist von 2008 und wir sind so konstant. Wer auch immer diese Statistiken für Mobile-Max gemacht hat, möchte ich gerne mal wissen, in wieviel Folgen das Keyword ZFS gefallen ist, so für das nächste Mal.
Oder David sollen es so sagen.
Aber er hat es erwähnt mit der Folge 01, weil ich da schon erzählt hab in Apple is Evil, dass Apple für das Adressbuch so eine Sperre einbauen sollte. In Folge 1.
Ist Apple noch Evil?
Klar, immer mehr.
Immer mehr noch. Noch mehr als 2008?
Also... Müssten wir ja auch sein, weil die Aktionäre wollen ja Kohle haben. Ja, wenn sie verkaufen, kriegen sie die. Übrigens, weißt du, wann es Dividende gegeben hat? Oder wann es zum letzten Mal Dividende gegeben hat? Bis ein Jahr, bevor es tief kam. Seitdem gibt es keine Dividende mehr.
Dividende haben sie abgeschafft.
Scheiß drauf.
Hat nicht Cook vorsichtig angedeutet, dass er sich eventuell vorstellen könnte, dass man ja so was machen kann?
Nein, dann sagt er mal, sie diskutieren drüber. Was man so machen könnte. Ob sie über Dividende diskutieren, sagt er auch nicht. Er sagt, wir sind weit am Diskutieren, was man dann mit so viel Geld macht. Und dann wiederholen sie die Frage so, und er so, ja, wir diskutieren. We're still discussing.
We're still discussing. Das ist auch nicht anders als bei uns.
Genau, Konsequenz.
Wir reden immer darüber, was man mit ZFS so machen könnte, wenn es denn mal da wäre. Aber jetzt ist es ja da.
Mit ZFS wäre Syncing wahrscheinlich auch viel einfacher.
Aber jetzt könnte er darüber reden, was man mit ZFS machen könnte, wenn es richtig funktionieren würde.
Nee, es funktioniert ja richtig. Aber nicht auf den richtigen Betriebssystem.
Die Herren, womit machen wir denn jetzt weiter? Rotti, du warst im Computerspülermuseum, oder?
Ja, ich war leider alleine.
Ich hatte heute leider keine Zeit, aber auch heute eine spezielle Veranstaltung, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Warst du da auch noch?
Steve war da und hat den Apple I vorgestellt.
Die fingen erst an, als wir hier angefangen haben, glaube ich. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber sie hatten diese Sonderausstellung alter Rechner schon irgendwie eröffnet. Und ja, ich hatte vorhin, vorhin hatte ich einen Tweet geschrieben mit einem Bild. Die Frage war, was auf dem Bild zu sehen ist. Und es wurde gemutmaßt ein Apple II, aber das ist falsch, es ist ein Apple I. Man kann dort, also in dem Computerspielemuseum, tatsächlich einen Apple I bewundern.
Nein. Und die gibt es doch wirklich extrem selten. 600 Stück oder sowas?
Sie haben 600 Stück in ihrer Garage gebaut. Ich glaube, da stand, es wurden 300 gebaut. Davon wurden 200 wieder zurück, weil sie sie nicht verkauft haben. Oder wurden wieder zurückgekauft aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Ich weiß es nicht. Und der Rest vagabundiert irgendwo rum. Und es ist schwierig, einen zu bekommen. Und ich muss sagen, ich fand das sehr faszinierend, weil also die Platine, also muss man mal sagen, der Apple I, das ist einfach nur eine Platine. Also die ist zwar voll bestückt, ist Speichers mit dabei, Prozessors mit dabei, ist alles drauf. Aber man kriegt weder ein Netzteil, noch kriegt man irgendeine Art von Bildschirm. Das Kassetteninterface, was man braucht, um die Kassette mit dem Basic drauf... Die gibt's noch mal extra irgendwie 60 Dollar oder was hat das gekostet? Da lag auch so eine Rechnung rum von dem Typen, der das gekauft hat. Und eine Tastatur ist auch nicht dabei, muss man alles irgendwie anschließen. Aber wenn man das irgendwie hinkriegt, dann läuft die Kiste und tut einfach. Was ich faszinierend fand, wie aufgeräumt diese Platine ist. Ist halt von Voss. Die ist richtig schön anzusehen.
Woran machst du das jetzt fest?
Du kannst jetzt mal das Bild posten.
Wohin poste ich denn das Bild?
In irk.
Also die Platine ist auch in der Wikipedia.
Ja, aber nach schlechten Auflösungen. Du kannst dir ja mal ein bisschen besseres Bild hier spendieren von der Wikipedia.
Und alles gesockelt natürlich, so wie sich das gehört. Alles gesockelt und die Widerstände, alle gleiche Seite, gleich alles, denn am Rand sogar hier so ein, wie nennt man das hier, so eine Matrix-Nummerierung. So eine Seite Buchstaben, die andere Seite Zahlen wahrscheinlich, damit du sagen kannst A5 und dann weißt du, wo du auf der Platine gucken musst.
Ja, genau.
Hat meine Amiga übrigens auch, ich hab letztens mal ein A1000 auseinander genommen.
Und es sind wirklich schöne Reihen irgendwie, also alle Bauteile nebeneinander und so. Also das fand ich schon sehr, sehr schön. Also so schön sauber aufgebaut hab ich irgendwie selten eine Platine gesehen.
Na wobei man könnte es natürlich, ohne jetzt rumkritteln zu wollen, man kann das schön aufgeräumt nennen, man kann es aber auch Platzverschwendung nennen.
Das kann man auch nennen.
Bei der höheren Integration, da würde ich ja sagen so.
Auf jeden Fall, SMD gab's halt noch nicht.
Ja, und ist das nicht auch erheblich?
Ja, aber das ist schon zweiseitig.
Nee, das ist schon zweiseitig. Also du siehst an dem Bild, dass da so Durchkontaktierungen sind.
Ja gut, es gibt oben und unten, aber es gibt jetzt keine Layer dazwischen.
Ja, aber oben und unten sind schon zwei Layer. Also wenn du sagst Single-Layer, dann ist wirklich nur die Rückseite der Platine.
Ja, schlag mich.
Also auf Deutsch das Ding ist, heute gehst du zu Sega, kaufst dir ein Aduino Duo und dann hast du alles das und noch viel mehr. Für 20 Dollar, Euro.
Ja, aber da kannst du keinen Bildschirm anschließen. Also ich würd's ja eher mit einem Beagle Board vergleichen.
Oder einem Raspberry Pi.
Da gibt's so einen Teil, da kannst du...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Jetzt muss ich auch noch mal gucken, wollte ich mir auch noch einen shoppen.
Mit so was kann man's dann doch eher vergleichen. Aber ich fand das Ding also auf jeden Fall schön anzugucken.
Na, aber es hält so eine Art Mikrocomputer, mit TPU und Speicher, das ist mehr oder weniger ein paar Ein- und Ausgabebausteinchen, oder?
Aber wahrscheinlich hat die SIM-Karte deines Telefons mehr Rechneleistung als das Ding, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Aber ich meine, wenn man halt...
Wahrscheinlich auch mehr Speicher.
Wenn man halt sehr hart beschäftigt, dann ist sowas eigentlich auch genau das Richtige, um reinzusteigen. Weil da kannst du echt jedes Signal noch verfolgen. Das Ding läuft mit wieviel Megahertz? Auch eins wahrscheinlich, oder?
Ja, nehme ich an, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau.
Ja, da kannst du mit jedem El Chipo-Scope-Meter kannst du dann auch irgendwie zugucken, wie da die Signale durch die Gegend hüpfen. Also da kannst du schneller gucken, als die Signale rennen.
Schön fand ich auch, da gab es noch so ein paar Dokumente, wo also einmal die Rechnung, die Kaufrechnung und einmal der Kunde hatte irgendwie dann geschrieben, ja wie ist denn das mit der Tastatur und so weiter. Und da gibt es einen einseitigen Brief, unterschrieben von Steven Jobs slash Apple Computer, wo er erklärt, ja ja, man könnte eigentlich jedes normale SG Keyboard anschließen. Das würde schon passen. Den werde ich auch mal kurz bei Twitter hier. Ich hau die einfach alle auf Twitter.
Habt ihr denn damals irgendwie so eine Art Tastaturstandard oder so was?
Irgend so eine Art Tastaturstandard.
Wahrscheinlich war eine Tastatur nichts weiter als Serial Output.
Nee, üblicherweise wurden die Tastaturen damals einfach so als Matrix angeschlossen.
Das kann auch sein, ja.
Das heißt, du hast einfach die Reihen und die Spalten quasi, also die Tasten so auf Spalten angeordnet. Und wenn du halt eine Tasse...
Du musst ja auch voll viele Pins haben, oder nicht? An dem Tastaturstecker.
Ja, das ist sehr parallel und dann musst du ja halt aussehen. Ja, aber ich mein, das ist die... Weil du hast keine Logik in der Tastatur. Die Tastatur ist einfach nur dummes Zeug. Das war beim C64... Auch so.
So, dann gab's zu sehen natürlich einen Apple II. Den fand ich auch so toll. Also eigentlich hätte man am Apple II auch schon wieder sehen können, wie Steve so arbeitet, weil wenn man den Apple II und daneben stand ein Commodore Pad, Personal Electronic Transactor, dieses Teil, das ist... Dieses Teil ist irgendwie in so einem komischen, winkligen Blechgehäuse, was so ein bisschen aussieht wie ein Roboter aus einem schlechten Science-Fiction-Film irgendwie, mit einer Tastatur, wo die Tasten so klein sind, dass ich mit meinen Finger da nicht ordentlich drauf tippen könnte. Und der kam irgendwie ein halbes Jahr nach dem Apple II. Und der Apple II hat wirklich eine ordentliche Tastatur, hat ein schickes Plastikgehäuse. Und was eigentlich noch am schönsten ist, da gibt's einen Monitor, der ein Monitor, der da dazugehört, da ist die Bildröhre drehbar gelagert aufgehängt, sodass man oben oder unten drücken kann und so ein paar Grad nach vorne und nach hinten drehen.
Beim Pat?
Nee, beim Apple II-Monitor.
Krass.
Geh dahin, schau dir das an, kannst du drücken und drehen.
Wie lange dauert denn diese Ausstellung?
Bis Freitag.
Echt nur?
Ja.
Ist ja sparsam.
Also morgen und übermorgen noch.
Okay, dann weiß ich, was ich morgen mach. Wann macht das auf?
Pat hässlich aus.
Pat hässlich aus. Aber den haben sie da auch da. Dann haben sie ein Original IBM PC. Eine Lisa.
Funktioniert die? Läuft die auch?
Also die Geräte waren da alle nicht an, aber sie hatten sie glaube ich auch gerade eben erst hingestellt. Die ganzen Schautafeln sind lustigerweise auch auf Englisch und Italienisch. Also weil es ja irgendwie aus Italien kommt. Und was sie auch hatten, waren Altair 8800 heißt der. So ein Ding habe ich noch nie gesehen. Das sind nur so ein paar Lämpchen und Schalter. Also den fand ich irgendwie auch ganz lustig.
Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie HAL 2000.
Ja, nur mit weniger Lämpchen. Und weniger HAL 9000 glaube ich.
HAL 9000, nicht 2000, stimmt.
Kann man auch im Film Pirates of the Silicon Valley sehen, wie Bill Gates zur HAL 9000. Hier, Roddy, guck dir mal Pirates of the Silicon Valley an. Was ist denn das für eine Webseite?
Und das Einzige, was sie nicht hatten, ich bin ja so nostalgisch geworden, weil an so einem Apple II habe ich tatsächlich auch mal gesehen. Alkostal geworden, daran liegt es nicht. Ich kannte viele von den Rechnern. Was sie nicht hatten, was ich echt sehr schade fand, war nämlich der zweite große Mitbewerber vom Apple II neben dem Pad, das war der THS 80. Den hatte nämlich mein Vater damals. Der erste Rechner, an dem ich saß. Und das erste Programm, was ich geschrieben habe, lief auf diesem THS 80. Den hatten sie leider nicht da. Das war auch so eine ganz hässliche Plastikkiste. So richtig hässlich.
Das war lange Zeit echt das Standard-PC-Modell.
Ja, bei dem war das. Der war so wie so ein Commodore C64. War das Ding, also so vom Formfaktor her, Platine unter der Tastatur. Und man sieht aber bei diesen Wikipedia-Bildern, sieht man aber noch so eine Kiste, wo der Monitor drauf steht, das sogenannte Expansion-Interface, wo man nochmal Speicher reinstecken konnte.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wie der Apple I, wann ist der? 76, 77, 78?
76.
Ja, wenn die da 76 sich so ein Ding gekauft haben, haben die angefangen, so was drauf zu programmieren. Die mussten es ja auch immer wieder eintippen oder auf der Kassette speichern, dass die sich schon ganz schön weit vorne gefüllt haben, oder? Die Leute, die so einen Teil bedienen konnten.
Auf jeden Fall. Die haben ja damals auch geworben, wenn du dir diesen Apple I kaufst, da ist irgendwie alles dabei und Speicher und viel mehr und so weiter, als wenn du dir jetzt einen so und so von der so und so Firma hinstellst, das kostet ja gleich zehnmal mehr. Also es war schon so ein bisschen auch so dieses, ja, wie soll ich sagen, dieses Raspberry Pi der damaligen Zeit.
Raspberry Pi, wüsste ich sofort, was ich damit anstelle. Ich glaube, mit den Dingern, die wussten selber nicht, was man damit anstellt.
Beim Raspberry Pi kannst du das Image schon fertig, schiebst es drauf, hast einen Linus, legst es los und so. Also das Ding, da musstest du sowohl Software können, als auch Hardware, als auch irgendwie Oscilloscope, wie also löten, machen, tun, also musstest du einfach alles können.
Ja, und wenn es dann irgendwann mal lief und du mit löten fertig warst, dann konntest du Basic anfangen zu programmieren.
Oder Assembler halt.
Oder Direkt Assembler, klar.
Also der... Mein Vater hatte diesen TRS 80 damals aus einem Laden, der hieß Enter Center. Den find ich so geil, den Namen irgendwie. Gibt's wahrscheinlich schon sehr lange nicht mehr, aber irgendwie fand ich das cool. Also so ein richtiger Laden, der Computer verkauft hat. Enter Center.
Ja, so viel Namen und Benennungen im Allgemeinen in der ganzen Computerbranche sind eine Geschichte voller Missverständnisse.
Nein, nicht nur in der Computerbranche. Also ich meine, dämlichen Namen gibt's auch noch bei ganz anderen Branchen.
Also es gibt Enter center.de, aber da ist leider nichts drauf.
Ich meine, könnte man sich nicht ein bisschen an den Friseuren orientieren?
Was meinst du so?
Friseure, die haben Humor.
Das nennst du Humor, diese Friseure-Namen.
Also sie haben schlechte Wortspiele, meinst du?
Die haben auch gute Wortspiele, finde ich. Man ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen übersättigt, aber an sich finde ich das lustig.
Kammerspiel habe ich letztens gesehen oder kam irgendwas mit Kamm, irgendwas in einer Kaiserschnitt.
Das gibt es bestimmt auch noch irgendwo die Haarspalterei oder sowas.
Unter Garantie.
Gab es noch so etwas wie Notaufnahmen?
Ja, aber ich meine, hey, das ist...
In die Haarwerkstatt.
Du gehst in den Quaffeur für ihn?
Ich geh mal zu Helga und Bernd, steht den Volksmann.
Die Haare sind auch schon so lang, dass du sie eh nicht mehr siehst. Und beim Rausgehen guckst du nicht nur mal nach innen.
Die sagen immer, ich soll ein bisschen früher kommen.
Also ist unser Überblick über dein Computerspielemuseum Besuch abgeschlossen?
Ja, war nur ein kleiner Raum. Ich bin auch nicht wirklich ins richtige Museum rein. Das ist nur so im Foyer so eine Sonderausstellung. Aber die kostet auch nichts. Kann man aber empfehlen, so eine Viertelstunde sich da mal hinzustellen und so diese alten Teile noch mal so in Original zu sehen?
Gibt es eigentlich von Apple I? Also wenn man wirklich mal so ein bisschen löten will und was lernen will und so, dann ob man das jetzt mit einem Admin macht oder mit einem 65002 ist eigentlich fast egal. Gibt es nicht da irgendwie so, so...
Apple II heute bauen?
Retro?
Replikas?
Replikabords oder so zum Bauen?
Keine Ahnung, aber wenn du nett fragst...
Oder Apple sagt es nicht.
Ne, ich weiß, dass man da was fragen kann und dass der Fragen zu dem Ding sehr gerne beantwortet.
Also wenn du nett fragst, kannst du sicherlich mit einem iPhone von der Vorderseite und der Rückseite ein Foto machen und danach kannst du glaube ich komplett reingenieren.
Also es gibt ja jemanden, der hat ein Replika... So leicht das nicht ist.
Gibt es nicht einfach für Igel hier, für das Latin-Layout-Programm die Daten und dann...
Also hier gibt es einen Replika 1. Und ich weiß von einem, der hat dann wirklich auch hat dann auch Voss angeschrieben, weil... Ach stimmt, da hat dann Voss irgendwann mal zugegeben, dass er eine bessere Lösung gefunden hat als... Also dass der Nachbauer... Hatte einen Bagger gefunden. Nee, hat für irgendein Problem eine elegantere Lösung gefunden, als Vossi hatte und daraufhin... Und der hat das probiert so.
Apple I Replica Creation gibt's bei Amazon. Was ist das, ein Buch oder ein Paperback?
Für 30 Euro.
Kann man auch mal machen. So, jetzt will ich wieder. Was gibt's denn?
Ein Apple I-Set für Weihnachten. So, wenn alles drin liegt, was man braucht, dann kann man dies heute in...
zusammenstatteln. Man braucht nur einen, machen sie auch Spaß halt. Und dann macht man so ein Basic drauf oder ein Game oder... Und so weiter.
Oder ein Bitcoin-Miner.
Themenübergang. Aber wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht machen. Bitcoin kommt später. Ihr kennt ja, wir haben ja bestimmt ja schon mal über Kickstarter geredet, oder?
Ja, das bin ich bestimmt.
Das wurde immer mal wieder erwähnt, aber mehr sind die Projekte, die da sind als Kickstarter.
Und ihr habt auch schon öfter mal hier über Monkey Island geredet und so, ne? Der hat da ja auch irgendwie gesagt, er will ja ein neues Projekt anstarten und hat irgendwie gleich mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ist der zweite Typ, der da über eine Million Dollar bei Kickstarter zusammengesammelt hat innerhalb von Stunden oder paar Tagen. Also ziemlich kurz. Darum geht es mir aber eigentlich gar nicht, sondern der erste Typ, der es geschafft hat, diese Millionen einzusammeln, ist irgendwie die heißen Elevation Labs und machen ganz simpel und banal iPhone-Docs und zwar aus irgendwie voll Alu, nicht so leichter Plastischeis oder ein bisschen Plastischeis mit so einem kleinen Bleiblättchen drin, damit es ein bisschen Gewicht hat, sondern so einen richtigen fetten Aluklopper, der irgendwie auf dem Tisch stehen bleibt. Und die waren die ersten, die irgendwie eine Million Dollar zusammen bekommen haben. Also so ohne Ende sind sie irgendwie bei anderthalb oder noch mehr.
1,5 Millionen Dollar für ein Alp?
Ein iPhone-Doc? Einfach schick, so ein Doc, wenn man einen haben. Und es ist leider vorbei, weil die haben ihre Kohle voll drin, weil da hätte es nämlich gegeben für, keine Ahnung, 250 Dollar oder 500 Dollar hätte man fünf Stück bekommen in der Luxus-Ausführung mit irgendwie schwarz anodisiert, was auch immer, irgendwie mit Audio und Netzwerk und alles und mit Laserdings drauf, also hier mit eingedingst, eingelasert und sowas hätten wir uns hier für unsere Sendung so mal mit Mobile-Max-Dings irgendwie einmal ordern können, aber es ist leider vorbei. Muss man jetzt einzeln kaufen. Die Leute wollen es einfach alle haben und die haben halt keinen Bock auf Plastescheiß. So ist ja ganz schön dieses weiße Plastezeug von Apple, aber es will halt keiner. Die wollen halt ein Ding, was halt auch da stehen bleibt, was auch so einen gewissen wertigen Eindruck hat. Einzige Bedenken, was ich hab, ist, dass eventuell das aktuelle iPhone-Gehäuse jetzt in diesem Sommer irgendwie vorbei sein könnte, weil vielleicht das 5er dann doch ein bisschen anders aussieht und da müssten sie da halt alle wieder das nächste kaufen. Vielleicht steige ich erst beim nächsten ein, aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz schick.
Haben die da nicht auch so kleine Gummiteile drin, die man dann so hinten reinkleben kann?
Kann man machen, je nachdem, ob man mit Bumper hat oder ohne, kann man da verschiedene Teile noch so ranpappen. Irgendwie sind da auch so leicht flexibel. Aber ich hätte halt gerne einen Dog, wo ich mein iPhone noch tippen kann, ohne dass es nach hinten umfällt. Und ich will aber auch nicht jedes Mal ganz vorsichtig drücken müssen, weil das geht halt auch wieder nicht. Das ist voll blöd. Ich will schon gut tippen können. Also soll ordentlich Gewicht haben. Also ich würde fast sagen, die sollen das nicht mal aus Alu machen, sondern... Baal. Lass mal hierbei zu Hause Starter so nix starten.
Wobei ich hab im Büro so ein Dock und ich nutze das nie, weil es ist halt so, wenn du...
Ja, weil es scheiße ist oder weil du es nicht brauchst?
Na, ich wüsste nicht, wofür ich es brauchen sollte.
Na, damit es drinsteht, dann... Ich hätte eigentlich auch beim iPhone eine Einschätzung, dass wenn es im Dock ist, dass es nicht in Sleep Mode geht oder wenn es Strom hat, dass es bitte anbleibt einfach die ganze Zeit. Das hätt ich. Dann ist es da die ganze Zeit an. Da kommt genug Power, wenn du es direkt am Netzteil hast zum Beispiel, kommt da auch genug Saft, das ist doch kein Problem.
Ich weiß nicht. Aber erzähl erst mal weiter.
Und dass ich es halt bedienen kann, ohne dass es nach hinten umkippt. Das hätt ich gerne. Und dass ich es die ganze Zeit sehe und nicht so schräg da liegt.
Ich hack das ans Ladekabel und wenn ich es bedienen will, dann nehm ich es ganz normal in die Hand. Das finde ich total doof, wenn man es so hochnehmen will. Man will es jetzt nicht unbedingt rausnehmen, weil wertvolle Ladezyklen verschwenden. Dann nimmst du es so merkwürdig hoch und hältst ja dieses Dock so irgendwie dran.
Aber das ist ja das Coole an dem Dock. Du kannst es einfach hochziehen und rausnehmen. Du brauchst keine zwei Hände. Das Dock ist so schwer, dass es einfach stehen bleibt.
Ja, aber wenn du entwickelst, dann musst du ja das Kabel dranhaben.
Ja, dann steckst du es wieder rein.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass du dann willst das drehen, damit du den Portrait-Mode hast, damit du das Drehen der ganzen Views angucken kannst. Und dabei muss das Kabel drin bleiben.
Dann vielleicht für euch als Developer ist das vielleicht nicht das Richtige, aber für die User so. Also, guckst du dir an, aber Kickstarter, die gehen alle ab wie nix. Die wollen endlich mal ein vernünftiges Dock.
Ich hab zu Hause ein Dock, das ist ganz cool. Das war eigentlich ursprünglich mal für ein iPod, aber es ist von der Größe so, dass auch locker das iPhone reinpasst, ohne dass es wackelt. Nö, einfach so. Steckst du einfach rein. Naja, da ist kein Kabel dran oder so. Das musst du natürlich extra reinstecken. Aber das ist insofern ganz cool, weil das steht in so einer Art Metallbecher drin. Du kannst das von der Neigung noch ein bisschen verstellen und du kannst diesen ganzen Metallbecher, der ist eigentlich so gemacht.
Also ist das kein originales iPod-Dock?
Nee, das ist nur so ein Halter. Aber du kannst diesen Becher, so wie er ist, im Auto auch in irgendeine Art Getränkehalter reinstecken. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, weil dieses Dock ist eigentlich für einen Getränkehalter gemacht.
Deswegen Becher.
Ja, deswegen Becher. Sieht halt so ein bisschen aus wie so. Aber es steht dadurch, dass dieser Becher, dieser eigentliche Becher relativ schwer ist, steht es halt sehr gut. Das schmeißt man nicht mal so immer.
Ich finde, das ist halt das Wichtigste, dass man es rausnehmen kann mit einer Hand und nicht immer fummeln muss und dass es auch schnell reingeht. Also so, ich will es einfach nur hinstellen und wieder rausnehmen können, ohne irgendwie was festhalten oder ziehen oder treffen oder reindrücken. Und so. Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob die da halt auch ein bisschen übertreiben, weil es sind ja schon Stecker, die reinflutschen. Es ist ja, also es muss ja auch einen leichten Druck haben irgendwie. Aber ja, wollte ich mal kurz drüber erzählen.
Wo kann man das jetzt kaufen?
Na, kannst du direkt bei Elevation Labs, kannst du in den Shop klicken und kannst du da eins ordern. Leider jetzt halt nicht mehr über Kickstarter. Da gab es halt bessere Preise irgendwie für die Frühbucher sozusagen. Und weil die Händler auch schon gesagt haben, oh Gott, alle wollen es, die Händler wollten es auch. Und dann gab es selbst für die Händler irgendwie für 10.000 Dollar, konnten sie halt sich irgendwie keine Ahnung, wie viele schon mal vorher schicken lassen und kriegen sie dann auch früher als die Leute, die es jetzt einfach nur so nachträglich kaufen. Also man sollte bei Kickstarter jetzt immer gucken, ob es da schon Sachen gibt, damit man möglichst früh dabei ist, wenn man sowas auch haben will, weil alle anderen müssen jetzt warten.
90 Dollar plus 20 Dollar International Shipping.
Aber guck dir das an, das geht ab wie nix. Na Elevation Labs. Ja nicht Lab wie P, an was du wieder denkst, sondern mit B.
Der Fisural war das Problem.
Hab ich gesagt, also ich find's halt ein bisschen...
Ach, da klickt man drauf, dann ist man wieder bei Kickstarter. Ach, hier ist der Store.
Ein bisschen blöd, weil eventuell diesen Sommer halt ein anderer Formfaktor von Apple kommt und dann stehen sie erst mal da. Dann müssen sie wieder ihre... Also müssen sie halt neue machen.
Glaub ich nicht. Das ist auch kein Problem. iPhone 4 ist einfach mal, und 4 ist es jetzt einfach mal noch, für drei Jahre mindestens dauerhaft gemacht.
Was ich dazu sagen wollte übrigens, durch dieses Dock ist mir das erste Mal aufgefallen, dass das iPhone 4 immer noch genauso breit ist, wie der iPod fünfte Generation. Und auch der Dock-Connector ist an der gleichen Stelle.
Was meinst du, warum?
Aber der war dicker.
Der war dicker, ja. Aber ich sag ja, breit. Breit ist es immer noch genauso. Also entweder ist es halt die Handform von Steve.
Genau.
Oder aber die haben gesagt, wir ändern diese Breite nicht mehr, weil es so viel Zubehör gibt, dass halt einfach auf die Breite und so weiter.
Es liegt auch wirklich gut in der Hand, oder?
Wird da ganz romantisch werden.
Jaja, das hatten wir auch schon.
Haben wir es jetzt mit den Docs irgendwie durch? Ja, haben wir es durch?
Genau. So, jetzt will ich weitermachen. Ich bin gerade dabei. Also ich hab ja irgendwie so ein Bitcoin-Pool, wo man irgendwie sich anmelden kann, damit man hier in der Gemeinschaft meint, also meint, sein Miner laufen lässt, wie auch immer.
Neulich gingen die Preise wieder ein wenig hoch.
Ja, aber die gingen auch neulich, nämlich die letzten zwei Tage, wieder runter gerade. Also es schwankt halt weiterhin hoch und runter. Aber es gibt auch, also alle denken ja, hier der Hype ist vorbei und hier der Early Adopter ist auch vorbei. Und da gibt es aber auch Leute, die sich angucken, auf welche Zeit Bitcoin angelegt ist und die meinten, nee, wir sind noch nicht mal bei Early Adopter angekommen. Weil es ja wirklich nur die totalen Freaks sind, die es benutzen und Early Adopter sind ja nicht die totalen Freaks, sondern die Freaks kommen noch eins vor den Early Adopters. Ob das jetzt alles so stimmt, weiß ich nicht, aber muss man halt mal gucken, wie lange es so läuft. Was ich sagen wollte, ist, dass mein Pool, der eine Weile Schwierigkeiten hatte, weil da ja auch irgendwie so ein Botnet irgendwie am Machen war, dass wir unsere Auszahlungsmethode vor, keine Ahnung, jetzt ist auch schon wieder vier Wochen her, glaube ich circa, von proportional auf Pay-per-Share umgebaut haben. Das heißt, es ist egal, wie viel Blöcke wir finden, wir zahlen den Leuten genau das, was einen so einen Share irgendwie wert ist, egal, ob wir jetzt Glück haben und dabei einen Block finden oder nicht, weil statistisch gleicht sich das für unseren Pool am Ende wieder aus.
Also...
Also vorher konnten wir das Glück haben, also zurzeit braucht man 1,4 Millionen Shares pro Block im Durchschnitt, statistisch. Wenn wir den jetzt aber schon nach 100.000 Shares finden, haben wir... Ein Share sind eigentlich 4 Milliarden Hashes, die du berechnet hast.
So ein Rechenblock?
So ein Rechenblock, so eine Einheit. Und davon braucht man... Na, weil es dein Anteil ist, weil damit findest du ja nicht einen Block, sondern man braucht 1,4 Millionen davon. Deswegen ist es dein Share oder manchen nennt es auch ein Proof. Damit beweist du, dass du 4 Milliarden Hashes durchgerechnet hast. So, wenn du jetzt den nicht nach 1,4 Millionen Shares den Block findest, sondern schon nach 100.000, dann warst du ja 14-mal schneller. Das heißt, die Leute kriegen auch so gesehen das 14-fache an Bitcoins ausgezahlt, weil wir den ja so schnell gefunden haben. Das heißt aber auch andersrum, wenn wir jetzt nicht 1,4 Millionen Shares brauchen, um den zu finden, sondern ist auch schon passiert, wir haben auch schon mal 4,5 Millionen Shares gebraucht, dann brauchen wir 4,5 mal so lange. Das heißt, die Leute kriegen auch nur noch ein bisschen weniger als ein Viertel. Das heißt, es schwankt immer, je nachdem, ob man mehr Glück hat oder mehr Pech hatte beim Suchen. So, und dann gibt es ja diese Poolhopper, die nutzen das aus, dass immer, wenn er schnell gefunden wird, da machen die mit und greifen das Glück mit ab. Wenn es aber lange dauert, dann sind die schon längst weg und meinen woanders und machen beim Pechen nicht mit. Dadurch verschiebt sich das. Warum machen sie nicht mit? Beim Pech machen sie nicht mit, beim Glück schon.
Ach so, beim Pech.
Genau, das heißt, die Leute, die beim Pech mitmachen, das Pech gleicht sich dadurch aus, dass man auch manchmal Glück hat. Aber das Glück ist ein Stück kleiner, weil die Poolhopper nur beim Glück...
So ist das Leben.
Wenn du so Altersweis hättest, hättest du auch bei Janis schon einen.
Nein, das ist mehr so Statistik-Ding. Das läuft ein bisschen anders.
Aber man weiß doch vorher nicht, ob man Pech oder Glück hat.
Na doch, von der Zeit her schon. Die Poolhopper machen einfach immer nur am Anfang mit und hauen dann ab. Das heißt, die erhöhen ihre Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie Glück haben. Da muss man eine Weile drüber nachdenken, aber es funktioniert. Das ist, was Poolhopper ausmacht.
Also, sind die Chancen noch höher?
Bei der Pool, der gerade angefangen hat, der noch null Shares hat, weil er kurz davor einen Block gefunden hat und dann losrechnet, da ist die Chance, dass er den Block bei 100.000 oder 200.000 finden kann, ist ja noch gegeben. So, bis 200.000 machen die mit und dann sagen wir mal, hauen die einfach ab und rechnen bei einem anderen Pool mit, der auch wieder bei Null anfängt gerade. Das kann zwar sein, dass wir den Block trotzdem erst bei 4 Millionen finden, aber es könnte sein, dass wir ihn bei 200.000 finden.
Aber man könnte doch auch von 600.000 bis 800.000 mitmachen.
Ja, aber dann kriegst du ja auch, wenn die Auszahlung ist, kriegst du schon weniger. Die versuchen immer möglichst.
Du bist noch vorne dabei, weil wenn er früh gefunden wird, ist die Auszahlung größer. Bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt mache ich mit, dann wird mir die Auszahlung zu klein und dann rechne ich woanders weiter.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass da, wo die bei mir, die sind halt die ersten 200.000 Shares dabei, dann hauen sie ab, dass ich natürlich trotzdem bis 4 Millionen rechne. Aber ihr Anteil an diesen 4 Millionen ist dann auch nur ganz klein, weil sie sind ja vorher abgehauen. Das heißt, sie haben relativ wenig Arbeit investiert. Die haben zwar auch wenig bekommen, also genauso wenig wie ihr Anderen im Anteil, aber nicht viel. Das heißt, sie haben ihre restliche Arbeit lieber in einem anderen Pool irgendwie reingetan, der dann eventuell Glück hat. Also meine User haben sozusagen Pech und die sind woanders und hatten dann eventuell Glück, auch nicht immer, aber jedenfalls erhöht sich deren Output um keine Ahnung, 10, 20, 30 Prozent, müsste man mal so einen Profi-Poolhopper fragen. So und damit das nicht mehr möglich ist, haben alle Pools irgendwie gewechselt auf Pay-per-Share. Das heißt, du kriegst einfach, wenn du einen Share abgibst, kriegst du einfach 50 Bitcoins geteilt durch 1,4 Millionen. Weil das ist genau dein Share, den du beigetragen hast und den kriegst du, egal ob wir einen Block finden oder nicht. Dadurch nehmen wir jetzt noch 4% Donation, damit wir unser Risiko mit dem Block finden ausgleichen können. Aber jetzt läuft alles viel entspannter, die Poolhopper kommen nicht mehr und meine Arbeitswelle ist jetzt irgendwie gleichmäßig. Früher war, wenn wir voll lange gemeint haben, wir waren schon bei zwei Millionen, also wir waren schon lange, lange überfertigt, dann sind alle abgehauen und die Rate ist voll eingebrochen. Und wenn wir einen Block gefunden haben, dann sind die ganzen Poolhopper gekommen und ich hatte 200 Giga-Hash irgendwie am Start. Und das war voll schlimm und haben sich viele Leute aufgeregt. Ich hab jetzt alles umgecodet und jetzt ist irgendwie Paper-Share und jetzt ist alles schick, wollte ich mal gesagt haben. Und Leute, die immer noch bei Deepbit meinen, ich hab das mal ausgerechnet, der verdient 60.000 Dollar im Monat. Und bei dem sollte man nicht meinen, er ist einfach viel zu groß. Sucht euch irgendwie einen coolen kleineren Pool. Muss ja auch nicht unbedingt meiner sein, aber cool wär's schon. Solltet ihr mal drüber nachdenken, weil der Deepbit-Pool ist viel zu groß und die Developer müssen jetzt schon immer abquatschen, was sie da irgendwie mit dem zusammen machen. Oder dass es ein Problem wäre, weil der ja so viel Mining-Power hat und so und so. Sollte es eigentlich nicht sein. Also verteilt eure Mining-Power ein bisschen mehr auf alle Pools und nicht nur auf einen. Amen. Genau. Jetzt dürft ihr wieder. Ich muss holen.
Immer in verschiedene Pools pinkeln.
Nicht immer an gleichem Baum pinkeln.
So, wir haben noch mehr so nerdige Themen, glaube ich, hier auf der Liste.
Ja, wollte ich schon zweimal drüber reden. Ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht mehr das brandaktuellste Thema. Aber ich versuch's mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen. Also.
Muss ein bisschen erklären auch.
Couch DB ist eine Datenbank, die so ein bisschen auch, wie soll ich sagen, also eine der großen Player, in der NoSQL Welt ist. Muss ich erklären, was eine SQL-Datenbank ist? Okay, eine NoSQL-Datenbank funktioniert eigentlich so. Also es gibt im Prinzip zwei Arten von NoSQL-Datenbanken. Das eine ist ein Key-Value-Store, wo man unter verschiedenen Keys verschiedene Values abbilden kann und das andere ist eine dokumentbasierte Datenbank, wo ich im Prinzip ein komplizierter strukturiertes Dokument in der Datenbank ablegen kann und die Datenbank dann für eine Suchabfrage ein Programm laufen lässt über jedes Dokument, das halt das rausfischt aus dem Dokument, was man wissen will. Im Großen und Ganzen könnte man das so sagen. Also das Stichwort da ist MapReduce. Es gibt so eine Map-Phase, wo dieses Programm, was man laufen lässt, sagt, ist der so und so Schlüssel da drin und was ist denn das Ergebnis von dem so und so Schlüssel und pustet das für jedes Dokument raus und Reduce sammelt die irgendwie alle zusammen, diese ganzen Key-Value-Paare, die Map ausgespuckt hat.
Raussuchen und sortieren könnte man also auch sagen.
Könnte man auch raussuchen und sortieren sagen. So, CouchDB wurde ja ursprünglich mal von einem gewissen Damien Katz oder Katz oder wie auch immer, der sich ausspricht, geschrieben. Stimmt das? Katz, der bei Lotus mal gearbeitet hat und irgendwie die Datenbank gecoded hat oder zumindest mitgecoded hat, auf der Lotus Notes basiert und das wurde ihm alles zu viel. Dann ist er da gegangen, wollte das Ganze nochmal neu schreiben, hat es seine C++ versucht, ist gescheitert, hat es dann in Erlang umgeschrieben, weil das ist irgendwie Erlang sowieso gerade der heißeste Scheiß ist. Nein, aber Erlang hat so seine Vorteile.
Sag es ruhig. Das ist der heißeste Scheiß.
Erlang ist gerade einer der heißesten Scheiße, auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen kriegen wir auch keinen Grimme-Preis.
Unter den Scheißhaufen auf jeden Fall einer der Wärmeren.
Also wenn ihr so in die Handfläche reinsteckt.
Dieses ganze Projekt CouchDB ist irgendwann bei der Apache Foundation gelandet.
Um da zu sterben.
Auf jeden Fall hat Damian dann sein eigenes Projekt bei Apache dann, glaube ich, Ende letzten Jahres ungefähr verlassen. Aus Gründen, die ich jetzt auch nur so halb nachvollziehen kann.
Also du musst jetzt auch nicht die ganze Geschichte wiedergeben, weil die habe ich auch. Da gibt es ja dann auch ein CRE zu.
Ja, also warum er jetzt unbedingt CouchDB, also die Apache Foundation, das Projekt verlassen hat, war, dass er der Meinung war, dass er mit Apache so nicht weiterkommt, weil die demokratischen Prozesse bei Apache irgendwie so sind, wie er sich das nicht vorgestellt hat. Es hat sich da um diese ganze CouchDB auch diese Firma couch.io gebildet, die das federführend weitergetrieben hat. Und die wurden aber dann wiederum von einer Firma Membase gekauft oder die haben gemerged. So genau wissen tue ich das nicht, ob jetzt einer den anderen gekauft hat. Membase, das sind die, die diesen Memcachedemon bauen und irgendwie eine Datenbank, die da oben drauf sitzt. Und die sind jetzt gerade dabei, dieses ganze Konstrukt mit Memcachedemon und ihrer Membase-Datenbank und CouchDB zu einem Produkt zusammen zu stricken, was sie Couchbase nennen. Das heißt jetzt auch die Firma. Und die haben, ich glaube, anderthalb bis zwei Jahre damit zugebracht, CouchDB nach iOS zu portieren. Und haben das irgendwann so Ende letzten Jahres dann auch soweit gehabt, dass man es benutzen konnte und mussten dann aber sich eingestehen, dass halt irgendwie eine Library, die allein schon 5 Megabyte hat, wenn man sie irgendwie einbindet, in sein iOS-Programm und dann auch noch 30 Sekunden braucht, um zu starten. Na, ich glaube, sie haben es auf 5 Sekunden runter oder so, aber auf jeden Fall ewig lange braucht, um zu starten, dann doch nicht so das wahre ist. Und was haben sie dann gemacht? Sie haben angefangen, CouchDB für iOS in Objective-C noch mal nachzuschreiben. Ja, unter dem Namen TouchDB. und die-
Man merkt schon, die haben lange Weile.
Und die speichern jetzt Dokumente als Blobs wiederum in eine SQL-Datenbank, um die hinterher als NoSQL-Datenbank betreiben zu können.
Was rauchen die denn eigentlich so?
Ich weiß es auch nicht. Auf jeden Fall gibt es dann wiederum einen Til-Klamm-Päkel, wenn ich den richtig ausreiche.
Ich glaube nicht.
Der sich da fürchterlich über all das in seinem Blog ausgekippt hat, dass das ja alles irgendwie nix wäre. Und dass ja das Couch-DB jetzt keine Zukunft hätte, wenn die Couch-Base-Jungs da irgendwie jetzt eine ganz neue Datenbank anfangen würden. Ja, im Großen und Ganzen, wie endet jetzt diese Geschichte?
Man könnte ja noch mal kurz vielleicht einwerfen, warum Couch-DB überhaupt machen wollten. Weil Couch-DB auch als primäres Feature hat, dass man halt mehrere Instanzen halt synchronisieren kann und replizieren kann relativ einfach. Und das sozusagen für das Synken, das magische Stichwort, eigentlich dafür sozusagen gedacht war. Weil das haben auch die Ubuntu-Jungs zum Beispiel erst gedacht für ihre Kontakte und so weiter.
Ubuntu One hieß dieses Projekt, was auch ursprünglich mal Couch-DB benutzen sollte. Die haben sich da aber irgendwie ohne weitere Nennung von Gründen wieder von verabschiedet. Die haben nur gesagt, das performt nicht, haben aber nicht genau sagen können, was jetzt genau nicht performt. Da hat sich auch dieser Till fürchterlich darüber aufgeregt, dass die zwar gesagt haben, ja geht nicht, aber sie haben eigentlich nicht konstruktiv gesagt, warum es jetzt nicht geht. Also naja, also Couch-DB, das stimmt schon, das ist das größte Feature von Couch-DB, ist, dass das eine Master-Master-Replikation kann. Das können eigentlich alle an einer Datenbank nicht.
Und Synken halt, also auch relativ schmerzfrei tatsächlich.
Na ja, das Synken ist ja diese Replikation, wo du also Teile oder eine ganze Datenbank wirklich komplett in eine andere Datenbank rüber replizieren kannst und auch wieder zurück.
Und die Dokumente sind auch noch versioniert.
Die Dokumente sind auch noch versioniert. Aber das hat erst mal alles nicht sein sollen. Es gibt jetzt irgendwie drei oder vier Branches von Couch-DB, je nachdem, was man alles mit dazu rechnet. Es gibt noch so ein Big-Couch und noch andere Branches. Ich hoffe, dass die sich alle irgendwie mal einkriegen und wieder zusammen zu einer Couch-DB werden.
Setzt euch mal alle auf eine Couch!
Ja, sonst haben wir irgendwie, sonst ist Couch das nächste SQL. Irgendwie machen sie es alle, aber irgendwie sind alle zueinander inkompatibel.
Hier, guck mal, da gibt's auch gleich den Link zum Touch-DB-Android, wo das dann wahrscheinlich nochmal in Java implementiert ist.
Richtig, richtig, richtig. Es gibt auch einen, der sitzt an der Android-Java-Variante davon und auf der Mailing-Liste gab's auch schon einen, der nachgefragt hat, wie es denn jetzt mit einem C-Sharp-Port für Windows Phone 7 wäre. Also eins, was sich die Couch-Base-Jungs auf jeden Fall auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben und ich glaube, dass es auch gut und wichtig ist, dass sie mal eine ordentliche Spezifikation von dieser Replikation machen wollen. Die existiert nämlich nur als lauffähiger Code, aber nicht wirklich als Spezifikation. Und wenn diese Replikation mal ordentlich spezifiziert ist, dann können auch, weiß ich nicht, tausend Leute irgendwie replikationsfähige...
Ingress-Touch...
.Kleins dafür schreiben. Also ich denke, das ist... Ja, so viel zum Thema CouchDB, wollte ich einfach mal sagen. Ich kann, wenn da mal wieder was passiert, was irgendwie interessant ist, kann ich da noch mal was dazu sagen.
Was heißt das, dass es an deinem Mobile-Max stecken fährt?
So wie das, was dem Dennis sein ZFS ist, das ist...
Das hab ich ihm ja auch schon fast weggenommen.
Ich hab ihn heute zurückgeholt.
Und Bitcoins.
Ja, genau. Das sind meine Bitcoins.
Ja, wollen wir dann mal wieder mehr über Macs reden? Oder wollen wir uns jetzt echt nur noch hier mit...
Da hast du ja auch ein schönes Mac-Thema.
Na du hast ja noch ein Android-Thema aufgeschrieben.
Das sagt er, der immer nur Microsoft und Nokia hat.
Ich hab nichts von Microsoft oder Nokia gesagt.
Ach, schon wieder habt ihr gehört? Eingewickelt.
Ich weiß nicht, da gibt es ja nichts weiter zu erzählen.
Also was ich da sehr lustig finde in Bezug auf Nokia, ist gerade, es gab irgendwann im Herbst, haben die hier in Berlin auch so eine kleine Entwicklerkonferenz gemacht, wo man...
Im Herbst.
Letztes Jahr im Herbst. Nokia. Wo sie Leuten beigebracht haben, wie man für Windows-Phone entwickelt. Zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es noch gar keine Nokia-Windows-Telefon. Sie haben darum jedem, der da war, ein HTC-Gerät geschenkt, damit er anfängt zu entwickeln. Jetzt haben sie noch ein Newsletter, ich war leider nicht da, noch ein Newsletter hinterhergeschickt, dass sie einem anbieten, dass sie noch so das kleine von den Lumia-Telefonen, die noch da oben drauflegen. Aber das musst du wieder zurückgeben, wenn du bis Juni dann keine App im Windows-Market-Dingsbums eingereicht hast. Also das ist dann so... Dann meinen sie es auch wirklich ernst. Das wollen sie dann auch wieder haben, das Telefon.
Die Zeiten werden härter.
Also für eine Veranstaltung kriegt man jetzt schon das weite Telefon geschenkt. Das hat nicht mal Google geschafft. Da gab es immer Pro-Veranstaltungen.
Apple hast früher die Maus geschenkt bekommen und dann Sitz geklebt.
Irgendwann gab es auch mal eine Eyesight-Kamera.
Da mal, weil es Apple noch scheißig, da muss man noch Teufel schenken inzwischen.
Die sind alle so dermaßen verloren. Die werden demnächst noch auf dem Hamburger Fischmarkt mit ihren scheiß Telefonen auftauchen.
Und hier gibt es einen Lumia. Und ich sag euch, das ist gar nicht alle. Ich leg nur einen drauf.
Das glaubt ihr gar nicht.
So ein heißes Angebot hier. Ja, aus dem hohen Norden.
Da kriegst du den Meerrett dich umsonst zu.
Noch ein Fisch dazu. Tja, während die Schlangen am Apple Store stehen, am Jungfernsteak und sich irgendwie die ganzen anderen Telefonbetreiber entblößen, dann darüber Witze zu machen, was so eine dermaßen krasse Anti-Werbung ist.
Diese Samsung-Werbung?
Da fällt mir echt nichts mehr zu ein. Also wie kann man damit werben, dass der direkte Competitor, dass da die Kundenschlange stehen für das Telefon? Ich meine, wer kommt auf so einen Scheiß?
Na Samsung.
Nee, das ist nicht Samsung. Samsung hat nur keine Ahnung, was sie tun sollen. Die sind hilflos. Gehen dann zu irgendeiner Werbeagentur. Da sitzt dann irgendwie so ein hippes, kokses Volk, die ja immer mit diesem ganzen Quatsch auflaufen, den du auch sonst so in der Öffentlichkeit siehst, wo du dich fragst, ob die überhaupt noch alle haben. Und dann halt sowas. Ich meine, die kann man einfach nur... Ja, also der einzige Hamburg-Bezug, den die haben sollten, ist, dass man sich danach in der Allstar versenkt.
Die ist aber nicht so.
Das Einzige, was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass Samsung mit diesem Galaxy-Tab, das ist selbst in Südkorea, wo sie eigentlich herkommen, das nicht geschafft hat, irgendwie die Dominanz von Apple zu brechen.
Ich hab das Ding neulich mal gesehen, dieses Galaxy Note heißt das, glaube ich. Das 5,5 Zoll-Display. Das hatte jemand auf der Acta-Demo, oder Anti-Acta-Demo hatte das jetzt best dabei und holte das plötzlich raus. Das ist also, ob du einen kleinen Plasma-Fernseher aus der Tasche holst.
Also so eine Holzschange, die man halt immer so hoch gezeigt und dann stand immer oben seine Botschaft, die dann so wechselt oder wie?
Das könnte man theoretisch machen, problemlos. Die haben ein Software-Update nachgeliefert, weil die Tastatur unten war zu groß, als sie über die volle Breite ging, damit du es mit einer Hand halbwegs drauf tippen kannst auf dem Ding. Darum haben sie jetzt eine Tastatur nachgeliefert, ein Update, mit dem die Tastatur unten schmäler wird, damit du das wenigstens halbwegs mit einer Hand bedienen kannst. Das ist echt eine totale Katastrophe. Also ich finde schon dieses Google Galaxy Samsung Dings, also dieses aktuelle Google-Telefon, das finde ich... Galaxy Nexus, Galaxy Nexus, Galaxy Nexus.
Heißt das nicht sowieso Nexus, wenn es von Google kommt?
Galaxy Nexus.
Wenn Google irgendwas mitbestimmen dürfen, dann...
Heißt das Nexus.
Wenn Google mal erlaubt wurde, die aktuelle Software auf dem Telefon aufzuspielen.
Sie schaffen es ja nicht mal, den eigenen Namen durchzudrücken. Das erste ist ja Nexus One, dann hieß das zweite, sollte ja natürlich dann eigentlich konsequenterweise Nexus Two heißen. Dann hat Samsung sich aber dagegen wohl gewährt, gerüchteweise. Nee, wir wollen aber nichts weiter sein. Dann hieß es Nexus S und jetzt heißt es halt Nexus Galaxy.
Also bei Blade Runner hieß es nicht schon Nexus Six, also ich habe mit sieben angefangen, mindestens.
Ich sag dir jetzt 2012, das ist der Niedergang von Google.
Ja, aber die haben sich, also mit Android haben sie sich komplett verzettelt.
Das war auch schon immer so.
Und wir haben es als allererstes auch schon gesagt.
Ich hatte ja gehofft, dass es besser wird.
Ja, die Kuh kommt aber auch nicht mehr vom Haus.
Das ist ja so geil, dass diese Android-Tablets irgendwie eine nennenswerte Konkurrenz darstellen können. Nichts davon ist auch nur im Ansatz irgendwie.
Ja, aber wenn die auch so einen Scheiß verkaufen. Also ich meine so... Ich finde das bei diesen...
Verwundert dich das?
Naja, aber bei diesem Galaxy Tab, da kommt jetzt die zweite Version raus, die zweite Version, die kann bla bla bla, ein kleineres Update. Das eigentliche, was wirklich ein Update ist, ist, dass sie die neue Betriebssystemversion drauf spielen. Und das ist dieses Galaxy Tab, das erste, das hat jetzt ein Update auf Android 2.3 bekommen, vor ein paar Wochen. Die aktuelle Version ist vier. Also die haben wirklich... Das Ding hatte, glaube ich, noch nie eine aktuelle Betriebs... Also auch als es ausgeliefert wurde, war es schon zwei, drei... Also war die Betriebsversion schon veraltet, die drauf war. Und sich dann wundern, warum man den Scheiß nicht verkauft kriegt.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Alles tragisch. Aber hier Chrome auf Android 4.0, das ist ganz schick. Das hab ich mir mal angeguckt. Hab ich mal hier... Ich sitze bei Soundcloud direkt neben den Android-Jungs und da hab ich mir einfach mal deren Telefon geschnappt und hab da mal ein bisschen mit rumgesurft. Da könnte sich wiederum Apple ein bisschen was abschneiden. Also das ist echt schick. Das ist so die Tab-Verwaltung, die macht eine Menge her. Schön schnell. Und ja, mal sehen, was dann aus so einem Bugs kommt. Aber hübsche kleine Details haben sie sich bedacht. Also beim FSCK-Log, der hat einen ganz wohlwollenden Artikel dazu drin.
Was heißt das, dass jetzt Chrome demnächst der Standard-Browser wird? Oder warum haben sie überhaupt zwei Browser?
Naja, ich nehme... Keine Ahnung, warum sie überhaupt den anderen Browser haben. Ich nehme an, jetzt sind sie mit der Entwicklung fertig und... Nein, dass der Standard-Browser wird... Erstmal muss hier dieses Android 4.0 überhaupt auf einer nennenswerten Zahl von Geräten sein. Dann ist es natürlich wie immer bei Google Chrome nur eine Beta-Version. Das heißt, bis es den Standard-Browser ablöst, wird auch noch eine Weile vergehen. Aber ich schätze mal so, das wird dann über kurz oder lang passieren. Und dann auch zurecht. Also dieses Chrome auf Android, das macht echt einen guten Eindruck. Das war echt... Auch so nette Sachen wie, wenn du im kleinsten Modus zwei direkt nebeneinander liegende Links probierst, einen davon abzutippen, dann zeigt dir die beide nochmal ein Groß an. Dann kannst du nochmal präziser auswählen und so was. Also da haben sich schon ein paar Gedanken darum gemacht, wie man das vernünftig machen kann.
Meinst du auch der Grube, dass das schon eine ganz schön dolle Verbesserung gegenüber dem vorherigen Browser wäre?
Also der vorherige, das ist auch nicht schwer, eine Verbesserung zu machen. Der war kompletter Schrott. Aber ich glaube, jetzt haben sie echt was vorgelegt, wo Apple mal wieder durchaus hoffentlich nachzieht.
Genau, ich glaube auch, der unmittelbare Untergang steht bevor. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt nicht so ganz mitbekommen, was da jetzt so, also wo jetzt da Apple in der Ecke steht und zittert.
Ich sag nicht, dass die in der Ecke steht und zittert, aber ich sag, dass das ein Browser ist, der gut ist.
Ja, aber ich meine, was war jetzt nochmal konkret besser? Also das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Also was ich, da sitze ich ja schon ewig an einer App, mit der man mal auf seinem iOS-Device auf seine Tabs im Browser auf den Desktop zugreifen kann. Das kann man zum Beispiel bei denen. Also er synkt deine Chrome-Tabs mit deinem...
Sync, sync, sync, sync!
Das ist genau das, was ich gesucht habe. 50 offene Tabs auf meinem Telefon.
Also ich find's nicht schlecht, wenn man auf seine Tabs zugreifen kann.
50 Tabs auf deinem Telefon.
Ja und?
Aber beim iPhone passiert mir das andauernd, dass ich dann mal unten in die Tabs gehe und merke, dass da wieder mal zehn Dinge offen sind, weil man's immer gar nicht mitkriegt, wenn man irgendwo klickt, in den nächsten kommt, acht geht nur, na gut, dann sind's immer acht.
Ja acht und den Ältesten macht er automatisch wieder zu.
Ja und damit kommst du schon nicht klar, siehst du?
Aber das Telefon kommt damit klar, nur ich nicht. Also das scheint dir schon alle mal aufzuheben.
Das Telefon kommt da nur sehr begrenzt mit klar, weil es halt irgendwann diese Seiten eh wieder aus dem Ram rauslöscht.
Nee, ist doch okay, sollen sie mal machen, das spricht denen dagegen.
Ich weiß nicht, das sind alles so Nerd-Features, die am Ende echt keiner will.
Ich will's! Und okay, dann bin ich vielleicht Nerd, aber das finde ich halt...
Wenn sie es besser anzeigen würden, dann würde ich es cooler finden. So gehen die immer so ein bisschen, sind immer ungenutzt. Also ich weiß gar nicht, dass sie da sind sozusagen.
Die haben das echt, die haben das wirklich ganz gut gemacht. Das ist so ein Effekt, also ist eigentlich nichts anderes großartig als eine Liste. Aber du scrollst halt so durch, als ob die so hintereinander liegen würden und du so oben wie in so einem Aktenordner so durchgehen würdest mit den Fingern, als ob die so umklappen würden. Und dann hat man immer ein Preview der Seite jeweils noch dazu. Und oben, das sieht auch so ein bisschen tabbig durchaus alles aus.
Ja. Und was gab's letztens Cooles? Es gab den Aufruf, dass die Entwickler jetzt doch bitte nicht mehr WebKit und Chrome, also Safari und Chrome unterstützen, sondern dass es ja auch noch andere Browser geben würde. Also die neuesten Features werden immer mit WebKit-Extension irgendwie eingeführt. Weil die nicht im Standard sind. Genau. Und weil es aber so viel Chrome und Safari gibt und die ganzen Entwickler benutzen es, kleben immer WebKit hinten dran. Und das finden die jetzt schon nicht gut. Also der Internet Explorer hat sich ja genau oben gedreht gerade. Bei uns benutzen sie nicht so viel Apple, das ist voll unfair.
Aber dass man da auch mal guckt, ob es da noch die entsprechende andere Variante gibt. Also es gibt mittlerweile ja einige Standards, die schon lange in den Standard übergegangen sind. So was wie Border-Radius, da braucht man wirklich keinen Minus-Webkit mehr davor zu schreiben. Also es gibt halt immer dieses Minus-irgendwas, was die Wendor-Erweiterung ist. Und Opera hat da irgendwie ein O und Mozilla das Mods. Aber was das eigentliche Ding war, das jetzt irgendwie, war das nicht das W3C-Konsortium, was Mozilla und Opera aufgefordert hat, auch Minus-Webkit, also quasi die Webkit-spezifische CSS-Erweiterung zu unterstützen?
Die machen das von alleine eigentlich. Also die machen das von sich aus, glaube ich. Es hat nicht das W3C gesagt. Der Typ vom W3C hat doch gesagt, irgendwie dass jetzt nicht alle Web-Development...
Nein, genau, das wollen sie nicht tun.
Nee, Moment mal, weil so viele Leute das machen, dass die Browser jetzt einfach anfangen, ah, das ist zwar nicht für meinen Browser die Spezifikation, aber ich nehme jetzt trotzdem das Minus-Webkit vorne dran.
Ja, und der Typ hat das doch aber so, diesen Gesamtzustand eher angeprangert, oder?
Ist das schon jetzt so, dass irgendwie Mozilla oder Opera, dass die diese Webkit-Erweiterung unterstützen? Ich glaube nicht.
Sie haben zumindest...
Das wäre auch ein großer Fehler, wenn sie das tun. Weil sie sind nicht Webkit. Und sie programmieren da was nach, was es nicht ist. Wenn du Webkit-Behaviour haben willst, dann kriegst du das einfach nur auf Webkit.
Aber für diese Properties, für Border-Radius oder was auch immer, wo sie auch ihr eigenes Prefix haben.
Ja, dann sollen sie eine kluge Webseite aufbauen, in der du deine Webseite reinpastest. Und dann kriegst du komplett gesagt, was du heute schon ändern kannst.
Aber wieso? Sie können doch einfach ein Wildcard-Match auf Prefix Border-Radius machen, weil es sich eh in allen Browsern gleich verhält. Weil es ist ja schon de facto Standard.
Ja gut, bei Border-Radius mag das jetzt funktionieren.
Das machen sie ja auch nur für solche Sachen.
Aber diese Features, es ist ja nicht gar ein... Ja gut, trotzdem sagst du im Prinzip, dass die Webseiten-Entwickler darauf scheißen sollen. Aber ich finde das schon völlig angemessen, darauf hinzuweisen, dass man sich selbst langfristig überhaupt keinen Gefallen tut, wenn man das jetzt macht. Das ist wie this page best view on Internet Explorer.
Ja, aber die Leute haben halt keinen Bock, zehn Jahre zu warten, bis das W3C aus dem Arsch kommt und die Spektrum zu nagelt.
Na ich glaube...
Die benutzen das halt jetzt. Weil es ist drin.
Das ist doch jetzt...
Ich glaube das Problem ist ja...
Darum geht es ja um Sachen, die schon da sind.
Na es geht aber auch... Also der Typ hat ja verschiedene Sachen angeprangert. Und dann gab es ja irgendwie gleich so die ersten Leute, die in der Replik sozusagen gemeint haben, ja irgendwie das Problem ist nicht, dass irgendwie jetzt die Browser-Hersteller da drum rum arbeiten, dass das W3C es nicht gebacken kriegt, oder dieses Konsortium oder diese Gruppierung von Firmen irgendwie mal eine Speck innerhalb von einem Jahr oder zwei auf den Tisch zu bringen. Also das ist die Ursache des ganzen Problems, das ist eigentlich eher so im W3C und wie dieser Standard da entsteht. Und dass es zehn Jahre dauert und nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie die Leute halt nicht warten können und anfangen das so zu benutzen, wie es halt ist. Das ist ja auch schon die ganze Zeit so im Web. Irgendwie bis der Standard dann tatsächlich in Granit gegossen war, haben die Leute das alle eh schon längst benutzt.
Stimmt, das wurde mal am Anfang von HTML5 ging es mal relativ flott und jetzt ist wieder alles stimmt.
Ja, aber auch nur, weil diese Witterhack oder wie sie heißen, weißt du, die Leute, die dann so neben dran gesessen haben, mit HTML, nee, XHTML2, das wird doch alles nix, wir machen jetzt mal HTML5 und dann irgendwie, oh Moment, jetzt wird uns hier grad der Teppich unter den Füßen weggezogen, jetzt machen wir doch auch HTML5.
Genau, dann wird es wieder langsam, seitdem das W3C da aufgesprungen ist. Wessen Schuld könnte das wohl sein?
Das W3C an sich ist ja auch nicht an sich schuld, sondern da sitzen halt auch Adobe, Microsoft und so weiter und die bremsen sich ja auch noch gegenseitig aus, aber ich finde das ja eher den richtigen Ansatz, da mit der flachen Hand auf die Kacke zu hauen und einfach erstmal zu machen und so Tatsachen zu schaffen, bis man halt, bis ich das so von alleine der Staub legt, anstatt jetzt darauf zu hoffen, dass das W3C dann irgendwie in 10 Jahren dann die ganze Situation geregelt hat.
Der Typ hat sich auch schon eher beschwert, weil die Developer einfach zu faul sind, danach nochmal aufzuräumen, also ist doch ganz normal. Hat sozusagen mit Apple gar nichts zu tun?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Und mit Chrome oder Google auch nicht. Also einfach nur mit faulen Developern. Aber ich meine, so ist die Welt normal. Wer räumt schon auf?
Da jetzt bei Apple die Schuld zu suchen, ist halt, also ich glaube, dass Chrome gerade, also Google, der treibende Kraft da ist. Wobei Apple ist glaube ich auch ganz gut, dass man die Features nutzt, aber da muss man halt auch dann die Seiten umbauen, sobald es in den Browser anders geht.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn dann so bestimmte Sachen sowieso alle Browser gleich können, da gibt es ja schon eine echt große Schnittmenge von CSS3 und HTML5-Features.
Ja, dann baue ich auch meistens das Mods ein und gucke, ob es so funktioniert. Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann fliegt das Mods halt wieder raus. Also der entsprechende Präfix für den anderen.
Ja, naja, also hier HTML5 und CSS3 und wenn, dann Präfix ist auf jeden Fall schon... Alles böse, eine ganz große Katastrophe. Und dann ist es ja noch schlimmer, weißt du so, das Web und so, das Internet damals, da haben die einfach RFCs geschrieben, da haben die irgendwie die Hippies im Internet, da haben dann irgendwelche Standards sich ausgeladen, es hat auch alles funktioniert. Heutzutage kommt halt Google daher, denkt sich dann so was wie Speedy aus, um jetzt HTTP zu revolutionieren. Dann klebt dann so in den Lizenzen auch schon, ja, du musst aber auch jetzt das Speedy-Trademark, wenn du das dann erwähnst und so. Alles, was dann so jetzt auch so Erneuerungen kommt, die eigentlich vielleicht potenziell toll sind, ja. Gleich wieder mit irgendwelchen, am besten auch Patenten und Trademarks drüber bügeln, dass es auch ja nicht sich schnell im Web verbreitet, sondern erst mal wieder, ja, aber das hat Google gemacht, das können wir jetzt doch nicht so einfach übernehmen und so. Ja, das alles ist schon, also das Web, also...
Aber es hätte ihm ja klar sein müssen, dass im Pflegeheim nachts um 10 das Licht ausgeht.
Im Software-Pflegeheim.
Nee, aber es ist schon, also... So richtig schön ist es da im Web eigentlich nicht.
Schön ist dieses Web nicht.
Was man nicht alles machen könnte. Und dann dieser Internet-Exploder, bei dem auch immer noch alles schiss hat.
Gibt's den noch?
Ja, nicht mehr. Also Chrome übernimmt jetzt so langsam von den Desktop-Browsern, aber es gibt schon noch zu viele IE-Browsers, dass man sie ignorieren könnte. Der kann halt einfach nix so.
Das hängt auch immer noch extrem vom Land ab. Ich glaube, so im China, da bist du noch so um 80% IE6-Bereich. Das ist ganz, ganz düster da noch.
Aber schon krass, wie Google es schaffen konnte, so schnell im Browser-Markt einzusteigen, oder? Da kann man ja fast froh sein, dass sie es früher nicht gemacht haben, sonst hätten die ja voll übernommen.
Schon beeindruckend auf jeden Fall.
So, jetzt sind wir schon fast am Ende, weil jetzt habe ich irgendwie keine tolle Themenliste mehr. Also die Themenliste habe ich, aber da steht jetzt nichts mehr drauf.
Nee, jetzt so abrupt?
Nee, abrupt nicht. Jetzt können wir sozusagen, entweder finden wir jetzt noch ein schönes Thema.
In den offenen Diskussionsteil übergehen.
Ich habe ja noch was, Kleinigkeiten. Und zwar habe ich mir runtergeladen aus dem App-Store. Ein Tool, das heißt SourceTree. Ich weiß nicht, wie neu das ist. Kennt das schon jemand?
Nee. Ich finde es furchtbar.
Warum?
Weil es so glattert ist. Und du kriegst immer, wenn du irgendwas machst.
Also es ist so ein Git-Browser, könnte man sagen. Also ein Git-Gui gibt es ja inzwischen eine ganze Menge.
Und Mercurial.
Was ist denn dein Lieblings Git-Browser?
Ja, ich bin Nutella.
Von Laulon. Oder wie auch immer der sich ausspricht. Also du nutzt da auch so einen dieser Forks. L-A-U-L-L-O-N.
Ich benutze tatsächlich Tauer hauptsächlich, obwohl ich GitX eigentlich besser finde.
Der macht eigentlich einen ganz ordentlichen Fork. Dieses SourceTree ist mir viel zu glatt. Vor allen Dingen, was ich schlimm finde an SourceTree ist, du drückst irgendwo so ein Toolbar-Button, um eine Aktion aufzulösen. Das Erste, was du bekommst, ist ein Sheet. Du kriegst immer einen Dialog vorgeknallt, um irgendetwas zu tun. Er tut es nicht einfach, sondern er knallt dir dann noch ein Sheet vor. Bei GitX ist es sehr schön, du markierst irgendwie einen Commit. Und dann sagst du, mach jetzt das mit dem Commit. Du hast irgendwie einen Branch. In diesem Branch markierst du einen Commit. Du drückst auf den Cherry-Pick-Button. Also nimm mir diesen Commit und pack mir den auf den anderen Branch. Und dann macht er das. Und wenn du das gleiche aber unter Source Tree machst, mal abgesehen davon, dass er kein Cherry-Picking kann, dann kriegst du als erstes dieses Sheet. Und in diesem Sheet musst du dann in der Tabelle, die in dem Sheet drin ist, deinen komischen Commit auswählen, um dann die Aktion zu machen, die du vorher schon angewählt hast. Wo du vorher schon den Commit angewählt hättest. Also das ist völlig brain dead. Das ist völlig brain dead, dieses Programm. Das geht gar nicht.
Also Tool der Wahl, Git X sagen hier alle.
Ich benutze halt wie gesagt noch Tower, das ist halt kostenpflichtig.
Und ist, also Git X fand ich eigentlich auch cool, aber ich hatte dann irgendwann mal einen Stand erwischt, wo es nur noch gecrashed ist und so. Und dann hab ich irgendwie keinen Bock mehr auf diese Fork-Scheiße gehabt, weil der Originalauto hat es halt irgendwann abendet. Dann gab es irgendwie einen, der es weitergemacht hat und dann hat der aufgehört und dann gab es noch einen, der weitergemacht hat und irgendwann...
Hier, ich schmeiß mal den Link in den Chat, wo ich die Version hier hab, die ich benutze und mit der bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden.
Hast du das selbst gebaut oder von der Seite geladen?
Von der Seite, ja, anfänglich noch selbst gebaut, aber dann irgendwann nur noch von der Seite geladen.
Achso, die Version, die nimmst du sicher auch, die L-Version?
Die ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Ist auch einer der ältesten, OS X Klein, der ist schon ganz cool. Welcher? Dieser geht X. Tauer ist halt auch nicht schlecht, aber eigentlich muss man auch ehrlich sagen, kann er jetzt auch nicht viel, Dinge besser als jetzt...
Ja und man muss ja bezahlen, ne?
Ist nicht, aber...
Inzwischen, weil diese Atlaschen... Atlaschen, die Firma, die diesen Mercurial-Webseite da macht, Bitbucket heißt die, glaub ich. Bitbucket und die machen diesen komischen, das ist ihr eigentliches Geschäft, so einen Issue-Tracker, Jira heißt der.
Zu gut, leider.
Das ist die Firma. Ich auch, leider. Also diese Firma Atlaschen, die diesen Jira macht und den Bitbucket gehört, die haben sich jetzt noch das Source-Tri da zugekauft. Und seitdem ist es umsonst.
Wieso kann ich das jetzt nicht in meinen Application folgen?
Aber es ist zum Mercurial machen, es ist ganz okay. Weil zum Mercurial gibt es halt als Alternative nur dieses Merky, was ich nie so richtig zum Funktionieren gekriegt hab. Ja, leider.
Ich hab noch einen Nachtrag zur letzten Sendung. Da hab ich ja hier so abgerantet über das garstige Fehlverhalten von iCloud, dass er mir die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Passwortabfragen um die Ohren geworfen hat und meint, mein Account wäre nicht verifiziert und ich könnte mir doch jetzt eine Verification-Mail schicken und das hat er dann alles nicht gemacht und so weiter. Das war alles ganz furchtbar. Noch während der Sendung kam dann das 10.7.3-Update, was diesen Fehler weggemacht hat. Nicht, dass keine Probleme bleiben, aber grundsätzlich funktioniert das jetzt so weit an der Stelle, wie es mich genervt hat, auf jeden Fall. Ansonsten so mit iCloud, ich weiß nicht, ich höre so die Developer fluchen alle. Also alle, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, so wie ist denn das, hier baut doch mal Sync gegenüber iCloud ein. Die meinten halt so, naja, funktioniert alles nicht so richtig, gibt Probleme. Und dann vor allem, wenn du halt so, keine Ahnung, hier so eine App hast, die dann eben auch so in Accounts nachschauen soll, dann darfst du halt auch keine Passwörter ablegen in iCloud. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es halt auch kein Keychain-Sharing so über iCloud. Da fragt man sich, okay, da darf ich nicht. Und da kann ich nicht, was ist hier so der Pfad in die Zukunft eigentlich? Davon gibt es natürlich dann auch immer keine Antwort. Das ist schon alles irgendwie so ein bisschen bekloppt. Aber zumindest kann ich jetzt so diese Migrationsphase noch ein bisschen aussitzen, indem ich halt jetzt MobileMe und iCloud quasi parallel benutze.
Also ich kann zu iCloud nur sagen aus der Entwicklerperspektive, es ist eigentlich kein Mittel für ein echtes Syncing, sondern alles, was man damit machen kann, meiner Meinung nach, ist ein paar Preferences wegzuspeichern. So nach der Art soll jetzt meine Direct Messages so rum oder so rum sein. Und ich kann halt Dokumente wegspeichern, und zwar komplette Dokumente, aber so irgendwie Daten sinnvoll einzeln zu synken, funktioniert auf...
Core Data geht noch gar nicht, oder?
Doch, Core Data funktioniert irgendwie, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich nix Core Data. Also wenn es irgent geht, kein Core Data. Das ist so dermaßen schlimm, dieses Core Data. Das will man einfach nicht mit der Kneifzange anfassen. Das größte Problem an Core Data ist, dass es nicht richtig multi-threaded, beziehungsweise... Also ich muss ein bisschen ausholen. Also bei Coco gibt es eine Möglichkeit, sein Datenmodell an das Interface zu binden heißt es. Also man kann den Interface-Elementen sagen, wenn hier was passiert, dann ändert doch bitte mal das und das im Datenmodell. Das funktioniert relativ gut. Was man allerdings wissen muss, diese Bindings funktionieren nur auf dem Main-Thread. Das ist alles schön, wenn ich auch mein Core-Data-Modell nur auf dem Main-Thread verändere. Sobald ich aber versuche, mein Core-Data-Modell auf einem anderen Thread als dem Main-Thread zu verändern, bricht das große Chaos los, weil nämlich diese Bindings aus dem anderen Thread versuchen, die Oberfläche zu manipulieren, was sie aber nicht dürfen, weil diese Bindings nur auf dem Main-Thread funktionieren. Es nennt sich Managed Object Context. Also ein Managed Object Context ist eine Art Bereich, in dem Objekte leben, die eine Beziehung zu Core-Data haben und die dann per Datenbank auf die Platte gespeichert werden. Und ich muss aber pro Thread, den ich benutze, einen Managed Object Context für mein Core-Data benutzen. Und diese Managed Object Context können aber nur miteinander kommunizieren, indem sie Daten auf Platte schreiben. Das heißt, wenn ich von einem Background-Thread mein Core-Data-Modell ändern will, muss ich es in einem anderen Kontext machen. Der Kontext muss seine Daten speichern. Auf dem Main-Thread muss ich die Daten aus der Datenbank wieder laden, um dann die veränderten Datenbanken in meiner UI anzeigen zu können. Oder man hätte auch gleich sagen können, es ist ein Major Pain in the ass.
Teilweise hat man auch das Gefühl, dass die iOS-Appi an der macOS-Appi vorbeizieht, oder?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, die macOS-Appi...
Das ist im Augenblick ein reines Coco-Dink und das hast du nicht auf dem iPhone. Die Bindings sind super eigentlich.
Die Bindings sind eigentlich gut oder wären eigentlich gut, wenn sie thread-safe wären. Das sind sie aber nicht. Ja, fast immer.
Aber wenn man Bindings auch nicht direkt nutzt, um sofort gleich irgendwas in die Datenbank zu pappen oder sowas, ich hab mit Bindings durchaus auf dem Desktop schon die dreieinhalb Male, wo ich was gemacht habe, relativ schnell sinnvolle Sachen damit machen kann. Das ist eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Ich sag ja nicht, dass Bindings prinzipiell eine schlechte Idee sind. Also was eine prinzipiell schlechte Idee ist, dass Bindings nur auf dem Main-Thread funktionieren. Aber ansonsten sind sie eigentlich eine schöne Sache. Das Problem ist, dass dieses ganze Core-Data irgendwie nicht so richtig in dieser Welt, der ich hab mehr als einen Thread, lebt. Das ist das eigentliche Problem da dran. Also das ist einfach... Und man denkt, naja, da machst du hier noch ein bisschen, machst du da noch ein bisschen. Und irgendwann kämpft dein Programm nur noch mit Core-Data. Und das ist, wenn ich wirklich alles nur auf Main-Thread mache, meine ganzen Objekte nur da verändere und auch das Objektmodell nicht allzu groß ist, dann mag das gehen. Aber spätestens wenn man was ändert, dann muss man das wieder migrieren zur nächsten Version. Und dann klappt das wieder bei einer bestimmten Anzahl von Usern nicht. Dann verlieren die ihre Dokumente und so weiter. Also das will man alles nicht haben. Core-Data will man nicht haben. Also es gibt Leute, die sagen, man ist blöd, wenn man nicht Core-Data benutzt. Ich sage, man ist blöd, wenn man es benutzt. Das ist, glaube ich, möglicherweise auch schon ein Glaubenskrieg geworden. Couch-Deb.
Couch-Deb.
F-T-B.
F-T-B oder wie das heißt?
Ehrlich gesagt hängt das sehr stark davon ab, was du machen willst. Ja, doch. So wie Core-Data nun mal einfach keine One-Size-fits-all-Lösung ist, auch nicht sein kann, aber es sein will, wird von Apple so angepriesen, aber es funktioniert nicht so. So ist auch jede andere Lösung nicht so eine One-Size-fits-all-Lösung. Sprichst du viel mit dem Netzwerk, kommen da viele Daten runter? Oder tippst du ein Dokument und speicherst das sowieso nur als Text ab? Das sind halt so Fragen.
Na ja, so für den kleinen... Wo eine P-List zu klein oder zu langsam für wird, wo es dann anfängt, wo man ein bisschen serialisiert Daten irgendwie wegspeichern will.
Also es gibt ja immer noch NS-Keyed-Archiver, was zumindest dann, wenn die Sachen, die du speicherst, nicht zu groß werden, super ist. Weil das ist einfach jetzt, keine Ahnung, es ist älter als iOS. Und es funktioniert einfach auch gut.
P-Lists werden auf dem iPhone auch im Binary-Format gleich gespeichert, oder?
Du kannst P-Lists aber auch als XML speichern.
Ja, auf dem iPhone, ich komme eh nicht anders dran als mit meinem iPhone. Ja, also ich meine, dass ich... oder?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, meistens.
Auf Mac OS ist es ja okay, da sind es wirklich P-Lists, wenn du die selber speicherst.
Ja, aber eine P-List ist halt, kannst du nur bestimmte Objekte reintun. Also im Prinzip wie ein JSON, nur dass es ein anderes Format ist. Während einer NS-Archiver, da kannst du halt beliebige Objekte archivieren, wenn du halt...
Die entsprechende Protokolle unterstützt.
Tim, ich muss mal sagen, der map hat recht.
Wo, wo, was, wie, haben wir das verpasst?
Ja, jetzt wollen mir die Leute erklären, dass man doch diese Pfaffsternchen nicht benutzen kann, nur um sich Dinge zu merken. Na ja, immer alle glauben, wenn ich was faffe, dass ich es dann ganz toll finde und dass ich dann alle kuschel und abschlecke und keine Ahnung, was sie sich noch alles so vorstellen. Meinetwegen können sie das ja auch denken, aber ganz ehrlich, ich meine, ich notiere mir natürlich auch tolle Tweets, aber ich notiere mir nicht nur tolle Tweets. Manchmal notiere ich mir auch nicht so tolle Tweets, ich will sie mir halt einfach merken. Und natürlich kann ich jetzt wieder irgendeinen anderen Dienst und hinten rum und Instapaper und Read-It-Later und keine Ahnung und hier ein Book-Mathlet und so. Aber meine Erfahrung ist einfach mit dem ganzen Scheiß, ich will einfach ein System, weitgehend vor allem in sich selbst benutzen, weil dann bricht mir wieder irgendeine Funktionalität in dem anderen Teil weg oder dann stehe ich da. Und das prangere ich an.
Komplexe Systeme neigen zu komplexen Fehlverhalten.
Tim prang hat an, dass er die Angst hat, dass ein Problem eintreten würde, was aber zur Zeit noch nicht existiert.
Diese Probleme sind schon sehr häufig eingetreten am Internet.
Du weißt doch, wie viele Probleme Tim so hat.
Was glaubst du, was du für Probleme hast, wenn mal irgendwie eine von deinen Lieblingsseiten den Spagat macht?
Dann aber... GitHub. Ich hab auch noch...
Da kenn ich einige Firmen, die dann pleitegehen würden.
Du hast ja alles noch dezentralisiert.
Du hast ja noch sein Auf-Live-System drauf.
Ich hätte ja auch noch mal so einen kleinen Absacker am Rande. Jetzt wo ich ja so ein Kindl hab, lese ich ja auch immer ganz viel Bücher. Und irgendwie habe ich mit Freude festgestellt, dass immer mehr Leute Bücher einfach so schreiben und die selber auch verkaufen ohne Amazon und ohne alles so dazwischen. Und die gleichen PDF und Mobi und E-Book. EPUB und alles DRM-frei. Und das halt so für kleine Münzen im Web verkaufen. Da wollte ich mal drei, die ich gerade so gelesen habe und ganz gut finde, mal der breiten Öffentlichkeit vorstellen. Zum einen ist es hier, ich paste die Links gleich mal in den Chat. Das ist ein Ruby-spezifisches Buch, das heißt Working with Unix Processes. Und weil Ruby natürlich vor allen Dingen bekannt ist als so Web-Programmiersprache, vergessen die Leute, dass es auch eine super coole Systemen-Programmiersprache ist. Also dass der Perl-Ersatz auch als Perl-Ersatz sehr gut geeignet ist. Und das erklärt halt so ein bisschen wie...
Das ist ein Ruby-Buch und da kommt nicht Ruby im Titel vor, sondern Working with Unix Processes.
Aber es ist tatsächlich ein ganz cooles Buch. Und das zweite Buch, was ich jetzt gerade schon erwähnt habe, so ein bisschen abfällig, aber es ist trotzdem ganz interessant, heißt speedybook.com, die Webseite. Da geht es darum, dass mal sich einer die Mühe gemacht hat, dieses speedy-Protokoll, was jetzt eben so als potenzieller Nachfolger von HTTP oder Superset...
Du meinst, das ist dieses Google-Dings, ne?
Warum bei dieser Schreibweise denke ich immer an eine Partei, die so eine rote Image hat?
Naja, also ich bin jetzt ja wie auch immer...
Das, was man sich halt immer so denkt.
Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn man mal... Wenn man das mal gut zusammengefasst erfassen will, was da so die Gedanken sind und die Konzepte, weil die sind eigentlich auch jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig neu, die sind halt bloß bei SPDY alle mal zusammengebracht, kann man dieses Buch durchaus mal lesen. Und da ich mich jetzt gerade...
Ich denke, die sind auch alle nicht allzu lang, oder?
Genau, die sind alle so 100 Seiten, 120 Seiten, kann man schön mal schnell wegcrunchen und sind halt auch alle nicht so wahnsinnig teuer. Und dann das letzte Buch, weil ich mich ja gerade beruflich mit der Datenbank, auch in der NoSQL Key-Value-Datenbank namens RIAC, beschäftige. Hat auch ein Bekannter von, oder ja, in der Berliner Internetszene sowieso bekannt, Matthias Meyer, auch ein Buch geschrieben zum Thema RIAC. Und das ist auch echt ganz gut geworden. Und das Coole, was ich daran eben finde, wie gesagt, DRM-frei, vielleicht alle Formate, du weißt halt, die Kohle, die du da überweist, die geht halt einfach auch zu 100% an den Autor selbst. Zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt Leute bei Amazon, was ich heute auch erfahren hab, ihre Bücher hochladen, da gibt es dann so Modelle, wo Amazon 70% einfach nimmt und dir nur 30 auszahlt. Bei iBooks ist es ja glaube ich so, dass die Apple-Jungs auch nur 30 nehmen. Aber zum Beispiel Amazon, ist das wohl so, dass Amazon erst mal 70 nimmt.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht mal so, noch nicht vier. Ich glaube, das gibt es nicht. Also ich hab mich neulich mal informiert bei Platten, also so CDs, da ist wohl das Übliche, dass der Künstler 20% kriegt ungefähr. Von dem, was nachher drauf steht.
Ja und jetzt sagen hier, welche im Chat 24 Dollar für 150 Seiten ist nicht so günstig, aber... Nö, ist das auch nicht. Ich fände das okay, dafür, dass die Leute... Also ich weiß halt, der hat sich jetzt ein paar Monate da auf den Arsch gesetzt und ein cooles Buch geschrieben und der kriegt halt jetzt das Geld direkt sozusagen ohne jemanden dazwischen und ich finde das...
Der Buch wird ja nicht dadurch besser, dass es länger ist.
Ja, das außerdem.
Ich kenne den auch, der hat da echt dran gearbeitet.
Das ist bei den anderen auch so, das Speedy Book zum Beispiel, das ist echt, das geht auch sehr tief sozusagen. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur so mal, ach übrigens, ich hab mir mal das kurz angeguckt, so und so sieht das aus, sondern das ist schon... Gut, ihr könnt glaube ich auch bei denen sogar Free-Samples klicken und so weiter. Es gibt sogar bei dem Working with Unix eine Geld-Zurückversprechung. Das heißt, wenn ihr eben schreibt und sagt, das Buch ist scheiße, dann kriegt ihr euer Geld auch wieder. Also das ist halt, ich finde das auf jeden Fall echt sehr viel entspannter und cooler und wünsche mir mehr von diesen Indie-Books und kleinen Books, die sich so mal ein Thema kümmern und das in geschmeidigen 150, 200 Seiten abarbeiten.
Aber wenn das ePub stimmt, man bezahlt ja auch nicht pro Seite.
dass das ordentlich lesen lässt.
Ja, also auf dem Kindle super, auf dem iPad super, auf dem PDF super. Also die drei habe ich jetzt zumindest auf Kindle und in dem Zusammenhang.
Es gibt jetzt eine ePub-Anwendung für den Mac im App Store. Die heißt ganz einfach Buckel. Die ist jetzt nicht besonders großartig, würde ich sagen. Also so auf den ersten Blick vermisse ich da keine Ahnung, so Cover-Previews für die Library oder sowas. Man ist ja irgendwie schon so ein bisschen verwöhnt. Das ist da halt alles nur ein Text. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, man kann es halt überhaupt mal lesen. Also das ist eine App, die irgendwie das halbwegs ordentlich macht. Die gibt es da irgendwie für ein paar Dollar. Und wenn man halt ePubs rumliegen hat, und die vielleicht auch meistens auf seinem, keine Ahnung, iPad zum Beispiel liest, dann kann man das halt jetzt auch irgendwie auf Mac ganz ordentlich verwalten. Also unspektakulär, aber so erstmal ganz okay. Das wäre doch was für dich.
Wolltest du mal Buckel huckeln?
Tja, durch den Kindle bin ich jetzt echt mobi-versaut. Ich hab ja, ePub weiß ich gar nicht, wo ich das mir angucken soll, groß. Auf dem iPad habe ich ja die Kindle ab, wo dann auch meine Mobis quasi drin sind. Ich bin jetzt voll zum proprietären Amazon-E-Bookjünger geworden.
Ist das Mobiformat deiner Meinung nach dein Vorteil?
Das ist mir total egal. Ich kann das Buch lesen auf meinem Kindle. Das ist das, worum ich mich vor allen Dingen in der Hinsicht kümmere. Und ich kann es auf meinem iPad lesen. Und ich hab PDF sowieso für den Desktop. Prinzipiell fände ich Epoch wäre schon besser, aber momentan habe ich gar keinen Bedarf dafür. Skandal. Jetzt ist es raus. Aber es gibt glaube ich allen so, die einen Kindle haben, würde ich ja mal behaupten.
Ich hab nur Horror-Stories bei den Kindle.
Die haben deine App ein bisschen üblicher gemacht.
Also gerade wenn du da so ein bisschen zwischen den Stores hin und her, dann willst du mal in den USA was kaufen und hast irgendwelche Subscriptions und dann musst du irgendwie dein Kindle wieder umstellen und dann löschen sie diese Subscriptions, wenn du dann wechselst und so.
Ich kaufe ja sehr wenig Bücher bei Amazon selber. Ich kaufe ja tatsächlich eher sowas bei O'Reilly und so. Und dann schieb ich, also du kannst ja dein E-Book dann auf dein Kindle mailen quasi. Und so mach ich das hauptsächlich. Also ich hab auf Amazon direkt glaube ich vielleicht einsmal gekauft.
Ja, also da stimme ich dir vollkommen zu. Wenn man jetzt nicht bei Amazon kauft, dann ist der Kindle wahrscheinlich ganz gut. Aber so bei Amazon kaufen und mit dem E-Book Store, da bin ich auch nicht so für. Also ich würde da zwar, hab da auch schonmal so testweise was gekauft, aber erstens finde ich da nie was interessantes.
Ja, das ist auch so das Ding, genau.
Das ist also völlig scheiße der Store. Also dass das überhaupt Store heißt. Gerade Apple, die so total anal fixiert sind, was so Store betrifft. Was sie da für einen Aufwand treiben mit ihren scheiß Stores. Und dann trauen die sich irgendwie so einen Dreck. Das verstehen die. Also die Experience ist wirklich schlecht.
Ja, es gibt halt auch wirklich so von den ganzen coolen Büchern, die man noch so haben will, die es jetzt nicht eh schon bei O'Reilly oder PrakProk oder Manning oder sonst wo gibt. Die kriegst du dann halt auch nicht bei Amazon oder im iBook Store. Zum Beispiel die ganzen Tannenbaum-Bücher hätte ich ja zum Beispiel auch statt irgendwie diese tausend Seiten-Schinken, hätt ich ja auch gerne handlich, auf dem Kindl gibt's aber nicht. Skandal.
Muss man sich wieder die Raubkopierer-E-Books runterladen.
Die das gescannt haben, oder wie?
So Jungs, haben wir's?
Eigentlich wollte ich ja noch ein bisschen mit Huckel über Rails reden. Über meine Rails erfahren.
Dann müsste man wieder mehr über Ruby reden, ja.
Weil ich hab jetzt ja, ich hab... Ich hab ja so angefangen, ich sitze ja immer noch an dieser Tapsync-App, hab ich ja schon erzählt, was einen Haufen Sprachen involviert. Also man braucht halt die Extension für einen Browser, die wird im JavaScript geschrieben. Objective-C auf dem iOS-Device und dann halt bauen wir noch irgendwas für einen Server. Und da hatte ich so einen Prototypen-Server in PHP geschrieben. Wollte jetzt aber was haben, was im Zweifelsfall skaliert.
Erlang!
Und darum habe ich dann gedacht, so, ne, das möchte ich...
Etwas, was auch UTF-8 kann, Mann.
Erlang kann kein UTF-8.
Oh Gott.
It's just a list of bytes.
Das ist genau das Problem.
Nee, es kann tatsächlich Unicode und so auch.
Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt dafür... Da habe ich dann gedacht, das will ich mal, das ganze Zeug, dann probiere ich mal den hippen Scheiß hier Heroku. Ich hoffe, das ist noch hip. Und pack das dahin und mach das dann mit Rail. Also hab's am Anfang angefangen hier mit Sinatra, mit diesem Toolkit, weil ich brauche wirklich eine billige Restful-AP. Ich will da kein Interface, ich will da gar nichts drauf haben. Hab auch gedacht, ich knalle da hinten Couch-DB hinter und bin erst mal richtig schön gegen die Wand gefahren.
Da habe ich übrigens noch einen Tipp für dich gerade. Also genau zwischen Sinatra, was ja so das richtig, das low-leveligste, einfachste ist, um meinen Web-Server hochzufahren und Rails, dem full-blown Toolkit mit allem, was nicht bald drauf die Bäume ist, gibt's noch eins dazwischen, das heißt Padrino. Das basiert auf Sinatra, bringt aber so ein bisschen mehr gepolsterte Hebel mit, um irgendeine Couch-Stäbe oder sowas ran zu flanschen.
Jetzt hab ich's alles schon in Rails gebaut. Jetzt ist es, also war auch nichts Großartiges. Ich hab mich dafür erstmal mit so einem, hab ich mit so einem Videotutorial angefangen. Wie hießen das?
Na jetzt verlink's nicht, wenn's schlecht war.
Ich kann ja einfach darüber erzählen, wie es war. Und dann kann jeder seine... Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich guck noch mal. Und das ist so ein Videotutorial. Und der fängt dann an mit Textmails. ruby.railstutorials.org ist die Adresse. Und was halt schön ist, gerade so am Anfang, man kriegt so diese ganzen Tricks, die eigentlich nirgendwo jemand so richtig aufschreibt, aber die so nebenbei abfallen, kriegt man ganz gut mit. Also wie arbeitet da jemand mit dem Zeug? Der Nachteil ist, dass der entwickelt quasi so einen Twitter-Clone und naja, ab dem fünften Kapitel, da passiert jetzt nicht mehr so sagenhaft viel Neues. Also das ist dann, dann wartest du noch auf die dreieinhalb neuen Informationsstückchen, die da sind, guckst dir den ganzen Scheiß an und sagst mir, okay, jetzt leg ich zum zwanzigsten Mal einen Controller an und irgendwann hat man es dann halt auch raus. Das fand ich nicht ganz so gut. Das Zweite ist, ich fand's, also ich hatte auch nach der Hälfte des, dieses Video-Tutorials nicht das Gefühl, wirklich jetzt selber was machen zu können. Weil es ist immer so, ja, und dann legen wir hier, da schreibst du die und die Zeile rein, dann gibt's halt irgendwie so, Rails ist ja voll von Magic, die man einfach wissen muss. Ja, und das kann man hier weglassen, das braucht man eigentlich gar nicht, aber wir machen es jetzt trotzdem hin und so. Und man weiß dann nicht, wie es funktioniert. Wenn es irgendwann mal schief geht, geht es auch immer gleich richtig schief. Also dann hängst du irgendwie so relativ tief drinnen. Es gibt für jeden Scheiß direkt einen Operator, den Orgleich-Operator zum Beispiel, den ich ja sehr schön finde, den Oder-Zuweisungs-Operator. Alles furchtbar praktisch und man kann tolle Sachen damit machen, aber es ist schon eine ziemliche Einstiegshürde.
Aber Rails ist halt auch so, die machen halt alles, was Ruby erlaubt zu machen, machen die auch.
Ja, und manchmal auch bloß aus Prinzip, einfach weil es geht.
Ja, durchaus. Es ist schon ganz, wie heißt das Schloss von Harry Potter? Ja, ganz Hogwarts in einem Web-Framework. Das Hogwarts der Web-Frameworks, genau.
Und alles, ja stimmt. Und hier noch ein bisschen Magie und dann noch ein bisschen Zucker obendrauf. Und da, wenn du von Programmierung keine Ahnung hast, brauchst du dir keine Sorgen darum zu machen. Aber wenn du es ein bisschen anders haben willst, dann geht es halt gleich gar nicht mehr. Was ich, also zum Beispiel, wieso, also es klappt jetzt, es funktioniert jetzt alles, dass ich immer ein JSON-Objekt zurückgebe, aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung wieso.
Aber das ist halt tatsächlich bei Rails bei mir auch am Anfang so gewesen, dass ich, also so hab ich überhaupt so Bock gehabt auf Web-Programmierung, Backend-Programmierung, weil mit diesem Rails war es dann halt so das erste Mal, okay, ich kann jetzt mal hier erstmal was wuppen, was auch einigermaßen brauchbar aussieht und was irgendwie sinnvolle Funktionen hat. Und ich weiß zwar nicht, was es tut oder warum es das tut, aber es ist schon mal da. Darüber konnte ich dann halt tatsächlich immer so hier mal ein bisschen am Knopf drehen und ausprobieren, immer weiter reingleiten, ohne jetzt...
Das stimmt, also ich hatte jetzt schon relativ konkret das Bild im Kopf, was ich gerne haben möchte. Ich wollte auch keine Webseite, was ja sozusagen, ich hab eigentlich Android vorbei entwickelt, an dem eigentlichen Einsatzzweck. Insofern stimmt das auch alles schon, aber ich fand das dann alles nicht so total trivial. Was halt wirklich cool ist, das muss man mal sagen, also was ich mir jetzt echt angewöhnt habe damit mit dem Projekt, das hat er nämlich auch in diesem Tutorial sehr schön gemacht, mit Testing, so dieses jeden Scheißdreck testen. Macht sich natürlich gerade super, wenn man eine API schreibt, dann hab ich es auch so gemerkt. Am Anfang hab ich immer noch einen Curl-Befehl gemacht, um das auch testen zu können, also so auf der Kommandozeile und zu sehen, was kommt. Und irgendwann hab ich mir relativ konsequent angewöhnt, immer zuerst einen Test zu schreiben und das dann zuerst zu implementieren.
Das ist auch echt einer der größten Verdienste von diesem Rails oder dieser Ruby-Community und das merkst du dann auch, wenn du dann so mit anderen Entwicklern sprichst, hast du hier irgendein Problem, hast du einen Test dafür? Muss ich jetzt nochmal in die Datenbank und die Werte wieder zurücksetzen? Und das ist auf jeden Fall ganz cool und auch eigentlich ganz smooth integriert, dass du halt mit Integration-Tests und Unit-Tests da eigentlich wirklich so deinen Back-End komplett abdeckeln kannst.
Ja, wobei für Integration-Tests brauchst du schon eine ganze, da brauchst du dich, also ich hab das dann mit A-Spec gemacht, also die ganzen, das gibt da ganze Geteste.
Noch mehr Magic.
Noch mehr Magic? Naja, ich meine, Kukumba, wie wird es ausgesprochen? Das ist, wo man anfängt... Geschichten. Geschichten aufzuschreiben. Ich meine, das ist, ich hätte gerne eine ARPi, die Folgendes macht, oh nee. Also da finde ich, ging A-Spec noch so halbwegs, also es ist zwar jetzt auch viel Magic, aber bis ich denen beigebracht habe, dass sie... Es war dann auch wieder, es ist dann so, ja, dann macht man einen Integration-Test und ich wollte halt, dass ein bestimmter Controller eine Exception wirft, die ich dann sauber abfange und die dann mir in JSON eine Fehlermeldung ausgibt. Und der konnte halt nicht vernünftig, sobald halt die Exception geflogen ist, hat A-Spec die standardmäßig abgefallen. Und da musste ich jetzt irgendwie Web-Rats installieren, also mal wieder so ein Jam hinterher schieben oder sowas. Und jetzt bist du eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur dabei, irgendwie zu suchen, wie kriege ich das hin, dass ich da einen echten Request machen kann. Bei dem auch, nee, genau, HTTP-Authentifizierung war. Ich wollte HTTP-Authentifizierung. Und dann, ja, da musst du nur hier das Jam installieren. Und, okay, dann installiert man noch ein Jam. Und irgendwann hat man dann 320 Jams. Und braucht eigentlich wahrscheinlich von den meisten, höchstens vier Zeilen, Funktionalität. Aber weil ich jetzt nicht besser weiß, wie es geht, halt das ganze Jam da hinten drin.
Das kommt halt alles so mit der Zeit. Ja, das weiß man auch. Irgendwann merkt man, dass man auch ohne R-Spec oder irgendwelchen Magic-Helpers auch ganz gut Test schreiben kann und so. Aber am Anfang ist halt so...
Was ich allerdings auch sagen muss, ist so, ich bin ja ein echt großer Freund von vernünftigen EDEs mit guter Autocompletion. Und all die Ruby- und Rails-Fans sagen ja, ne, totaler Schwachsinn. Text-Made mit hier irgendwie mit ein paar vernünftigen Makros. Und alles ist gut. Und wo ich... Und also in Bezug auf Ruby und Rails sehe ich es ein. Da ist definitiv Text-Made hier diesen ganzen... Also ich hab jetzt hier mit diesen Ruby-Mine rumgespielt, mit dieser IDE. Und auf der PHP-Ebene halte ich die für wirklich ungeschlagen. Und die sind auch so in Java die Standard-IDE. Also wenn man irgendwann mal mitgekriegt hat, dass Eclipse-Scheiße ist. Aber für Ruby oder für Rails taugen die wirklich einen Scheißdreck. Also kriegen keine vernünftige Autocompletion hin. Und sie sind unglaublich langsam. Und Text-Made ist schnell, hat die Abkürzung da, die man braucht.
Findest du Text-Made schnell?
Wenn dein Projekt nicht so richtig groß ist, ist das okay.
Die haben halt für jeden Scheißdreck irgendwelche Abkürzungen. Du musst die halt kennen. Aber so ein Symbol auf Eigenschaft, also quasi in einem Haschen, Symbol auf Eigenschaft, Referenz, ist halt Doppelpunkt, Tab, dann kannst du anfangen zu tippen, dann tippst du nochmal Tab, dann hast du Anführungsstriche, dann tippst du nochmal Tab, dann bist du in den Anführungsstrichen drin und dann hast du noch ein Komma hinten dran. Das kannst du halt alles so mit zweimal kurz Tab drücken und ein bisschen tippen, kriegt man das alles relativ gut hin, wenn man es irgendwann mal drauf hat. Und das habe ich jetzt bei keiner anderen Sprache so gesehen. Also gerade diesen Gleichzeichen, Größerzeichen-Pfeil, der ist ja wirklich auch auf einer amerikanischen Tastatur quasi untippbar. Und das ist irgendwie so, geht wahrscheinlich nur auf einer japanischen Tastatur vernünftig, oder liegen die bestimmt nebeneinander. Tim möchte fertig werden.
Das Ding ist halt auch, IDE macht bei so einer Sprache wie Ruby nur so begrenzt sind, weil die so hochdynamisch, metaprogrammatisch ist, dass zum Beispiel so Refactoring-Features da echt schwer irgendwie verstehen überhaupt, was da zu refactoren ist. Und deswegen, ja, sind die IDE's da für Ruby wahrscheinlich auch einfach nicht.
Und dann diese ganzen Domainspecific Languages und so. Und da bauen wir noch ne Sprache und da, oh, ich fand's eher so. Aber Tim guckt mich müde an. Ich glaub, der möchte nicht, dass wir hier noch über irgendwas weiter reden.
Ich will euch jetzt nicht unbedingt in die Parade fahren, aber ich hab schon seit einer Weile den Eindruck, man könnte jetzt die Sendung langsam dem Ende übergeben.
Wir haben noch nicht über Kalender geredet.
Und über Nokia und Microsoft.
So ein Scheiß guckt mir nicht in die Sendung.
Hochdynamisch, metaprogrammatisch.
Hat der der Typ auch die sechs Sekunden von mir aus der Sendung eins gepostet? Der hat da so einen Audio-Ausschnitt gemacht, wo ich genau das schon in der Sendung eins sage, was wir hier heute über das Adressbuch erzählt haben.
Ja, ich hab den Link hier. Was ist damit?
Na, spiel doch mal ab, dann hören wir's mal. Hauptsache, der hat jetzt da keinen...
Da muss ich hier erstmal... Ist der auch im Chat irgendwie der Link? Ich paste hier immer selber rein. Dann kann ich ihn hier schnell mal auf dem anderen Rechner...
Hast du die Schnell-Aus-Taste?
Mit Audiobu. So, was soll das jetzt dokumentieren?
Hören wir, dann weiß ich nicht genau. Ich hab's ja auch nicht gehört. Das muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Das war der falsche Sound-Ausgang.
Oh Gott, das wird bestimmt laut.
Wollen wir das auch runterladen?
Nein, das heißt Apple ist evil.
Wie kann man diesen Scheiß nicht runterladen bei Audiobu? Ist doch alles Fickenscheiß. Mann oh Mann. Also nochmal. Zurückscroll.
Jetzt muss ich's mal sagen, jetzt kann ich's ja machen. Tausende von Zuhörern, Apple ist evil. Vielleicht hinter Google oder davor schon. Weiß ich noch nicht so richtig.
Mittlerweile ist Google deutlich eviler als Apple, oder?
Nee, alle großen Firmen jenseits von ein paar Milliarden Dollar sind evil.
Na, Google ist nicht eviler geworden, es ist nur unfähiger geworden.
Na auch eviler.
Es kommt immer drauf an, wie viel Macht so eine Firma hat. Microsoft, die sind ja inzwischen voll zahm. Weil die können gar keine Hebel mehr ansetzen.
Ich glaube, nach hinten raus sind die immer noch richtig Arschlöcher. Ich meine, wenn die so mit HTC oder Samsung darüber verhandeln, wie viel Geld die für Android dafür rüberrücken müssen, dass er Android weiterhin nutzen dürfte, ohne verklagt zu werden.
Ja, aber zum Not nutzt deren Scheiß dann halt einfach keiner.
Weil sie die Patente haben und so was.
Ja gut, aber dann sind sie ja nicht Arschlöcher, sondern haben sie ja vielleicht doch mal dafür bezahlt oder investiert und so. Also ich meine, Apple macht das ja genauso.
Ich glaube bei den Verhandlungen sind die schulzsinnige Arschlöcher.
Die machen das ja genauso. Und dann heuen sie auch noch um und sagen, das mit den Patenten finden wir aber nicht so gut.
Ich glaube auch die Apple-Patent-Anwälte sind ziemliche Arschlöcher.
Ja, aber die werden von Apple bezahlt.
Jaja, ich finde es deswegen nicht gut.
Es sind Anwälte.
Ja, aber ich glaube Microsoft hat auch mal ein bisschen mehr Spaß dran als...
Tim hat gerade versucht das Thema abzuwölfen. Erschöpfend zu beschreiben mit, es sind Anwälte. Ich glaube es ist ihm gelungen. Juhura, nein.
Jungs, ich bin total durch und außerdem noch krank und... Ich habe... Ja, wollt euch nicht die ganze Wahrheit gleich auf den Tisch legen. Ich werde euch gleich frustrieren. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Sendung ist verpackt. Originalverkorkt.
Von Paul Huber und Söhne?
Genau.
Insofern bleibt das nur noch in die Zukunft zu schauen auf die nächsten zwei Wochen. Ich hoffe, dass der Laden in Cupertino mal ein paar richtige News bringt. Und nicht nur diesen ganzen Quatsch.
Ist dann schon das iPad draußen? Dann haben wir die nächste Sendung.
Nein, das können wir nächstes Mal fabulieren. Die nächste Sendung ist planmäßig am 29.
Und am 7. kommt es dann.
Eine Woche später kommt es dann raus. Dann haben wir eine Woche Zeit uns Keynotes zu geben.
Vielleicht kommt da auch gar nichts.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es vielleicht.
Das kannst du ja dann glaskugelieren.
Also nächstes Mal machen wir Glaskugel. Und dann zwei Wochen später zerbrechen wir sie. Super, bis dann.
Das war's für heute.
Wir sehen uns bald wieder.